GOOD AFTERNOON RATHER TO
EVERYONE AND WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED WITH OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING --
MY NAME'S ADAM GRAY ON THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE ASSEMBLY
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE.
AND I WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE
TODAY TO THE JOINT HEARING ON
THE UTILIZATION.
OF CURRENT AND EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES TO MODERATE
ACTIVITY IN CAL FILED FOR IT TO
BE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO THANK CHAIRMAN DON IS
STAFF FOR HELPING TO PUT THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING TOGETHER --
CALIFORNIA SUFFER DEVASTATING
FIRE SEASON TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE MAGNITUDE OF
THE DESTRUCTION THAT WE WENT
WITNESS FROM THESE WILDFIRES WAS
SIMPLY.
UNBELIEVABLE.
IT WAS NOT JUST THE INTENSITY OF
THE FIRES --
BUT THE SPEED WITH WHICH THEY
SPREAD THAT SEEM TO CATCH SO
MANY PEOPLE BY SURPRISE.
BOTTOM LINE WE'RE SEEING LARGER
MORE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS TRIGGERED
DEVASTATING DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION.
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGY HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN
IMPORTANT PART.
OF PREVENTING --
AND FIGHTING WILDFIRES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA LESSEN BRACES
EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES TO NOT
ONLY REDUCE THE CATASTROPHIC
RISKS POSED BY WILD FIRE.
BUT ALSO SAVE LIVES SOME OF
THESE TECHNOLOGIES INCLUDE
DRONES SENSORS SATELLITES FIRE
MODELING WEATHER STATIONS REAL
TIME CAMERAS TO MONITOR AREAS
WITH A HIGH RISK FOR WILDFIRES.
THIS AFTERNOON WE HEAR FROM
INDIVIDUALS WHO BRING A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE ON WILD
FIRE DETECTION MONITORING.
WILD FIRE DETECTION TECHNOLOGY
ADVANCEMENTS HAVE PROGRESSED
BEYOND AN INDIVIDUAL ON LOOKOUT
TOWER ARMED WITH BINOCULARS.
I'M ENCOURAGED THAT ON THIS
FIRST FULL DAY AS GOVERNOR.
GAVIN NEWSOM ANNOUNCED EXECUTIVE
ACTIONS TO IMPROVE THE STATE'S
RESPONSE TO WILD FIRES AND OTHER
EMERGENCIES.
IN ADDITION THE GOVERNOR'S
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET --
INCLUDES NEW INVESTMENTS TO
PREVENT FIGHT ESCAPE WILD FIRES
REYES YOU RESPONSE TO LARGE
RAPIDLY SPREADING WILD FIRES
THAT THREATEN LIFE AND OR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
INVOLVES COORDINATION MULTIPLE
ENTITIES AT THE LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL LEVELS.
EACH OPERATING WITH DIFFERENT
MISSIONS AND DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS.
TODAY WE'LL HEAR PRESENTATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA --
AND CAL WE **** ABOUT HOW
CURRENT NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
ARE BEING OR MIGHT BE USED TO
PREVENT.
AND FIGHT WILDFIRES WE ALSO
LEARNED HELMER IN A DECISION
MAKERS ON HOW BEST TO RESPOND TO
SAVE LIVES AND PROPERTY FROM THE
RAVAGES OF WILDFIRES.
WE'VE ASSEMBLED SOME OF THE
GREAT SCIENTIFIC MINDS VARIOUS
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS FROM
WITHIN THE STATE WHO EDUCATE US
ON SOME OF THE NEW --
AND EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES I MUST
SAY EXCITING TECHNOLOGIES --
LASTLY WE'LL HEAR FROM
REPRESENTATIVES OF LOCAL
FIREFIGHTING COMMUNITY RELATING
TO HOW NEW AND EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES BECOME AN INTEGRAL
COMPONENT OF A MULTIFACETED
RESPONSE PLANS --
HELPING TO PROTECT FIREFIGHTERS
FIRST RESPONDERS AND OF COURSE
OUR COMMUNITIES.
WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
OUR CHAIRMAN DOT FOR HIS OPENING
REMARKS AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE TODAY.
I THANK YOU I WROTE REALLY WANT
TO THANK CHAIRMAN GREATEST STAFF
FOR HELPING US ORGANIZE IS
HEARING.
IT FOR THE WORK THAT YOU'RE
COMMITTEE IS DONE IN RESPONSE
THE DEVASTATING FIRES OVER THE
PAST COUPLE YEARS.
I THINK THE CHAIRMAN HAS A SET
THE TABLE QUITE NICELY.
A VERY GREAT SET OF TALKING
POINTS WHICH I'M NOT GONNA --
ADD ON TO YOU KNOW ANYMORE I
THINK BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE
TO PERSONALLY JUST THANK ALL THE
PANELISTS FOR BEING HERE TO DAY
TAKEN --
TIME OUT.
THE RECOVERY WORKERS FIRST
RESPOND A SINGLE PERSON WHO CAME.
OUT TO OUR HELP WHEN WE WERE
MOST IN NEED AND OF COURSE I'D
LIKE TO THANK --
THE THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR FOR BEING HERE TODAY AS WELL.
SO WITH THAT GERMAN.
IT'S ALL YEAR.
THANK CHAIRMAN.
AT THIS TIME WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO ITEM TWO ON THE AGENDA.
WE WOULD ASK --
JUST COMPUTERS --
TOM PORTER AND DIRECTOR AGAIN OR
DID SHE TO PLEASE JOIN US UP
FRONT FOR THEIR TESTIMONY
[inaudible]
START.
IT WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN WITH
THE MISS PETERS FROM THE OHIO --
WELCOME TO ALL OF YOU --
AND PROCEED WITH YOUR
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU JUST COMPUTERS WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND THE SERGEANT IS PASSING OUT
A HAND OUT RIGHT NOW THAT WE
HAVE PREPARED FOR YOU --
REALLY BUT MY ROLE TODAY IS TO
HAVE THE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF DIFFERENT
STATE AGENCIES --
INVOLVED IN WILD FIRE RESPONSE
AND JUST HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF
THE CURRENT YEAR ACTIONS THAT
WERE TAKEN RELATED TO WILDFIRES
AS WELL AS AND SOME OF THAT
BUDGET PROPOSALS RELATED
SPECIFICALLY TO WELFARE
TECHNOLOGY.
SO WHEN YOU HAVE A HAND OUT AND
IF YOU CAN TURN TO PAGE.
ONE I'M JUST HAVE A SUMMARY AS
AND THAT THE ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE
DIFFERENT STATE AGENCIES SO YOU
HAVE --
DOCTOR PORTER IN DIRECTOR GIL
DID SHE I'M FRIEND CAL FIRE AND
YES HERE WITH YOU TODAY I'M --
YES IS ROLE IN A WILDFIRE
RESPONSE IS SORT OF A HIGH LEVEL
COORDINATION --
MISSION TASKING DIFFERENT
ENTITIES --
BEING A CONDUIT FOR FEDERAL
FUNDS TO THE STATE.
I AM WHERE IS CAL FIRE IS THE
ENTITY IN THE STATE THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR DIRECTLY
RESPONDING WHEN THERE'S A FIRE
OUT CALL WE WILL COME IN A NINE
ONE ONE CALL.
ON AND CAL FIRE AND RESPONSE
CREWS WILL BE THE ONES WHO ARE
SENT OUT.
I ONCE A A FIRE IS IS PUT OUT --
AND CONTAINED THEN THE COW FIRES
ROLL SORT OF SUBSIDES IN THE
FIRE AND YES WELL I CONTINUE IN
OVERSEE RECOVERY EFFORTS.
ON IN TERMS OF WILDFIRE RECOVERY
THERE'S ALSO A NUMBER OF OTHER
STATE AGENCIES I AM JUST TO KNOW
THEY'RE NOT HERE TODAY BUT JUST
TO GIVE YOU THAT CONTEXT AND THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT
OUR NATIONAL GUARD AND PLAYS A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN.
A WELFARE RESPONSE AND
SUPPRESSION I'M BRINGING THEIR
RESOURCES AIRCRAFT AND GUARDS
PEOPLE I'M TO BEAR TO FIGHT
FIRES -- IN
ADDITION AND CAL RECYCLE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL ARE USUALLY OR OFTEN AND
INVOLVED IN THE CLEANUP
ACTIVITIES AFTER AWHILE FIRES
HAPPENED.
US DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL WILL GO IN
AND REMOVE ALL OF THE TOXIC --
A WASTE AND HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS
MATERIALS AND I'M WITH CAL FIRE
IT'S NOT ALWAYS I'M COVER CYCLE
IT'S NOT ALWAYS THEM BUT OFTEN
I'M CAN BE THEM WELL OVERSEE THE
CLEAN UP OF ASH AND DEBRIS IN
REALLY THE BULK OF AND THE
DEBRIS THAT'S LEFT AFTER A MAJOR
WILDFIRE.
I'M AND THERE'S OTHER STATE
DEPARTMENT THAT MIGHT BE
INVOLVED IN BOB WHAT WELFARE
RECOVERY AS WELL SUCH AS
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
ON PAGE TWO OF THE HAND OUT WE
HAVE A SUMMARY OF SOME OF THE
CURRENT YEAR ACTIONS THAT WERE
TAKEN RELATED TO WILDFIRES.
AND THAT THE CURRENT YOUR BUDGET
PROVIDED AUGMENTATIONS OF ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS RELATED TO WILD FIRES.
ON TWO HUNDRED SIXTY SIX MILLION
AT THAT WAS FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE FOREST CARBON PLAN AS
WELL AS OTHER I'M FORREST HEALTH
ACTIVITIES.
TURNER FORTY FIVE MILLION WAS
EDITION ALL ENHANCING CAL FIRE
IS ABILITY TO RESPOND TO FIRE
SUCH AS HELICOPTERS.
ON AND THEN A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
THREE MILLION FOR RECOVERY THAT
WAS BUDGETED THERE'S OBVIOUSLY
ADDITIONAL RECOVERY FUNDS THAT
HAPPENED THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
WHEN SPECIFIC DISASTERS HAPPEN?
I'M AND AS CHAIRMAN DIED HE
OBVIOUSLY NOW AND SB NINE A
WENDY --
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE THAT CAME
OUT OF THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
AS WELL AS SEVERAL OTHER BILLS
THAT WERE PASSED IN. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO PUT TOGETHER THIS
PACKAGE AS AND REALLY THE
LEGISLATURE'S RESPONSE ON FOREST
HEALTH AND FIRE PREVENTION AND
LAYING OUT FRAMEWORK FOR HOW THE
STATE WILL RESPOND --
GOING FORWARD TO THESE VERY
SEVERE WILDFIRE SEASONS AND I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE HAD A VERY
STRONG FOCUS ON FOREST HEALTH
AND FIRE PREVENTION.
AND AND THE NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET THAT THE GOVERNOR JUST
PROPOSED ON JANUARY TENTH
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
IMPLEMENT LAST YEAR'S
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE THAT
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED MILLION IN
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS
THAT'S REQUIRED BY SB NINE I
WENT.
AS WELL AS OTHER FINES FOR A
VARIETY OF DEPARTMENTS TO HIRE
STAFF AND ESTABLISH NEW PROGRAMS
IS CREATED BY THE PACKAGE.
TURNING TO PAGE THREE OF A HAND
OUT AND WANT TO CALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO IN ADDITION TO
THESE FUNDING THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE THAT THE GOVERNOR
INCLUDES IN THE BUDGET.
AND THE GOVERNOR GOES ABOVE AND
BEYOND AND ADDS ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES AND TO ADD THE STATE'S
FIRE RESPONSE ABOVE AND BEYOND
WHAT THAT LEDGE PACKAGE REQUIRES.
AND REALLY WHERE THE GOVERNOR'S
FOCUSING IS ON ENHANCING FIRE
RESPONSE AND FIRE SUPPRESSION
ACTIVITIES.
SERRA COMPARED TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PACK PREVENTIVE AND
FOREST HEALTH AND FOCUS SO THE
GOVERNOR'S PACKAGE FOR FIRE
RESPONSE --
IT CAPACITY ENHANCEMENT WE
SUMMARIZING THE FIGURE ON TABLE
THREE IT INCLUDES ABOUT NINETY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OR SOME
MINOR REIMBURSEMENT OFFSET THAT
ROUGHLY NINETY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS MOSTLY FOR PRETTY MUCH
ALL IT ALL FROM THE GENERAL FUND
I AM SMALL NON OF OTHER FUNDING.
AND AND THIS WOULD BE FOR CAL
FIRE TO RESPOND --
INC ENHANCE THEIR FIRE RESPONSE --
ACTIVITIES AND SO THIS INCLUDES
YOU FIRE ENGINES HAIR TANKERS
INCREASING STAFFING.
AND THE WHEN IT PIECE OF THIS
THAT WE WANTED IT PARTICULARLY
CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO IS THE
FIRE DETECTION CAMERAS OR
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS CAMERAS.
I'M NOT REALLY RELATES TO THE
THE PURPOSE OF THIS HEARING
LOOKING AT EMERGING AND NEW
TECHNOLOGIES.
THE BUDGET INCLUDES FIVE POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FRIEND OF FOR CALIFORNIA --
TO AND JOIN AN EXISTING NETWORK
KNOWN AS ALERT WILDFIRE YOU HAVE
A REPRESENTATIVE FROM ALERT
WILDFIRE ON YOUR NEXT PANEL
TODAY.
AND AND IT THIS WOULD ALLOW
CALIFORNIA JOIN THAT NETWORK AND
ALSO ADDED ONE HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL WILD FIRE DETECTION
CAMERAS TO THE NETWORK.
THAT AND CAL FIRE WOULD BE ABLE
AS I'VE DETECTING IN MONITORING
WILDFIRES.
AND THE ALERT WILDFIRE IS A
CONSORTIUM AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
NEVADA RENO HE UC SAN DIEGO.
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF OREGON AND
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE SOMEBODY FROM
UC SAN DIEGO WHO'S PART OF THE
ALERT WILDFIRE ON YOUR NEXT
PANEL.
I'M PAGE FOR THE HAND OUT WE
SUMMARY THE RECOMMENDATION THAT
WE MADE RELATIVE TO THIS NINETY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR PACKAGE AND
ENHANCING OF FIRE RESPONSE AND
CAPACITY AT CAL FIRE.
AND AND WE WE JUST KNOW THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND CAL FIRE AND
YES HAVEN'T PUT FORWARD IN
RECENT YEARS.
A THOROUGH ASSESSMENT OF WHAT
THE FIRE RESPONSE.
I'M CAPACITY IS IN THE STATE
INCLUDING STATE LOCAL MUTILATE
AND FEDERAL RESOURCES.
AND AND WHAT THE GAPS ARE AND AS
WE THINKING ABOUT ADDING
RESOURCES NINETY SEVEN MILLION
THIS YEAR.
AND THERE IS A COUPLE HUNDRED
MILLION I'M IN THE CURRENT YEAR
THREE LIKELY THEY'LL BE MORE
RESOURCES AND PROPOSED IN FUTURE
YEARS TO CONTINUE ADDING.
AN EQUIPMENT AND STAFFING TO
RESPOND TO FIRES ON IS THAT WE
THINK THAT HAVING AN ASSESSMENT
OF REALLY WHERE WE ADDED A
RESPONSE CAPACITY --
WHERE THOSE GAPS AND THEN HOW WE
SHOULD BE PRIORITIZING AN
INCREASE OF RESOURCES WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL FOR THE LEGISLATURE
IN FUTURE YEARS TO PLAN FOR
WHERE ARE YOU GOING TO GET THE
BIGGEST BANG FOR YOUR BUCK AND
WE GONNA GET THEM ALSO BENEFITS
IF YOU'RE ADDING --
ADDITIONAL FIRE RESPONSE
RESOURCES.
SO IN AYE RECOMMENDATION WE
THINK THAT AND THIS ASSESSMENT
SHOULD EVALUATE ALL TYPES OF
FIRE RESPONSE RESOURCES AND WE
WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THAT COULD
INCLUDE TECHNOLOGY THERE'S NO
REASON THAT THAT SHOULDN'T
INCLUDE TECHNOLOGY --
AND SO YOU MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND DECIDES TO ADOPT
A RECOMMENDATION AND REQUIRE.
CAL FIRE AND WE ASKED TO PRODUCE
THIS ASSESSED ALL IT SHOULD AND
THEY TAKE IN LOOKING AT
TECHNOLOGY AND WHAT ROLE SHOULD
TECHNOLOGY PLAY.
IN HOW WE RESPONDED TO FIRES AND
IS THERE A WAY TO BE YOU KNOW
MORE COST EFFECTIVE BY USING
TECHNOLOGY AND AND HOW DOES THAT
FIT IN WITH THE MORE TRADITIONAL
FIRE RESPONSE.
I'M STRATEGIES THAT THE STATE
USES I'M AND I CAN BE ONE WAY OF
ENSURING THAT WHATEVER
ASSESSMENT THEY PUT FORWARD IS
SOMETHING THAT'S FUTURE LOOKING
AND REFLECTS SORT OF A
MODERNIZED APPROACH.
TO HOW THE STATE FIGHTS FIRES.
AND SO I WILL JUST LEAVE MY
COMMENTS THERE AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I'M EITHER
NOW OR AFTER THE DIRECTORS MAKE
THEIR PRESENTATIONS.
THE COOL WAY TO THE END OF THE
PANEL IN THE WALL.
QUESTION SO MEMBERS IF YOU WOULD --
KEEP YOUR QUESTION SANDY WILL
ASK THOSE AFTER ALL THREE
PRESENTERS ARE FINISHED.
THIS TIME WE'LL HEAR FROM.
TOM PORTER DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
PART OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR GRAY AND
CHAIR DOT THANK YOU --
FOR HEARING THIS THIS IMPORTANT --
A JOINT HEARING AND THANK YOU
THE REST OF YOU. FOR BEING HERE
AS WELL --
WHAT I WANT TO GIVE YOU IS KIND
OF AN OVERVIEW OF OF WHAT --
THE EMERGENCY RESPONSE --
FOR WILDLIFE WILDFIRE IN
PARTICULAR IN PARTICULAR BUT CAN
YOU CAN YOU CAN.
YOU CAN THINK OF THIS FROM AN
ALL HAZARDS --
KIND OF PERSPECTIVE AS WELL --
THESE ARE FIRE CURRENTLY IS
USING -- A
NOR A AS FAR AS TECHNOLOGY IN
OUR SITUATIONAL AWARENESS AND
RESPONSE --
TO WILDFIRES AT AS STATED --
BUT ALSO --
OTHER EMERGENCIES SO --
IT'S OFTEN.
THE FIRST WE HEAR ABOUT AN
INCIDENT IS THROUGH THE NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEM AND INCREASINGLY --
NINE ONE ONE IS IS --
THE CELLULAR BASE AND THE PLACE
WHERE SOMEBODY ON A NINE ONE ONE
CALL ON A CELLULAR SYSTEM IS NOT
NECESSARILY.
EVEN ANYWHERE CLOSE TO WHERE THE
ACTUAL INCIDENT IS OCCURRING --
THE TRADITIONAL NINE ONE ONE WE
HAVE AN ADDRESS TO GO BACK TO
WOULD BE ABLE TO GO AND TALK TO
A PERSON AT THAT ADDRESS AND SEE
FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE WHERE
FIRE WAS. FOR INSTANCE --
IT NOW THAT'S NOT REALLY THE
CASE AND SO IT TAKES IT TAKES US
A LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO IDENTIFY
EXACTLY WHERE --
FIRES ARE MORE --
THEN IN IN SOME CASES IN THE
PAST -- LOOK
OUTS WAS MENTIONED YES WE STILL
ACTUALLY DO USE LOOKOUTS WITH
VOLUNTEERS AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY
SITTING IN LOOK OUTS LOOKING FOR
FIRES AND THEY CAN USE --
THE DIFFERENT DEVICES TO
IDENTIFY EXACTLY WHERE THAT FIRE
IS IT'S ACTUALLY MORE PRECISE
THAN THAN --
NINE ONE ONE CALLER BUT IT'S
LABOR INTENSIVE AND WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH OF THEM OR ENOUGH
PEOPLE DOING THAT --
ANY LONGER SO WE HAVE IT WE USE
FIXED CAMERAS AND AS JESSICA
FROM LA --
MEN -- THE
THE HUNDRED CAMERAS THAT ARE
THAT ARE ON THE IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET BUT WHAT THOSE ARE HE IS
RIGHT NOW VERY MUCH A SITUATION
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS TOOL --
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE USE FOR
VALIDATION AND THAT THERE IS
TRULY A FIRE IN AN AREA --
WE STILL ARE YOU ARE DISPATCHING
ARE ARE --
RESOURCES BASED ON A NINE ONE
ONE CALL A RADIO CALL.
OR A LOOK A LOOK OUT CALL TO OUR
COMMAND CENTER SO --
WE LAUNCH THE RESOURCES AND THEN
WE TURN TO THE CAMERAS AND TAKE
A LOOK AT THE CAMERAS AND SEE IF
IF THERE ACTUALLY IS SMOKE IN
THE AREA IT GIVES US.
A SENSE OF OF HOW RAPIDLY --
AN INCIDENT IS GROWING AND
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S THE VALUE
OF THE CURRENT --
CAMERA SYSTEM THAT IS OUT THERE --
OTHER SITUATIONAL AWARENESS --
IT TOOLS THAT WE UTILIZE --
ARE UNDERSTAFFED AND STAFFED.
FORMS --
THOSE THE FLY OVER THE TOP OF OF
INCIDENTS AND GIVE US A LOOK.
AT WHAT'S HAPPENING ON THE
GROUND CASES THROUGH THE SMOKE
UNDER THE SMOKE NOW AND WE CAN
SEE EXACTLY --
WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE --
AT THE THE OUT OF FIRE --
AND THEN USE THAT INFORMATION TO
MAKE DECISIONS AS TO WHERE TO
PUT POLICE RESOURCES IN THAT
KIND OF THAT KIND OF THING --
WE DO HAVE OF MODELING
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE USE THEIR
PROGRAMS THAT WILL --
USE VARIOUS INPUTS AND KICK OUT
A PREDICTION OF WHERE A FIRE IS
LIKELY TO GO AND WE USE THOSE --
THAT WE DON'T USE THOSE ON THE
FIRE LINE BUT WE DO USE THOSE.
AS A PLANNING AND PRE PLANNING
TOOL -- IN
IN OUR DAILY OPERATIONS --
FURTHER --
LET ME LET ME TALK ABOUT.
WHAT THE STATE THROUGH CAL FIRE?
AND OTHER PARTNERSHIPS ALREADY
OWNS -- AND
OPERATES AND IN SOME CASES FUNDS
BUT DOESN'T OWN HOME --
WE HAVE A SYSTEM OF REMOTE --
AUTOMATED WEATHER STATIONS --
THESE ARE WEATHER STATIONS THAT
ARE SCATTERED THE LANDSCAPE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
THEY'RE PART OF A NATIONWIDE
SYSTEM.
AND THEY UPLOAD ON AN HOURLY
BASIS --
WHETHER FROM THOSE LOCATIONS THE
PRINT T. BROAD THEY DON'T HAVE
THEY ARE VERY GRANULAR.
SO WE'VE HEARD IN THIS IN IN IN
SIMILAR HEARINGS --
AND REMEMBER HUESO YOUR YOUR
DISTRICT HAS A VERY FINE GRAIN
LOOK AT THE WEATHER --
BEING --
THAT THAT THERE'S A WEATHER
SYSTEM THAT IS ALMOST ON A MILE
BY MILE BASIS ACROSS THE
LANDSCAPE WE DON'T HAVE THAT
ACROSS CALIFORNIA IS ONE MAKE
SURE MAKE SURE YOU UNDERSTAND.
OUR WROTE MORE REMOTE --
AUTOMATED WEATHER STATIONS ARE
MILES AND MILES APART AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE LOOKING AT A
VERY A KIND OF A REGIONAL --
WHETHER AT BUT THEY DO GIVE US
WHETHER ON AN HOURLY BASIS --
YEAR ROUND --
WE ALSO.
HAVE -- A
PREDICTIVE SERVICES UNIT IN --
EACH OF OUR GEOGRAPHIC --
COORDINATION CENTERS. ONE IN
RIVERSIDE FOR THE SOUTH HALF OF
THE STATE AND ONE IN REDDING FOR
THE NORTH HALF OF THE STATE --
THIS IS A NATIONWIDE SYSTEM --
AND THOSE GEOGRAPHIC ACCORDING
OUR ACROSS THE NATION --
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY.
STATE IN THE UNION THAT HAS.
TO SO WE ARE.
BIG ENOUGH AND WE HAVE A A A
DIVERSE ENOUGH.
KIND OF LANDSCAPE THAT WE
REQUIRE TWO OF THESE CENTERS AND
WHAT THEY DO IS THEY LOOK AT
FIRE WEATHER --
THEY LOOK AT FIRE WEATHER IN
VERY GREAT DETAIL DOWN TO THE
THE FINE FUELS AND THEIR FUEL
MOISTURE AND HOW THAT'S CHANGING
THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
THE HEAVIER FUELS AND I'M
TALKING ABOUT VEGETATION FUELS.
AND HOW THOSE ARE ARE AFFECTED
ON A SEASONAL BASIS.
AND THEY DRY OUT IN THE SPRING
AND THEN THEY DON'T VOICE AND UP
UNTIL WELL INTO THE WINTER --
THEY THEY LOOK AT THE
SEASONALITY AND THEN THEY AND
THEN THE WEATHER --
THAT'S HAPPENING AS WELL AND
THEY UTILIZE ALL OF THOSE
CRITERIA TO DETERMINE --
A PRODUCT THAT'S GIVEN FOR TODAY
AND TOMORROW WHAT WHAT IS MY
RISK OF HAVING A LARGE A
DAMAGING FIRE TODAY.
AND TOMORROW.
AND THEN THEY HAVE A SEVEN THE
GIVES US TODAY THROUGH.
NEXT WEEK AND THEN THEY HAVE A
SEASONAL OUTLOOK THEY GIVES US.
FOR ON A QUARTERLY BASIS WHAT
WHAT THE SEASON IS LOOKING LIKE
AND IF WE'RE GOING GOING INTO
DROUGHT CONDITIONS COMING OUT OF
DROUGHT CONDITIONS ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT AFFECT.
KIND OF THAT LONG TERM.
PLANNING AND ALL OF THAT'S DONE
THROUGH THOSE TWO CENTERS AND
THEY THEY PROVIDE THAT DAILY --
TO OUR FIREFIGHTERS AND
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS --
THROUGH THEIR WEBSITES --
THAT ARE ALL UNDER THE THE GAS
TAX.
SO.
WE HAVE THOSE --
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS TOOL --
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
COLLABORATION TOOL --
WHICH IS SCALP THAT IS --
JOINT OF PROJECT --
FOR A PLATFORM THAT WE CAN WE
CAN LOOK AT ALL OF THESE --
TYPES OF DATA ON ONE PLACE AT
ONE TIME THAT'S IN COLLABORATION --
WITH WITH --
SHE AND AND A CALLOW YES CAL
FIRE -- AS
PRIMARIES IN THAT AND AND WE'LL
TALK MORE ABOUT THAT IN THE
FUTURE BUT THE OTHER THINGS THAT
WERE USING OUR I KNOW I I AND
MANNED --
AERIAL SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS --
WHEN WE HAVE INCIDENTS WE CAN
PUT THOSE IN THE AIR THROUGH A
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL GUARD --
THE DOMESTIC --
OPERATIONS WE CAN GET INTO WHEN
WE HAVE A LARGER --
INCIDENT THAT REQUIRES A
MILITARY RESPONSE THAT GIVES US
AN OPPORTUNITY THROUGH ACCOUNT
CAL GUARD AGAIN. TO ACCESS --
ASSETS THAT WOULD BE --
ABLE -- TO
LOOK AT THAT --
THE SITUATIONAL AWARENESS --
AS WE HAD TO MOVE FURTHER INTO.
OUTER SPACE.
WE DO THROUGH --
THROUGH NASA AND THROUGH --
THE NEED TO SEE WHICH IS THE
NATIONAL INTERAGENCY FIRE CENTER
WE HAVE ACCESS TO A REMOTE
SENSING TECHNOLOGIES --
THAT WE CAN WE CAN TURN ON AND
TAKE A LOOK AT THE THOSE WOULD
INCLUDE --
THINGS LIKE --
GEO SPACE --
TOOLS THROUGH THE MOTOR
SATELLITE AND AND GOES SATELLITE
NOTICES OF MODERATE RESOLUTION
IMAGERY --
SPECTROMETER THE THESE DON'T
GIVE US A VERY FINE GRAIN LOOK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT RIGHT NOW
OUR LOOK FROM OUTER SPACE --
GIVES US LARGE BLOCKS ON A MAP
THAT SHOW US WHERE HEAT
SIGNATURES ARE THEY'RE NOT VERY
TIGHT.
WE CAN'T I COULDN'T WALK YOU TO
A PLACE.
WHERE A HEAT SIGNATURE WAS FROM --
WE CAN WITH THE AERIAL
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS WHICH WE
HAVE -- THAT
ARE THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
THINGS LIKE --
THE FIRE WATCH --
COBRA HELICOPTERS.
AND NYROP SWITCHES --
NIGHT FLYING --
INFRARED.
OPERATIONS THAT WE PUT OVER
FIRES.
EVERY NIGHT TO TAKE A LOOK AT
WHERE THE FIRE WAS LAST NIGHT
BUT BY THE TIME I GET THAT LOOK
AT IT IN THE MORNING SORRY.
LOOK AT IN THE MORNING THE FIRES
MOVED.
SO THESE ARE ALL THE THINGS THAT
WE ARE AND THERE'S A LOT MORE WE
NEED TO PULL TOGETHER --
BUT THAT THAT IS A A BROAD LOOK
AT WHAT CURRENTLY CAL FIRE AND
THE FIRE SERVICES USING --
FOR WILD FIRE KIND OF
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS ON THE
TECHNOLOGY FRONT.
THANK YOU AND I'LL TAKE
QUESTIONS WENT ON YOUR REQUEST.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR WELCOME TO
DRESS GO DUTY.
GREAT GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE
AND CHAIRMAN AND VICE CHAIR
THANKS FOR HAVING US HERE --
SO -- JUST
TO KIND OF CAPITALIZE ON ON
CHEAP PORTERS --
COMMENTS --
YOU KNOW --
YES IS ROLE COORDINATION OF
ASSETS AND DECISION MAKING AND
MAJOR EVENTS THAT HAPPEN IN THE
STATE -- YOU
KNOW I DON'T LAST YEAR --
WAS A ANOTHER CRAZY YEAR --
FOR AND IMPACTFUL YEAR FOR FIRES --
CAL FIRE BUT PROBABLY FUNDED
MORE THAN SEVEN THOUSAND FIRES
BUT IT WAS REALLY A SERIES OF
ABOUT -- OF
FOUR FIVE MAJOR FIRES THAT WOULD
RESULT IN A COMPLETE STATE WIDE
RESPONSE TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT --
THOSE OPERATIONS AND IN THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER --
IS WHERE ALL THE DIFFERENT
ENTITIES COME TOGETHER AND
HAVING GOOD SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS HAVING GOOD DATA --
THEY CAN TO BE TURNED IN THE
DATA ANALYTICS AND HELP WAS THEN
MAKE DECISIONS IN A VERY RAPID
WAY -- IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND THAT.
THAT WELL --
WELL TACTICALLY ON THE GROUND --
OPERATIONS CENTER IS THE GAS TAX
THAT -- TOM
AND MENTIONED --
ALL OF THAT RULES UP INTO OUT
STATEWIDE PERSPECTIVE --
WITH REGARDS TO WHAT IS
HAPPENING NO.
ONE INCIDENT REALLY.
TENDS TO BE CONFINED TO ONE
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA THEY ARE FIRES
TEND TO NOT LOOK AT BOUNDARIES
AND THEY SPREAD VERY RAPIDLY
PARTICULARLY THE EXTREME FIRES
THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING IN THE
STATE.
BUT WE'RE AN ALL HAZARDS
ORGANIZATION SO IT COULD BE THE
WAY THAT --
WE GET FLOODING WHERE WE HAVE A
HUGE AMOUNT OF RAIN AND THAT IS
SIERRA FRONT BUT THE WAY THE
WATER FLOWS IN CALIFORNIA WE GET
FLOODING IN THE LOWER --
A COUNTIES MUCH LIKE WE'RE
SEEING NOW IN CINEMA --
AND HUMBLED AND PARTS OF
MENDOCINO WHERE YOU'RE GETTING A
LOT OF OF OF OF FLOW COMING DOWN
SO WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
SITUATION AWARENESS THE
CAPABILITIES IN A VERY BROAD.
PERSPECTIVE IN THE ABILITY --
TO AND APPROPRIATE --
TO WHILE --
FOR ARE WHAT JUST ONE OF THE
HAZARDS WHEN I MENTION FLOOD
EARTHQUAKES AND OTHER --
ANY SITUATION AWARENESS TOOLS
ARE IMPORTANT FOR US.
IN FOR ON THE FRONT END OF THESE
ADVANCED TO LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE CASE A WILDFIRE
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE WE ARE --
WORKING TO REFINE OUR ABILITY TO
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN THE NATIONAL
WEATHER SERVICE SAYS WHERE HAVE
A RED FLAG WARNING --
THAT ENCOMPASSES. FIVE OR SIX
COUNTIES --
WHAT ACTUALLY DOES THAT MEAN --
WITH REGARDS TO HOW DO WE PLACE
RESOURCES --
THEY ARE PRE POSITIONED
RESOURCES IN A PLACE THAT IF
THERE'S A FIRE START WE CAN BE
VERY VERY --
RAPIDLY GET ON THAT AND AND
MINIMIZE THE THE SPREAD --
WE KNOW THAT THE CAL FINDING IT
MERELY LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS
RESPONDING IMMEDIATELY --
BUT THE ONE OF THE ROLES OF ALL
WE ASK IS TO BRING TOGETHER ALL
THOSE LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
AND THEY YES ASSETS. TO BE ABLE
TO COME IN AND SUPPORT --
FIRES THAT THAT CAL FIRE IS
HAVING TO MANAGE --
THE BECOME THAT ARE MOVING VERY
RAPIDLY.
SO IF WE GET A RED FLAG
CONDITION --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IS BEING
ABLE TO BE FINE --
THOSE MICROCLIMATES SO THOSE
THOSE THOSE --
AREAS WHERE.
THROUGH THE CAMERAS THE TOM
MENTIONED TO THE WEATHER
STATIONS THAT THAT THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED --
WE CAN WE CAN REALLY GET THAT
DATA AND REFINED WHERE THE
HIGHEST PROBABILITY OF A FIRE
STARTS ARE GOING TO BE WAR MAYBE
THE HIGHEST IMPACT ARE GOING TO
BE BASED UPON --
DENSITY OF THE COMMUNITY --
BASED UPON THE WILDFIRE MAPS
THAT -- AND
HISTORICAL DATA THE CALIFORNIA
AS THAT ALL OF US TO BE
INTEGRATED MUCH LIKE A FUSION
CENTER HAS TO BECOME COME
TOGETHER --
TO BE ABLE --
TO EFFECTIVELY APPLY RESOURCE
MINIMIZE --
THE AMOUNT OF OF DAMAGE --
YOU KNOW BETWEEN SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN WE HAD --
YOU KNOW OF THE FIRES AND IN THE
NORTH BAY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THEN AGAIN IN.
EIGHTEEN BETWEEN THOSE TWO
INCIDENTS WE LOST CLOSE TO
THIRTY THOUSAND STRUCTURES --
IS IS IS A PHENOMENAL TWO YEARS
AND WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
EVOLVE --
OUR SITUATION AWARENESS ARE --
UP YOU KNOW AUTOMATED
INTELLIGENCE CAPABILITIES --
FROM BUT THE TECHNOLOGY TO BE
ABLE TO HELP US MAKE OUR
DECISIONS OF MORE RAPIDLY.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN --
THESE FIRES ARE MOVING SO FAST
THAT WE ARE.
AT THAT COORDINATION LEVEL AT
THE WITH REGARDS TO BEING ABLE
TO GET REAL TIME --
THE DATA ON ON FIRE PERIMETERS
OR IMPACTS AND SO WE'RE HAVING
TO DO A LOT MORE INTENSIVE
COORDINATION WITH THE INCIDENT
MANAGEMENT TEAMS ON THE GROUND.
AND COMMUNICATING UP INTO THE
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER --
ON HOW HOW --
HOW RESOURCES ARE NEEDED AND AND
WHERE WE WE PLACE THEM --
THIRD REPORTER MENTIONED THE
SCALP THE THE SITUATIONAL WEARS
A COLLABORATIVE TOOL THIS IS UP --
OF A PRETTY PHENOMENAL
CAPABILITY THAT WE'VE WE'VE
JOINTLY INVESTED IN --
IT WAS --
ORIGINALLY --
IS FUNDED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY AND UP WAS A
CAPABILITY THAT WAS --
BILL BY MIT LINCOLN LABS --
AND THEN IT WAS GIVEN TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHERE BOTH
ARE ORGANIZATIONS WERE
INSTRUMENTAL IN BEING ABLE TO
BUILD OUT --
WILL -- WHAT
THAT PLATFORM WOULD LOOK
UTILIZATION FOR EYES ALSO
INCLUDE A LOT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE?
AND THIS THIS.
COLLABORATIVE TOOL NOW --
REALLY IT GIVES US YEAH --
SOME REAL TIME CAPABILITY TO
FACILITATE TACTICAL INFORMATION
SHARING AMONGST ALL THE RESPOND
OR IS THERE IN THE FIELD AS WELL
AS INTER AGENCY.
SITUATION WHERE THIS THIS IS ONE
OF THE FIRST MAJOR COLLABORATIVE
TOOLS THAT WE HAD THAT WE CAN
ALL BE LOOKING AT SIMULTANEOUSLY
TO BE ABLE --
TO A BIT MAKE DECISIONS AND MOVE
RESOURCES EFFECTIVELY AND OF
THERE AREN'T THERE ARE CLOSE TO
SIXTEEN HUNDRED USERS NOW --
ON THE REGISTERED USERS ON SCALP
AND UP REALLY IT IT HELPS AS
WITH INCIDENT LOCATION IN
PERIMETER --
IT HELPS AS WITH OUR OUR UP A
BRANCH OF DIVISION BREAKS WITH
DIRECTOR PORTER MENTION --
WHERE OUR COMMAND POST THE
STAGING ITS IN SUPPORT LOCATIONS
ARE -- HOW
WE DO EVACUATION AREAS HOW MANY --
STRUCTURES COULD POTENTIALLY BE
IMPACTED --
AS FIRE SPREAD HAPPENS AND THIS
IS IMPORTANT WHEN WE SEEK
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE AS WELL
BECAUSE EARLY ON IN A LOT OF
THESE FIRES --
WE ARE --
SEEKING WHAT'S CALLED THE FIRE
MANAGEMENT ASSISTANCE GRANT FROM
THE FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AGENCY THOSE F. MAJOR CRITICAL
BECAUSE THEY CAN PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE --
FUNDING TO HELP OFFSET THE COST
OF OF THAT INITIAL RESPONSE BUT
THERE ARE VERY SPECIFIC CRITERIA.
THAT ARE REQUIRED AND IN THIS
COLLABORATIVE TOOL HELPS US TO
IMMEDIATELY IDENTIFY --
THAT INFORMATION THAT
COLLABORATIVE TOOLS ALSO TIED TO
INITIATIVES THAT --
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE --
BUT CAL FIRE AND YES STARTED A
VEHICLE OKAY THAT'S THAT'S
ABILITY THAT SOURCES ASTOR
MOVING AROUND THE STATE IN REAL
TIME AND BE ABLE TO MAKE
DECISIONS ON WE'RE REPLACING
THOSE IN TRACK THEM --
AFFECTED LEE --
ALSO WE'LL TALK A LOT ABOUT --
SOME OF THE OTHER MODALITIES
THAT WE'RE USING --
THAT THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
HAS ABILITY TO TIE INTO.
A MANY THE CAMERAS THAT --
TRUCK REPORTER TALKED ABOUT ALSO
ALL OUR CALTRANS CAMERAS --
THERE'S A A NUMBER OF PRIVATE
SECTOR CAMERAS THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS -- TO
TO BE ABLE --
TO PULL I DATE A AND TO BE --
TO MAKE DECISIONS --
ARE WE HAVE --
THE BASE LIKE CAPABILITY WITHIN
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
BASED ON EVERY PLATFORM --
GIVES AS DATA THAT WE CAN TURN
IT ANALYTICS THE KIND OF SHOW --
SOME OF THE TECHNOLOGY TOOLS
THAT BASED UPON THE THAT THE
DATA THAT WE'RE GETTING WHETHER
WHETHER IT'S A FOUGHT A FIRE
FLOOD OR EARTHQUAKE --
GIVES US THE ABILITY TO RAPIDLY --
PUT NUMBERS --
AND METRICS ASSOCIATED WITH
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN THE
FIELD.
OUT WE AUGMENT THAT WITH THINGS
LIKE --
TASKING THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
GUARD TO PROVIDE SURVEILLANCE
AIRCRAFT --
TO BE ABLE TO DO FIRE PERIMETER
MAPPING OR DAMAGE ASSESSMENT ON
THE NUMBER OF STRUCTURES THAT
HAVE BEEN DESTROYED.
OR DAMAGED IT HELPS US DETERMINE
WHERE FLOOD --
BY WATERS ARE MOVING AND SO THE
SURVEILLANCE AIRCRAFT ARE VERY
IMPORTANT AND YOU HEAR MORE
ABOUT THE SURVEILLANCE AIRCRAFT --
AND IN A LATER PRESENTATION --
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR THE THAT
WE ENGAGE WITH AS WELL TO HELP
US WITH THAT THAT PROCESS --
DIRECTOR POR ALSO MENTIONED
UNMANNED AERIAL OR OR DRONES --
WE DO TASK NATIONAL GUARD FOR
THE DO YOU OF TWENTY FOUR AND
AERIAL RECONNAISSANCE AND BEING
ABLE -- TO
YOU SOME OTHER INFRARED
TECHNOLOGY TO BE ABLE TO GIVE US --
ON THE GROUND VISUALIZATION AND
AGAIN THERE'S SOME AERIAL
IMAGERY IN THESE IN THESE
GRAPHICS THAT SHOW --
THE FAR RIGHT SOME OF THE WHAT
WE'RE SEEING OUT OF THOSE DRONE
PICTURES THEY CAN FLY AT NIGHT
THEY CAN FLY IN THE DAY THEY CAN
CUT TO SOME OF THE SMOKE AND
THAT'S VERY VERY --
HELPFUL FOR US --
LASTLY --
DIRECTOR PORTER MENTIONED --
SATELLITES AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE
BEEN YOU KNOW WE USE OUR THE
NASA SATELLITES SYSTEM --
NATIONAL WEATHER SERVICE SYSTEM
BUT WE ALSO HAVE BEEN --
TESTING --
PRIVATE SECTOR SATELLITE
CAPABILITIES --
TO SEE ABOUT IF WE CAN ENHANCE
OUR ABILITY USED AS AND AND THEY
HAVE PROVEN SORT OF FIFTY FIFTY
WITH REGARDS --
TO THE ABILITY THAT THEY BRING
TO US -- AND
AND WHETHER THAT INVESTMENT THE
SECTOR SATELLITES ACTUALLY --
ARE ARE WORTH OUR OUR EFFORT --
SO -- I I I
GUESS I WOULD JUST SAY THAT YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF THERE'S
BUT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF EFFORT
GOING ON IN THE AREA OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND IN --
THE ABILITY TO GET GOOD
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS TOOLS.
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO MOVE --
BUT IT HAS TO BE DONE IN A IN AN
INTEGRATED --
COLLABORATIVE FASHION --
GIVEN THE FACT THAT OF THE WAY
WE DO OPERATE IN THE STATE --
WITH STATE AND LOCAL ALL OUR
MUTUAL AID ASSETS --
AND EVENTUALLY THIS WILL TIE
INTO -- ARE
ENHANCEMENT OF OUR NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM -- OR
OR HIS NINE ONE ONE IN OUR
ABILITY --
TO MOVE INTO WHAT'S CALLED FIRST
NET WHICH IS A BROADBAND BEING.
INTEROPERABLE I DATA PLATFORM --
TO BE ABLE TO SHE SHARE REAL
TIME DATA WITH RESPONDENTS SO
THAT WOULD BE P. MUTUALLY TEAMS
ARE RESPONDING TO SUPPORT CAL
FIRE FIRES --
THEY'RE ACTUALLY SEEING AS THE
RESPONDING A GETTING DATA --
SO THAT THOSE STRIKE TEAM
COMMANDERS CAN BE MAKING
DECISIONS.
EVEN BEFORE THEY ARRIVE --
INTO THE THE AREA OF OPERATION
RIGHT NOW THEIR LITTLE BIT BLIND
UNTIL THEY GET IN THE EVERY
OPERATION THEY GET ASSIGNMENTS
THIS IS GOING TO BE --
AN EFFORT TO EXPAND THAT --
THAT CAPABILITY --
AND THEN LASTLY I WOULD JUST SAY
TO THE WE'RE VERY ENCOURAGED HIM
TO TO DO IT ADDITIONAL
ASSESSMENTS THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
VERY SIGNIFICANT ASSESSMENTS
DONE -- IN A
FROM THE PAST BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSIONS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT
IN PLACE --
TWO OF THEM ACTUALLY --
SINCE ABOUT TWO THOUSAND AND
THREE THAT OUTLINED MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY AND SINCE THAT TIME BOTH
ORGANIZATIONS AND OUR PARTNERS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND OUR
PARTNERS IN THE U. S. FOR
SERVICE.
THE OTHER FEDERAL AGENCIES A
FEMA HAVE WORKED VERY DILIGENTLY
TO ADDRESS MANY OF THE
RECOMMENATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
PUT FORTH --
IN THOSE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSIONS
AND UP THAT'S ACTUALLY HELPED US
TO GET WERE OUT TODAY WITH OUR
CAPABILITY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE PANELS THAT
YOU DIRECTOR --
GOOD YOU SHE AND I THINK WE HAVE
SEVERAL QUESTIONS SO WE'LL TAKE
SOME QUESTIONS MEMBERS RIGHT NOW
IF YOU DON'T MIND --
STICK AROUND WE'LL START WAS
CENTERED HUESO.
THANK YOU --
I GUESS THE NUMBER ONE RULE.
OF FIGHTING FIRE SINCE I'VE BEEN
IN GOVERNMENT IS RESPONSIVENESS
AND HOW FAST WE CAN GET TO THOSE
FIRES AND AND USUALLY THE FASTER
YOU GET TO THEM THE LIKELIHOOD
THEY'LL BE SMALLER.
AND AND LESS LESS DEVELOPED.
SO LOOKING AT AT THE THE
PRESENTATION TODAY I I WANTED TO
FOLLOW UP A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT
YOU SAID AND SATELLITES BECAUSE
BOTH OF YOU MENTIONED SATELLITES.
AND FROM MY UNDERSTANDING OF OUR
TECHNOLOGY AND SATELLITES IS
VERY ADVANCED AT ANY GIVEN POINT
WE HAVE MULTIPLE SATELLITES I
JUST.
ONE THAT THE GOVERNMENT USES
MAINLY FOR SURVEILLANCE.
WINDOWS PRINT PRINCIPLE
DEVELOPMENT OF OF SATELLITE
TECHNOLOGY BY BY THE GOVERNMENT
NASA -- AND
AND SO WE CAN GET.
REALLY DETAILED INFORMATION FROM
THESE VERY --
HI.
THESE THESE THESE.
OUR CAMERAS THAT HAVE A VERY
HIGH RESOLUTION ABLE TO FOCUS
VERY IN DEPTH AND IF IF.
WE CAN USE THE TECHNOLOGY TO
IDENTIFY SMOKE.
AND WE HAVE --
THE EQUIPMENT.
THAT IS SPREAD OUT --
GEOGRAPHICALLY --
IN A COORDINATED FASHION --
WE CAN RESPOND TO THESE FIRES
MUCH QUICKER LET'S SAY --
MOBILIZING IN YOU KNOW WHATEVER
YOU HAVE NEAREST THAT INCIDENT
COULD BE HELICOPTER COULD BE --
YOU KNOW HELICOPTER AND FIRE
TRUCKS [inaudible]
SO.
WHY HAVEN'T WE LOOK AT SATELLITE
LITTLE BIT MORE IN TERMS OF?
IT MAY BE JUST.
QUITMAN SPACE AVAILABLE TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO SUPPORT YEAR.
IS THAT SOMETHING THEY CAN DO TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO THE STATE AND
HELPING US TO PROVIDE THAT
SURVEILLANCE INTERSTATE THROUGH
SATELLITE EQUIPMENT AND CAN
SATELLITE EQUIPMENT.
MONITOR.
WITH SOMEBODY THERE LOOKING
SPECIFICALLY FOR SMOKE AND FIRES
AND AND ANYTHING THAT CAN.
POTENTIALLY.
YOU KNOW BURN RIGHT IN OUR FORCE
BECAUSE CAMERAS I MEAN THEY'LL
BE VERY EXPENSIVE TO SITUATE
CAMERAS ALL OVER THE ALL OVER
THE STATE SPECIALLY.
AND THE LEAST POPULATED AREAS
WHERE THERE'S LESS LIKE THIS
SOMEBODY CAN CALL IN NINE ONE
ONE SEX MALE SMOKERS SEE SMOKE.
HARDER IN FOURS BUT FROM WITH
THE SATELLITE.
HE COULD ALMOST SEE ANYTHING
ANYWHERE AT ANY GIVEN TIME AND A
SMALL INCIDENT OF SMOKE.
COULD BE THAT TRIGGER THAT SAYS
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
IT IS BUT SENATE.
HELICOPTER THERE.
LEE AND AND I KNOW YOU YOU
MENTIONED A WELL WE FIRST ONE
ASSESS THAT SMOKER.
DO WE HAVE TO WAIT. FOR THAT
FIRE TO DEVELOP BEFORE WE WE WE
SEND SOMEBODY TO ESPECIALLY IN A
IN AN AREA.
THAT IS A HIGH RISK AREAS SHOULD
WE SHOULD WE BE A LITTLE MORE --
WILLING --
TO DEPLOY [inaudible]
OUR RESOURCES.
AND AND WAIT LESS TO GATHER
INFORMATION YOU KNOW THAT SO.
SATELLITES FIRST OF ALL.
WELL I STARTED IT ALL TURNED
OVER TO THE DIRECT PORTER --
SO -- WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING A LOT AND THE
SATELLITES AND AND I I THINK
THAT YOU KNOW MANY OF US --
KIND OF WATCH WHAT YOU KNOW DID
SHE SHOWS WHERE THEY CAN.
NAVIGATE THE SATELLITE AND LOOK
DOWN AND SEE EXACTLY WHETHER OUT
AND AND AND THAT'S PROBABLY TRUE
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE IN THE MIDDLE EAST --
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S NOT THE
CAPABILITY THAT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FRANCE WITH FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS HERE DOMESTICALLY --
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE TO TRY --
TO GET THEM TO DECLASSIFY SOME
CAPABILITIES --
OF THAT SATELLITE MORE OR WORK
CLOSELY WITH US --
TO DO SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT --
IN THE IN THE ABSENCE OF THAT
ACTUALLY COMING THE FULL
FLOURISH AND YOU KNOW WE DO YOU
WE DO EMPLOYEE SATELLITE
TECHNOLOGY NOW --
BUT AS AS THE DRUG FOR MATCH AND
YOU KNOW THE SATELLITES.
THE ORBIT SO YOU'RE GETTING A A
A PIECE OF TIME AND IN SOME OF
THAT DATA IS REALLY GOOD BUT
SINCE WE'RE NOT CONTROLLING THE
SATELLITES YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE TO
SAY OKAY YOU KNOW.
CHANGE THAT THE APERTURE THAT
SATELLITE AND JUST GET IT THE
FOCUS IN ONE SPOT --
WE'RE NOT THERE YET --
WE THIS PAST FIRE SEASON WE DID
TEST SOME PRIVATE SECTOR
SATELLITES AND AND THEY DO.
THEY DID PROVE TO GIVE US IN
FACT SOME OF THE PICTURES HERE
ARE FROM THAT PARTICULAR
SATELLITE.
BUT THEY DON'T THEY DON'T --
HAVE CERTAIN KINDS OF INFRARED
AND OTHER KINDS OF TECHNOLOGY
THAT YOU WE NEED SO THE NEXT
OPTION WOULD BE TO POSSIBLY YOU
KNOW.
LARGER ON SATELLITE OR HAVE OUR
OWN CAPABILITY THAT WE CAN
MANEUVER THAT BUT I THINK THAT
THERE'S PROMISING WORK THAT'S
BEING DONE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE SEEMS LIKE IT'S NOT
ONLY OUR STATE THAT THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY MAYBE THE ENTIRE WORLD
WOULD BE.
WOULD IF THERE WAS SOME
COOPERATIVE EFFORT TO SHARE
INFORMATION YEAH --
AND AND SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF OF LOOKING FOR FIRES
YOU KNOW.
TO THAT THAT IF IF BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AT ANY GIVEN TIME HAS SOME BE OF
OUR STATE.
EVEN WITH THE ROAD TO PERDITION
OF OUR OF THE SATELLITES BECAUSE
A MULTIPLE SATELLITES TO YOU.
TO BACK FILL IN.
AND AT SOME POINT THEY COULD
REALLY HELP US IN THAT ASPECT.
THE OTHER THE OTHER QUESTION WAS
ABOUT COVERAGE I MEAN.
YOU THERE IS --
FORCED CARBON PLAN THIS
MENTIONED.
AND HOW WE ENHANCED OUR BUDGET
BY SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION
WHICH IS A VERY HEALTHY SUM OF
MONEY.
AND COUPLED WITH FEDERAL
FIREFIGHTING IN.
OF RESOURCES IN OUR STATE BASED.
DOES I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S IN THAT
CARBON PLAN.
BUT DOES IT ASSESS OUR READINESS
TO COMBAT FIRES STATEWIDE IN
TERMS OF HAVING THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY.
AND TO BE PREPARED FOR THESE
EVENTS AND TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
QUICKLY TO THESE EVENTS AND I'M
MOSTLY CONCERNED OR ARE WE READY
TO RESPOND QUICKLY DO WE HAVE
WHAT WE NEED.
SURE SO IN TERMS OF THE FIRST
CARBON PLAN IS FOCUSED MORE ON
OF FOREST HEALTH AND PREVENTIVE
MEASURES AND RIGHT NOW.
AND ABOUT A THIRD OF THE STATE
IS FORESTED AND AND A LARGE VAST
MAJORITY OF THOSE FORESTS ARE IN
AN UNHEALTHY CONDITION WHERE
THERE. TO DANCE THERE'S MANY
DEAD OR DYING TREES AND AND THIS
JUST CREATES A SITUATION WHERE
YOU HAVE A LOT OF AND VEGETATION
FUELS THAT CAN.
RESULT IN THESE I AM EXTREMELY
SEVERE FIRES AND SO THE FOREST
CARBON PLAN AND A LOT OF THE
WORK THAT WAS DONE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE IS FOCUSING
MORE ON HOW OVER THE LONG TERM
DO WE MAKE THE FORESTS IN THE
STATE.
HEALTHIER IS SO THAT THEY ARE
NOT AS PRONE TO THESE VERY
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES AND THEN --
SEPARATELY THROUGH BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS AND IN RECENT
YEARS THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR HER PROVIDED THESE
ADDITIONAL FIRE RESPONSE
RESOURCES AND SO YOU HAVE THESE.
YOU KNOW TWO DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES FULL TO MAKE OUR
FIRST HEALTHIER SO THERE'S LESS
SEVERE FIRES AND LOWERS THAT
RISK -- AS
WELL AS INCREASING CAL FIRE AND
YES IS ABILITY TO RESPOND AND
I'LL LET THAT DOCTOR PORTER.
YES SAID.
THE POOREST CARBON PLAN REALLY.
GIVES US --
A BLUEPRINT OF WHAT THE
ENVIRONMENT LOOKS LIKE THE THE
THIS STATE --
FIRE STRATEGIC PLAN KIND OF
GIVES US A FRAMEWORK OF HOW
WE'RE GOING TO RESPOND TO THAT
WHICH IS.
IS REALLY A HOLISTIC APPROACH
WHICH INCLUDES RESOURCES AS WELL
AS A MEETING BY RESPONDING
RESOURCES AS WELL AS THE
TREATMENTS THAT WE WOULD DO PRO
ACTIVELY AND ALL OF THOSE THINGS
TOGETHER --
PROVIDE A SYSTEM OF OF FOREST
AND COMMUNITY RESILIENCE THAT
WILL.
THAT WILL REDUCE THE EFFECTS AND
THE RISK OF WILDFIRE IN THE
FUTURE -- SO
THOSE ARE THOSE ITEMS --
I THINK THERE IS SOME PROMISE IN
THE FUTURE ON ON THE THE
SATELLITE FRONT I THINK THERE
THERE REALLY ISN'T THAT
SOMETHING --
AS DIRECTOR GILLARD YUJI MENTION
WE WILL BE WORKING TOWARD WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE IN THE FUTURE --
AND THERE ARE THE HURDLES THAT
THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
BUT I WANTED ALSO TO MAKE SURE --
THAT I DIDN'T MISS SPEAK --
RELATED TO WHAT I'LL CALL GET
AWAY TIME THAT IS THE TIME THAT
THE THE ALARM GOES OFF IN THE
FIRE STATION. TWO TWO MINUTES
FROM THEN THAT THE ENGINES ON
THE ROAD GOING TO WHATEVER THE
INCIDENT HE IS --
GET AWAY TIME IS IS CRITICAL TO
US SO GET AWAY TIME IS THE TIME
FROM WHEN THEY GET WHEN I GET
THE CALL. TO WHEN I'M DRIVING
DOWN THE ROAD TO GET TO THE CALL --
THE LAG THAT THAT WE WE HAVE A
SO THAT IS A TWO MINUTE WINDOW.
THE LAG THAT WE HAVE THAT THAT
COULD BE --
SH DO REDUCED BY THESE OTHER
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
CAPABILITIES WOULD BE THE REPORT
TIME.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING WE WE
NEVER ONCE THAT ONCE THERE'S A
REPORT WHETHER THEIR SMOKE IN
THE AIR OR NOT WE'RE LAUNCHING.
SO WE LAUNCH AN AIRCRAFT DURING
THE PEAK OF SEASON.
THERE ARE AIR TANKERS
HELICOPTERS BULLDOZERS --
AND ENGINES AND HAND HAND CREWS
ALL HEADED TO A POINT ON EARTH
THAT SOMEBODY SAID THERE'S A
FIRE EVEN IF THERE'S NO SMOKE IN
THE AIR.
SO THE SITUATIONAL AWARENESS --
CAPABILITY THAT WE USE THAT
THOSE CAMERAS FOR NOW IS SO I I
AM SITTING AT MY CONSOLE TO GET
ALL THAT STUFF ON THE ROAD.
AND NOW I'M DOING EACH CALL
BACKS --
SAYS HEY LET'S LET'S PULL IT UP
SO WE CAN LOOK AND SEE WHAT'S
GOING ON OUT THERE BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THE AREA THE ZOOM IN ON ORG
OR THEY PAN TO OR LOOK AT THE
CAMERA THAT'S LOOKING IN THAT
DIRECTION.
AND THEN THEY START TO GO OKAY
THIS IS REAL THIS THING IT'S
BUILDING BECAUSE YOU CAN JUST
YOU CAN SEE FROM A SMOKE AT AN
EARLY AGE.
WHETHER IT'S IT'S JUST KIND OF A
WISPY OR IF IT'S BUILDING
QUICKLY AND SO THEN THEY'LL
START TO TUNE THEMSELVES HEY.
FRED GO GO GET ON THE PHONE
WE'RE GONNA BE HERE ALL NIGHT
WORKING ON THIS ONE START
GETTING PEOPLE COMING BACK TO
WORK.
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING THAT
WERE USING IT FOR IN THE CENTER --
AND THEN THE RESOURCES ON THE
GROUND ARE STILL USING.
THEIR THEIR HELICOPTER SEEM LIKE
THE WISEST INVESTMENT FOR OUR
STATE IN TERMS OF RESPONSE OF
HAVING AT LEAST SOMETHING TO BE
ABLE.
TO DROP A LOT OF WATER OR OR A
FIRE RETARDANT ON ON A FIRE HOW
MANY OF THOSE THAT WE HAVE IN
THE STATE.
SO RIGHT NOW WE WE HAVE OUR OUR
HUGH EASE THAT ARE THERE TWELVE
PLUS THE RESERVE AND THEN.
WE WE HAVE --
TWELVE NEW HELICOPTERS --
BLACKROCK STYLE TO THEIR SEVENTY
AYE HELICOPTERS THAT ARE COMING
THOSE ARE JUST CAL FIRES
RESOURCES --
SO SORRY SOME AREAS MAY HAVE.
HELICOPTERS SOME MAY NOT.
THEY GENERALLY AND HIGHER FIRE
PRONE AREAS AND WHAT KIND OF I
MEAN OTHER I GUESS THE QUESTION
IS -- WERE
WHERE WE HAVE --
HI FIRE PRONE AREAS AND THAT'S A
LOT OF ACREAGE I'VE SEEN THE MAP
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH IT THE WHOLE
STATE.
HOW MUCH HOW MANY?
HOW MANY HELICOPTERS PER ACRE I
MEAN IT'S ALMOST WE ALMOST HAVE
TO DO THIS THE MAP THAT WAY?
YEAH WE AND WE WE TWENTY FOUR
HELICOPTERS DOESN'T SEEM LIKE A
LOT.
WELL AND IT'S IT'S FEWER THAN
THAT ON THE CAL FIRE SIDE BUT
THERE ARE FEDERAL HELICOPTERS
AND AIR TANKERS WE HAVE AIR
TANKERS AS WELL.
AS WELL AS AIR ATTACK --
THAT THAT IS A IN A PLANE AND
THEN THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS A
LOT OF THESE RESOURCES AS WELL
PARTICULARLY HEALTH KERR WHO'S A
REX SYSTEM.
WHAT A FEDERAL HELICOPTER OR
MUNICIPAL HELICOPTER BE DEPLOYED
AT WHOSE DIRECTION?
USUALLY IT'S IT IS NOT --
YES IS IT IS.
IT WOULD BE THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA RIPLEY FEDERAL THE
FOREST SERVICE --
DISPATCH CENTER IF IT'S IN --
WILDLAND RESPONSE AREA. ONE OF
THOSE TWO AND THEN WE WOULD
EXPAND FROM THERE --
AS WE NEEDED MORE AND ALL THEIR
MEALS AS YOU WOULD BE AWARE MADE
AWARE OF ANY PARTICULAR FIRE
WHETHER IT'S ENOUGH FEDERAL OR
STATE OR MUNICIPAL.
YOU'D BE AWARE YES AND THE THOSE
TWO COORDINATING CENTERS THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THAT THE
WEATHER IS IS COMING OUT OF FOR
THE ROOF OF THE REGIONAL CENTERS --
A READING AND AND REVERSE AND
THIS AND THEN OUR DEPARTMENT OF
INTERIOR --
COUNTERPARTS AS WELL ALL WORKING
TOGETHER SO SO THEY'RE THEY'RE
COORDINATING THEIR CORNING THE
THE THE AERIAL KIND OF RESPONSE
TO WILD FIRES AND THEN.
COORDINATING THE MOVEMENT OF
RESOURCES AROUND THE STATE AND
INTO THE STATE FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHARE.
THANK YOU --
WE'VE GOT A NUMBER OF MEMBERS
THAT QUESTIONS WE'RE GOING.
TO AT THIS TIME --
GO TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND FIRST OF
ALL THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
AND ALL THE WORK YOU AND YOUR
TEAM TO DO --
I JUST MY FIRST QUESTION GOES --
TO MISS PETERS --
I WAS LOOKING AT ON PAGE THREE
THE LITTLES COME OUT OF THE FIRE
THE THE PROPOSALS.
MY CONCERN IS ON THIS IS FOR
SOME THIRTEEN BRAND NEW FIRE
ENGINES AND MIKE WHERE THIS IS
COMING FROM IS IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT WE'VE HAD A LOT OF OUR FIRE
FIGHTING EQUIPMENT IS GETTING
OLD.
IT'S BEEN USED A LOT OF THEM I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
AT LEAST THOSE PEOPLE ON THE
GROUND THAT WE HAVE THE CORRECT --
TOOLS THEY CAN THEY NEED TO DO
THEIR JOB SO IS THAT IN ADDITION
TO AND ARE THE ON ORDER I HOPE
BECAUSE IT TAKES YEARS AGO.
YOU SAID THESE ARE ADD NEW
ADDITIONAL ENGINES --
SO THIS WOULD INCREASE THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF FIRE ENGINES THAT
CAUGHT FIRE HAS AND ALSO
INCREASE HE NUMBER THAT ARE
OPERATED ON EACH YEAR ROUND
BASIS -- IN
TERMS OF EQUIPMENT --
WEARING DOWN IN NEEDING TO BE
REPLACED AT IN TERMS OF THOSE
ENGINES AND THAT THERE THE THE
BUDGET HAS TYPICALLY INCLUDED
FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS ON A
ONE TIME BASIS AND THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.TO INCREASE CAL FIRES
ABILITY TO REPLACE --
ENGINES AND AND OTHER MOBILE
EQUIPMENT BECAUSE IT'S JUST
WEARING OUT MORE QUICKLY I'M
BECAUSE IT'S BEING USED MORE
HEAVILY ON THAT NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET MAKES THAT THREE MILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION PERMANENT.
AN ON GOING --
THE KEEP IN MIND AND AGAIN THIS
IS GOES TO YOUR EXPERTS THAT ARE
SITTING THERE BUT IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT --
THESE THESE A FIRE ENGINES ARE A
LOT MORE EXPENSIVE THE MAYBE WE
HAVE BUDGETED --
FOR SO I'M HOPING THAT WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION A TRUE CONVERSATION
WITH THIS --
OUT HOW FAR TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE FUNDS WHAT THEY NEED --
THE OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE
OF THOSE I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
WHEN SAFE BUT I KNOW THAT THESE
ARE NOT CHEAP AND I KNOW IT
TAKES A LONG TIME TO ORDER THEM
AND GET THEM BACK TO YOU IN A
TIMELY FASHION SO.
THAT'S THE WHAT'S ONE THING
SOUTH AROUND FOR ME.
THE OTHER ONE IS THAT --
ON LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION --
SO YOU'RE ASKING --
YES AND CAL FIRE TO DO AN
ASSESSMENT ARE YOU'RE
RECOMMENDING AN ASSESSMENT WOULD
BE BE FUNDING ADDITIONAL STAFF
FOR THEM TO DO SO --
BECAUSE OF TO ME THEY'RE
STRETCHED WAY.
TO SO -- I
HATE MAKING PROMISES THAT WE
CAN'T FILL AND PUTTING THEM IN A
SITUATION OF MANDATING SOMETHING
THAT SHOULDN'T BE MANDATE.
SO.
SURE AND YEAH SO OUR OUR
RECOMMENDATION IS TO TO YOU ALL
TO CONSIDER REQUIRING THEM TO DO
IT -- I
THINK TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT
CAUGHT FIRE AND YES INDICATE
THAT THEY MIGHT NEED SOME
RESOURCES TO DO THAT IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE TO PROVIDE THEM
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
AND WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
CONTEXT OF PROVIDING A COUPLE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR ANOTHER CLOSE TO A
BUDGET YEAR.
AND AND LIKELY ADDITIONAL
AUGMENTATIONS OF THAT SCALE.
GOING FORWARD FOR THE
FORESEEABLE HAVE THESE VERY
SEVERE --
FIRE CONDITIONS AND HAVING IT
BETTER INFORMATION TAKE GUIDE
THOSE AUGMENTATIONS COULD HELP
THE STATE TO SAVE MONEY IN THE
LONG RUN AND ENSURE THAT WHILE
YOU DO HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES
AND LIMITED CAPACITY TO MAKE
THESE TYPES OF INCREASES.
THAT IT'S REALLY GOING TO THE
PLACES THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE
THE MOST BENEFITS.
AND AND REALLY MEET THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY NEEDS YEAH.
IT'S ALWAYS IMPORTANT TO ME IS
THAT WE HAVE THE SHORT TERM.
IDEAS BUT WE NEED TO MAKE THIS
LONG TERM THIS IS THIS IS IN
KEEP GOING ON SO I JUST WANNA AT
THE STRESS THAT.
THE OTHER ONE IS TECHNOLOGY I AM
ALL FOR TECHNOLOGY IS A MATTER
OF FACT ON MY TIME OFF THIS PAST
YEAR SPEND SOME TIME LOOKING AT
THE TECHNOLOGY.
SPENT SOMETIME SCRIPTS. TO WATCH
WHAT THEY'RE DOING --
I AM THOROUGHLY IMPRESSED THAT --
WE COULD REALLY PRE POSITION
PEOPLE WHERE EARLIER WHEN WE
KNOW WHAT THE WIND IN THE ERRORS
THE IT THE AIR SPEEDS ARE GOING
ON THOUGH.
THE WATER STREAMS --
BUT I DON'T WANT TO FORGET
SOMETHING THE DUE TO SAID
DIRECTOR DOES EVERYTHING.
THE RIGHT AROUND COULD HAPPEN
AND WE TALK ABOUT FIRES.
AND THAT'S FROM MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THE NUMBER ONE THING THAT
COULD HAPPEN DURING --
THAT PERIOD OF TIME IF WE WERE
TO HAVE EARTHQUAKES AND MAY BE
ABLE TO BE PREPARED FOR THAT AS
WELL AND I'M SURE ALL OF YOU ARE.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GIVE
YOU THE TOOLS TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE.
GOING TO DO THIS COMPREHENSIVE
LOOK AT THIS LET'S NOT FORGET
THE EARTHQUAKE ARE YOU KNOW --
AREN'T COULD HAPPEN WE HAVE MORE
FLOODING ABOUT THE FIRES --
BUT WE JUST ARE FOCUSED RIGHT
NOW ON THE FIRES WHICH A ARE
REALLY WELL FIRST WHICH IS SO
IMPORTANT.
THEY'RE PART OF MY DISTRICT I
DON'T WANT TO FORGET ABOUT MY
FRIENDS IN THE BAY AREA AND
ALONG THE COASTLINE.
SO THANK YOU.
THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO A
CELL NUMBER MELENDEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST
HAVE ONE QUESTION RELATING TO
YOUR TO MANNING ISSUES SINCE
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TECHNOLOGY
AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE HUMAN
RESOURCES TO GO ALONG WITH.
THE TECHNOLOGY SO --
ARE YOU GOING TO HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE TO MAN THE HAND KERR'S
ACROSS THE STATE AND I'M GONNA
HAVE ENOUGH PEOPLE TO MAN.
THE AIR TANKERS --
I CRIED WITH WITH THE FOR
SERVICE TO BE ABLE TO BATTLE
SOME OF THESE FIRES I KNOW WE'VE
HAD TO AT LEAST A FOR SERVICE HE
SAID TO ME SHE'S WITH THAT IN
THE PAST BUT I'M JUST CURIOUS --
AGAIN IT'S AT TO FISCAL ISSUE
BUT IT GOES HAND IN HAND I THINK
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
TECHNOLOGY IN BEING ABLE TO
MONITOR --
WELL THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
AND AND THE THE ANSWER ON HAND
CRUZ IS WE'RE WE'RE VERY MUCH IN
THE STATE SYSTEM --
RELYING ON OUR INMATE
FIREFIGHTING HAND CREWS --
THOSE THOSE IN MAKE CREWS --
IT WE WITH THEY'VE SEEN A
DWINDLING NUMBER.
OF MEMBERS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
US AND SO WE'RE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
DOWN ABOUT THIRTY CREWS --
BELOW WHAT ARE OUR CAPACITY IS --
SO OF COURSE THAT IS A CONCERN --
WE ARE --
BACK FILLING SOME OF THOSE --
A WITH ADDITIONAL OF SEE SEE SEE
FIRE DATA CORRECT DEDICATED
CREWS -- AND
AND THEN THE OF ENTER A TRAINING
CENTER -- IS
IN ITS --
WHAT WE'RE CALLING SECOND COHORT
PROGRAM TO BE FOR FIRE CREW AS
WELL?
OKAY JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT
HOW MANY TRAINEES DO YOU
ANTICIPATE RECEIVING OUT OF THAT
SECOND COHORT BECAUSE YOU SAID
YOU'RE DOWN THIRTY CREWS.
RIGHT SO IT WOULD BE TO THEIR
TWO CREWS THEY'RE CURRENTLY CAME
TO CREWS WERE THE PEOPLE OKAY --
IT ONCE THAT.
GIFT THAT PROGRAM CONTINUES AS
AS IT'S IT'S FUNDED WE WILL
ULTIMATELY HAVE FOR CREWS
WORKING OUT OF THEIR PLUS THE
THE CCC CREWS --
AND THEN WE ARE STILL WORKING
WITH CDC ARE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE GETTING AS MANY POSSIBLE
INMATES AS WE CAN INTO THE
SYSTEM. TO REPOPULATE THE CAMPS
THAT ARE --
THAT ARE.
AT A DEFICIT FOR CREW MEMBERS
CURRENTLY SO ALL OF THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT WERE WORKING ON TO
TO BRING UP THE CREW COUNTS --
AS FAR AS YOU CAN I'M GONNA
MOVED AIRCRAFT --
SO FOR AIRCRAFT THE AIRCRAFT
THAT WE HAVE TO FLY --
WE CONTINUE TO HIRE --
PILOTS AS WE NEED --
TO IT FOR REFERENCE THE
HELICOPTER PILOTS --
FOR CAL FIRE OUR STATE
CALIFORNIA AND LOUISE --
THE FIXED WING --
AIR TANKER PILOTS ARE ON A
CONTRACT BASIS WITH DYINGCORPS
AND SO DYNCORP.
PROVIDES THOSE THOSE PILOTS TO
FLY OUR PLANES --
AS WE MOVE INTO --
THE THE C. --
ONE THIRTY RR --
WE HAVE THAT LARGE AIR TANKERS --
PART OF WHAT'S IN THE PROPOSED
BUDGET -- IS
A PROGRAM THAT WOULD ALLOW THOSE
PILOTS HEAD OF GETTING THE
AIRCRAFT THAT ARE HERE AND READY
TO FLY SO.
SO THE MINUTE WE HAVE THE
AIRCRAFT --
THAT IS OUTFITTED AND READY TO
DROP RETARDANT.
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
IMMEDIATELY PUT THE PILOTS ON
THAT AND FLY THOSE THOSE SHIPS
WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
AN EXTENDED TRAINING PERIOD --
TO THAT WOULD KEEP THOSE FROM
FLYING MISSIONS DURING THAT
PERIOD.
OKAY SO I HAVE TO FOLLOW UPS IF
I MAY MISTER CHAIRMAN --
LET'S GO WITH THE LAST THING
WITH REAL RELATING TO THE AIR
TANKERS --
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT TRAINING
YOU KNOW OUR OWN PERSONNEL BUT
OR ARE YOU WE STILL CONTRACTING
OUT.
WITH THAT BECAUSE I KNOW FOR
INSTANCE IN THE CITY THAT I LIVE
IN LAKE ELSINORE WE HAVE MANY
TIMES IN THE PAST YEAR SEEN THE
BIG TANKER COMMAND.
AND YOU KNOW PHILIP IN THE LAKE
IN AND GO OUT THERE SO ARE WE
STILL DOING THAT I BELIEVE ONE
OF THE COMPANIES WAS EVEN BASED
OUT OF CANADA I THINK.
THAT WOULD BE --
SUPER SCOOPER STAMP --
AND THEY THEY FILL WITH WATER
THEY DROP WATER LIKE HELICOPTERS
DROP WATER NOT THE RED STUFF.
THE WATER --
THAT IS NOT SO EIGHT DOES --
ON A ROUTINE BASIS WE DO ON
OCCASION HIGHER --
THOSE THOSE THOSE TYPE OF AIR
TANKERS --
LA COUNTY.
DOES ANNUALLY AND THE FOREST
SERVICE HAS BEEN ANNUALLY OKAY
SO YOU GUYS TYPICALLY DON'T DO
THAT IT'S NOT BECAUSE THERE'S A
COST BURDEN HERE JUST IT'S JUST
NOT PARTY HERE.
IT'S IT'S TYPICALLY ONE WHERE
WHAT WHEN WHERE UTILIZING --
FIXED WING AIRCRAFT WE WANT
RETARDANT ON THE GROUND THEY
DON'T DROP RETARDANT.
IS A OF A PERSISTENT LONG
LASTING APPLICATION TO THE THE
THE FUELS.
WHERE WATER ONCE IT DISSIPATES
COURSE IT'S WATER?
OKAY AND THEN JUST TO FALL JUST
AS A FINAL QUESTION A FOLLOW UP
ON THE THE CRUISE.
STONE WHEN YOU'RE DOWN THIRTY
CRUZ I KNOW YOU'VE GOT SOME --
PEOPLE BEING TRAINEDNOW THAT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE IT'S GOING TO
PUT JANUARY NEAR WHERE YOU WOULD
LIKE TO BE ACT IDEALLY.
SO.
I STILL HAD THE LINGERING
QUESTION OF HOW.
IF YOU CAN AT ALL ADDRESS THE
SHORTAGE OF PERSONNEL TO BE ABLE
TO DO THE JOB YOU NEED TO DO
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR AND
SOMETIMES.
ON THAT MEANS MORE MONEY
SOMETIMES IT MEANS A DIFFERENT
STRATEGY BUT I'M JUST IF YOU
COULD.
ANSWER THAT IN THE BEST WAY THAT
YOU CAN AT THIS POINT.
HEY ANY AND IT.
REMAINS A GREAT QUESTION AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD --
FOR THE LAST FOUR YEARS --
START ARE IN MAY --
YEAH MEMBERS ON THOSE ON THOSE
CREWS AND WE'RE HOVERING.
AND SO --
THINGS HAVE NOT GOTTEN WORSE IN
THE LAST YEAR OR SO BUT THEY
HAVEN'T GOTTEN A LOT BETTER
EITHER SO --
WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT ALL
OPTIONS --
EVERY OPTION EXCEPT FOR AN
INMATE IS VERY EXPENSIVE --
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT --
POSSIBLE OPTIONS THAT WE HAVE
OUT THERE.
AND AND KIND OF JUST TO PIVOT
THIS --
CONVERSATIONAL LITTLE BIT BACK
TO THE GAP ANALYSIS --
CAL FIRES THE STRATEGIC PLAN --
I JUST SPENT THE LAST YEAR
WORKING --
WITH CHEAP PIMLOTT AND OUR
EXECUTIVE TEAM --
IN MY PREVIOUS ASSIGNMENT
DEVELOPING THAT.
AND THE FIRST GOAL IN THAT
STRATEGIC PLAN STARTING THIS
YEAR TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN GOING
FORWARD IS TO DO THAT GAP
ANALYSIS.
AND SO WE ARE LAUNCHING ON THAT --
AS WE SPEAK FORM BETTER HOW MUCH
WE NEED WHERE WE NEED IT.
AND THEN THE COST.
AND WE'RE GONNA BRING IT.
WE'LL LET YOU GO AHEAD AND CHECK
MY MAIL QUICKLY JUST ON THE IN
MAY --
PROGRAM CAN YOU EXPLAIN A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT EXACTLY HOW --
THE INMATES ARE CHOSEN TO
TRAINING AND HOW MUCH THEY'RE
PAID.
SO ARE ARE IN MAY PROGRAM --
A THE INMATES THAT ARE SELECTED
THEIR SELECTED BY CDC ARE THEY
HAVE TO MEET A SCREENING
CRITERIA --
ONCE THEY MAKE IT THROUGH THAT
SCREENING CRITERIA THEN THEY
HAVE TO MAKE IT THROUGH A
TRAINING PROGRAM AT ONE OF ONE
OF OUR CAL FIRE IN MAY TRAINING
PROGRAMS --
THEY GO THROUGH THAT --
AND LET'S JUST SAY THEY THAT
THAT THEY MAY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT MAKES IT THROUGH --
THEN THEY GET DEPLOYED OUT TO
ONE OF OUR CAMPS --
IT'S SOMEWHERE IN THE STATE.
HOW MANY DEFICIT --
MEMBERS WE HAVE --
POTENTIALLY AND THEN ALSO --
MAKING SURE THAT THEIR SORTED
APPROPRIATELY --
FOR SOME OF THE CONCERNS WE
MIGHT HAVE MIXING --
TYPES OF IN ME --
AND SO --
ONCE SAID THERE THEN THEY ARE
PAID -- AT
THE SAME RATE THAT ALL OF CDC
ARE IS PAID ON A DAILY BASIS.
ANY ANY INMATE THAT'S IN A A
PROGRAM --
IS PAID THE SAME AMOUNT.
WHEN THEY GO ON FIRES?
THEY ARE PAID AN ADDITIONAL
AMOUNT -- WE
PAY -- IN
ADDITION TO THEIR THEIR RATE
THAT THEY GET FOR THE WORK THAT
THEY'RE DOING --
IN OTHER PROGRAMS THEY GET AN
HOURLY RATE ON FIRES.
JOINT DAILY RATE ON FIRES.
BRING IT BACK TO OUR CHAIRMAN
DOT [inaudible]
YEAH -- HI
I'M WONDERING DOES THE DATA I
KNOW THAT --
WENT DOWN TO SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO
GAS ELECTRIC TO SEE THEIR
WEATHER MONITORING --
STATIONS AND ALL OTHER THREAT
ASSESSMENT AND THE WHOLE NINE
YARDS WHICH WAS --
YOU KNOW PRETTY DARN IMPRESSIVE --
AND I KNOW THAT --
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON --
IS DOING THAT --
ALTHOUGH NOT AS ADVANCED IN P.
GENIES ON AT THE TO OF
FACILITIES THAT YOU HAVE DO YOU.
SHARE IN THAT MONITORING --
THAT DATA.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OF THAT DATA OR
CAN YOU --
SHARE IN THAT DATA WHETHER IT'S
CAMERAS WHETHER IT'S YEAH THREAT
ASSESSMENTS AND THOSE TYPE OF
THINGS.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I THINK SEVEN BUT THE CELL
PHONES REALLY WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A SHARING OF RESOURCES WE
HAVE.
WE HAVE COMPANIES THAT ARE.
YOU KNOW REALLY DOING A GOOD JOB
MONITORING AND THEIR WATERSHEDS
THEIR AREAS AND EVERYTHING AND
INSTEAD OF RECREATING THE WHEEL
PUTTING NEW CAMERAS NEW --
WHETHER MONITORING STATIONS ALL
THESE PLACES I'D LIKE TO SEE --
WHAT WE CAN DO?
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ALL GUITAR
CUSTOMERS ARE PAYING THOSE BILLS
YEAH -- WE
OUGHT TO HAVE THAT DATA AND USE
THAT DATA A AND AND I CAN SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO SAN DIEGO --
HAVING BY A GUY COME FROM THERE
AND I I WAS THERE WHEN THAT
PROGRAM KIND OF LIST WAS
DEVELOPING --
AND YES IT'S VERY INTEGRATED --
THE SAN DIEGO --
GAS AND ELECTRIC AS WELL AS THE
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO AND THE
THE GAC WITH THE FOR SERVICE --
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR AND CAL
FIRE AND YES ALL INCLUDED IN
THAT FROM RIVERSIDE --
AND AND YOU SEE WORKS THROUGH --
SOME OF THE NUANCES OF ALL OF
THOSE THINGS WHETHER IT'S
CAMERAS OR SHARING DATA ON THE
FINE GRAIN WHETHER OR SYSTEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED
THROUGHOUT THE PARTICULARLY SAN
DIEGO BUT THEN ALSO MOVING INTO.
TO ORANGE RIVERSIDE LOS ANGELES --
YOU COUNTIES FOR SURE BUILT THE
AND THEN TOOLS LIKE --
YOU MAY HAVE SEEN OR BE AWARE OF
THE SANTANA WILDFIRE THREAD
INDEX IT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT
IS MANAGED OUT OF THE GAC BUT IT
DRAWS ON ALL OF THAT FINE GRAIN
WHETHER --
DATA -- TO
TO DEVELOP THE THE SEVERITY AND
THE TIMING THAT THAT THE THREAT
INDEXES GOING.
TO JUMP FROM ONE LEVEL TO
ANOTHER OR THEN THEN REDUCE AND
THEN ALL OF THAT SAME DATA IS
BEING USED AND SHARED.
BACK -- TO
SDG ANY IN THIS CASE --
TWO FOR FOR THE UTILITY TO MAKE
THEIR DECISIONS ON WHAT THEY'RE
DOING WITH WITH --
PUBLIC SAFETY POWERSHOT OFFICE
AS WELL.
SO I'M NOT.
GO AHEAD WELL I GUESS ONE OF
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE I MAKE
IT A PERFECT WORLD BOB AND THIS
ONE OF THE THINGS WERE WERE
TRYING TO WORK TOWARDS HIS IS
LEVERAGING ALL OF THAT WE WE
HAVE ACCESS. TO MANY OF THE
CAMERA SYSTEM WE DON'T HAVE THAT
STORY ACCESS TO THE INDIVIDUAL
UTILITIES.
DATA THAT IS COMING FORWARD AND
THAT IS. ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
TRYING TO WORK TOWARDS.
TO YOU KNOW MUCH LIKE WE HAVE
AND I GOT I MENTIONED BEFORE ARE
DATA COMING IN FOR MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT SOURCES THEN THEN THEN
OF COURSE YOU NEED ANALYSTS TO
BE ABLE --
TO YOU KNOW UNDERSTAND THE DATA
THAT YOU'RE SEEING AND AND PUT
IT IN THE ANALYTICS SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO MAKE DECISIONS ON
THAT YOU KNOW BECAUSE OTHERWISE
YOU'RE JUST LOOKING AT A LOT OF
A LOT OF STUFF COMING IN SO --
BUT YOUR POINT IS THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS TO SOME THINGS WE DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO ALL OF THEM --
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO GET.
TO THEM ONE FINAL QUESTION.
IT OUT.
IT'S AMAZING OVER THE LAST YEAR
HOW MANY PEOPLE THAT I'VE TALKED
TO COME INTO MY OFFICE --
TO SHARE ON SOME INFORMATION
THEY HAVE WITH NEW TECHNOLOGY
WHETHER IT'S A RETARDANT OR
WHETHER IT'S A FIRST ALERT
SYSTEM OR ITS.
MONEY ALL MONITORING IT'S ALL
VERY VERY IMPRESSIVE.
IS THERE A CLEARING HOUSE THAT
WE'VE GOT IN THIS STATE THAT WE
COULD.
SAID THAT TOO BECAUSE WHILE IT'S
IMPORTANT --
I'M NOT SURE.
THAT WE NEED TO BE WOULD BE
HEARING ABOUT IT BUT THE PEOPLE
HAVE SOME PLACE TO GO IF THEY'VE
GOT SOMETHING GOOD.
THEY CAN HELP --
PUT THESE FIRES OUT QUICK ALERTS
FIRST MODERATE ALL THOSE TYPE OF
THING.
BOB THAT MAYBE YOU THEY HAVE
THAT SO.
I WANT TO CIRCUMVENT ME INCOME
RIGHT.
THANK YOU OKAY.
BECAUSE AFTER ALL YOU'RE THE ONE
THAT LOOK AT YOU GUYS ARE THE
ONES ARE ON THE GROUND.
THE NO ONE UNDERSTAND THIS STUFF
AND I THINK WE OUGHT TO BE
AVAILABLE AND HAVE THESE
OPPORTUNITIES. TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S ON THE MARKET
AND MOVE ON IT --
IF IF NEED BE.
HI YEAH AND I I AGREE AND WE DO
HAVE AN OPEN --
RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT OF
PROGRAM THAT HAS --
CHIEF OFFICER THAT REVIEWS EVERY
EVERYONE OF THESE CONCEPTS
THAT'S COME THAT COMES INTO OUR
OFFICE.
AND WE CROSS REFERENCE THAT AND
CATEGORIZE IT WITH WITH OTHERS
AND THEN --
SEND LETTERS BACK DEPENDING ON
WHAT.
SIT SOME OF THEM COME AS A
CONCEPT WITHOUT AN WITHOUT
ENOUGH DATA TO BE ABLE --
TO REALLY ASSESS WHAT IT IS THAT
THEY'RE DOING OR ASSESS WHETHER
IT WORKS OR NOT AND FOR THAT
INFORMATION --
IN A LOT OF CASES THEY'RE UNABLE
TO COME BACK WITH THAT
INFORMATION WHICH IS A SCREENING
TOOL FOR US BUT WE STILL KEEP
THOSE THOSE IDEAS IN THE IN THE
HOPPER.
AND WE PERIODICALLY COMPANY
SCREEN THROUGH THOSE AND LOOK --
FOR WE AWARE WE'RE STARTING TO
SEE SOME AGGREGATION OF OF OF
IDEAS THAT MIGHT HAVE A A PLACE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU --
SURCHARGE LETTER.
FIRST OFF LET ME BEGIN BY SAYING
THANK YOU CHIEF TO ALL THE MEN
AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM
FIREFIGHTERS FIRST RESPONDERS.
AND ALL THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
SHOULD MISSPELLING THESE THAT
WORK WITH YOU AND AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SERVICE.
AND MY CONDOLENCES TO ALL THE
FAMILIES THAT --
LOSS -- OF
FAMILY MEMBERS THAT THERE WERE
SO DEVASTATED BECAUSE OF THE
FIRES.
I'D LIKE TO MENTION THE THE FACT
THAT EXACT IN NOVEMBER WE HAD
ONE OF THE DEADLIEST --
DESTRUCTIVE FIRES IN CALIFORNIA
WITH EIGHTY FIVE DEATHS AND A
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE STRUCTURES.
AND IN ALSO IN JUNE WE HAD --
ONE OF THE LARGEST AGAIN
MENDOCINO.
COUNTY THAT LOS FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY ACRES.
AND THE REASON I BRING THAT UP
IS BECAUSE WE HAVE ELEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS TO LIVE
WITHIN THE WILDLAND.
URBAN INTERFACE AND SO THAT
TELLS ME THAT WE'RE NOT DOING
SOMETHING.
RIGHT HERE BECAUSE 95% OF THE
FIRES THAT ARE OUT THERE ARE MAN
MADE MAN CAUSED AND YOU KNOW
SUCH THINGS AS THE LAWN MORE
DURABLE --
BUT WHETHER BE TARGET PRACTICE
FIRE [inaudible]
CAMPFIRE MIGHT BE.
BUT I THINK WE'RE WHAT I'M NOT
HEARING IS A PROGRAM TO GET TO
THE GENERAL PUBLIC. TO BRING US
ALL TOGETHER A GREAT PUBLIC
RELATIONS PROGRAM.
YOU KNOW ASKING FOR A FEW
MILLION DOLLARS AS AN EXAMPLE
FOR PUBLIC AWARENESS PUBLIC
RELATIONS SOMEWHERE JUST BLASTED
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
WHEN IT'S FIRE SEASON ALL OF US
HAVE GOT TO PARTICIPATE?
WHEN YOU HAVE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WOULD LOVE TO
PICK UP THAT PHONE TO BE YOUR
EYES AND EARS --
BUT WE'VE GOT TO TELL THEM THAT
IT'S US.
OFF THE HUMAN BEANS 95% OF THE
ONCE BECAUSE HE'S FIRED WE GOT
TO BE AWARE OF IT SOUL.
OF FIRE PREVENTION I THINK IS
THE KEY BUT THE PLEASE ALL
SUPPORT ANYTHING YOU BRING
BEFORE ME.
IN AND I'M SURE MY COLLEAGUES
ARE THE SAME WHEN IT TALKS ABOUT
PUBLIC RELATIONS AND PUBLIC
AWARENESS.
BECAUSE THEIR LIVES OUT THERE
WE'VE GOT A SHAPE OUR OUR OUR
FORESTS THAT ARE SO PRECIOUS OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND SOMEONE.
BUT OBVIOUSLY NOTHING MORE
PRECIOUS THAN THE HUMAN LIFE
ITSELF.
SO I'D LIKE --
TO ASK YOU PUT YOUR TEAM
TOGETHER NATION'S PROGRAM NEXT
TIME AND I SHOULD [inaudible]
YOUR COMMENTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU COMMENTS AND AND I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE THAT THAT
THE PUBLIC EDUCATION --
IS IS PARAMOUNT TO OUR SUCCESS
IN MOVING FORWARD --
AB THE PEOPLE OF OR PLAY OR WORK
OR TRAVEL THROUGH FIRE COUNTRY.
ALMOST ON A DAILY BASIS AND
EVERYBODY CAN BE AFFECTED IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHERE YOU ARE.
IN THE STATE WILDFIRE AFFECTS
YOU.
AND THAT MESSAGE --
IS SOMETHING THAT THAT WE ARE
ARE WORKING ON A CAMPAIGN TO DO
MORE OF AND MORE --
METHODICALLY --
IN AREAS THAT WE HAVEN'T BEFORE --
AND SO I AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
CONCERNS AND THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT
AND LET ME SEE WHERE MY PEOPLE
ARE AND AND WILL CONTINUE.
TO WORK DOWN THE STREET BECAUSE
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE TEAMS YOU
PUT TOGETHER THE MEN WOMEN OTHER
WORKING FIGHTING THESE FIRES
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THE EQUIPMENT.
THAT YOU HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY TO
HAVE THAT MISSING ELEMENT IS THE
HUMAN. TO GO GO AND BE PART OF
IT IN.
SHOULD KNOW HOW TO PREVENT A
FIRE AND BE ABLE TO TO WORK WITH
YOU IN YOUR FIREFIGHTERS.
AND I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
THANK YOU.
BRING IT BACK --
TO BACK TO THE CHAIR HERE I'VE
GOT.
A COUPLE QUESTIONS COME UP JUST
LISTEN TO THE THE CONVERSATION
TESTIMONY --
ONE I RECALL PREVIOUS
DISCUSSIONS --
IN PAST YEARS ABOUT --
BOTH HELICOPTERS AND PLANES AND
THE ABILITY TO DROP.
AT NIGHT --
AND SOME LIMITATIONS THERE AND I
HEARD EARLIER DISCUSSION I THINK
WAS A CENTER SO --
ADDRESSING SOME NEW EQUIPMENT
SOME HELICOPTERS.
DOES THAT ADDRESS THOSE --
PREVIOUS LIMITATIONS --
IT DOES SO THE NEW HELICOPTERS
THAT ARE COMING UP FOR
CALIFORNIA --
WILL HAVE NIGHT BUYING
CAPABILITY --
AND SO AS IT STANDS WE ARE STILL --
IN A STANCE OF HELICOPTERS OF
THE ONLY THING WE USE AT NIGHT
FOR DROPPING --
MATERIALS FROM THEM WE USE OTHER
AERIAL --
SURVEILLANCE AND AND FOR
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS BUT THE
ONLY TOOLS THAT WERE USING AT
NIGHT FOR DROPPING WATER OR
RETARDANT ARE ARE FROM.
HELICOPTERS I JUST WANT TO MAKE
THAT CLEAR --
WELL THERE IS RESEARCH AND THERE
ARE PROJECTS THAT ARE LOOKING AT
FIXED WING --
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE ARE.
CURRENTLY EQUIPPED TO DO --
NOR -- THE
DO WE HAVE A NEAR TERM PLAN TO
DO THAT.
WITH THE CAL FIRE FLEET.
HOW EFFECTIVE --
OR IS THERE A DIFFERENCE IN FCP
AS IT RELATES TO DROPPING IN
DIAPERS IS DROPPING DURING THE
DAY.
SPENT TIME ON FIRES WE'RE WE'RE
BOTH HAVE OCCURRED --
NIGHT AND AND DAY --
WHAT?
WHAT THEY'RE THEY'RE KIND OF A
COUPLE OF DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
YOU LOOK AT FOR USE OF OF --
DROPPING OF WATER AT NIGHT --
LIFE SAFETY --
IF YOU ARE IN A ENVIRONMENT
WHERE YOU'RE IN THIS KIND OF A
CITY TYPE OF A SITUATION OR
CLOSE -- TO
LET'S JUST SAY A SCREWBALL WHICH
WAS A FIRE THAT HAPPENED LAST
YEAR WHERE YOU CAN YOU CAN DROP
WATER -- AND
WHERE YOU CAN SEE THAT IT'S
HAVING AN EFFECT --
THAT'S HELPFUL.
IF YOU CAN SEE THAT YOU ARE
DIRECTLY SUPPORTING --
TROOPS ON THE GROUND OR TO DO
SOMETHING THAT'S HELPFUL.
IF YOU'RE JUST DROPPING WATER
OUT ON FIRE LINE SOMEWHERE ON A
HILLSIDE --
AND THERE'S NO GROUND RESOURCES
TO DEAL WITH IT --
THERE IS THERE IT WILL SLOW THE
PROGRESSION OF THE FIRE A LITTLE
BIT.
BUT FIRE STILL GOING TO BE THERE
IN THE MORNING.
AND IT'S NOT PUTTING FIRE OUT SO
SO THE THE IT'S IT'S A TACTICAL
TOOL AND IT REALLY FOR US IS
SOMETHING THAT WE LOOK AT A LIFE
SAFETY OR MEDIA --
PROPERTY OF PROTECTION KIND OF A
MEASURE.
AND WE NEED TO HAVE PEOPLE RIGHT
THERE ON THE GROUND TO TAKE CARE
OF WHAT THEY NEED TO ON THE
GROUND ONCE THE DROP.
THE DRUDGE STATE YOU CORRECTED
THE DIVISIONAL.
QUICKLY COMING ONLINE.
WILL INCREASE OUR ABILITIES THIS
AREA.
CORRECT IT WILL INCREASE OUR
ABILITIES TO DO THAT FROM THE
CAL FIRE PERSPECTIVE WE ALREADY
HAVE PARTNERS THAT HAVE THAT
CAPABILITY AND WE UTILIZE THAT
CAPABILITY WHEN THOSE SHIPS ARE
AVAILABLE.
AND THEY HAVE SEEN THE THE THE
MISSION DURING THE DAY AND ARE
ABLE TO FLY THAT.
AND THEN MY FINAL QUESTION AND
EITHER OF THE DIRECTORS MIGHT
TAKE THIS IS.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
ADDITIONAL I THINK WAS FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS?
IN THE BUDGET --
FOR CAN SOMEBODY PUT THAT IN
CONTEXT FOR ME YOU KNOW WHAT'S
OUR CAPABILITY NOW WHAT IS FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GET US WHAT IS A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS GET US
WHAT IS THE WHAT YOU KNOW IN A
PERFECT WORLD HOW MANY CAMERAS
MIGHT WE HAVE.
IT IS THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION --
I I CAN'T TALK TO THE PERFECT
WORLD -- I
CAN TALK TO WE'VE ALL BEEN
TRYING.
WHAT I CAN TALK TO IS --
WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
FIVE CAMERAS THAT WE CURRENTLY
UTILIZE --
AND SO.
WE MOST OF THOSE ARE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THE HIGHEST
SATURATION IS IN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND THEN AS YOU AS
YOU MOVE NORTH GETS LESS.
MORE AROUND SOME OF THE PUBLIC
POPULATED AREAS LESS WHEN YOU
GET OUT INTO THE THE MORE REMOTE
LANDSCAPE.
WE THIS HUNDRED CAMERAS BECAUSE
THAT THE FOR THAT FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS POINTS --
TO HUNDRED ADDITIONAL CAMERAS --
AND SO THAT WILL MORE THE NUMBER
OF CAMERAS THAT WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT AND SPREAD THEM ACROSS THE
REST OF THE STATE WHETHER IT'S
ENOUGH -- I
CANNOT SAY WE'LL HAVE TO DEPLOY
IT IS WHAT WE BELIEVE WE CAN
DEPLOY.
AND WE HAVE LOCATIONS TO DEPLOY
WITHOUT.
BUILDING NEW --
SITES TO DEPLOY THEM.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS --
CENTER BRADFORD THEM CLOSER
GALGIANI SHOULD QUICK QUESTION
ARE JUST ONE IN A WITH THE CDC
OUR RADIUS.
I WOULD HAVE TO CHECK IT HAS
CHANGED RECENTLY --
IT IS IT IS NOT A LOT OF MONEY.
IT'S TWO DOLLARS.
A DAY.
AND THEN WE PAY --
ON FIRES ADDITIONAL TO THAT.
SO WE'VE WAITED.
WHAT IS YOUR RATE FOR THE FIRE --
AGAIN WE'RE WE'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF REASSESSING THAT AND AND IT'S
CHANGING --
CAN I GET CAN I GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT [inaudible]
ONE SIR GALGIANI.
I JUST WANTED TO COMMENT THAT I
AM VERY PLEASED TO KNOW THAT
YOU'RE THAT THE REQUEST FROM THE
GOVERNOR INCLUDES MONEY FOR THE
CAMERAS.
I MET LAST YEAR WITH --
I BELIEVE IT WAS CAN'T GRAHAM
THAT GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS MY USED
TO WORK FOR INTRODUCED ME TO AND
HE SHOWED ME --
HOW THE CAMERAS WORK ON HIS
LAPTOP IN AND WALKED ME THROUGH
THE PROCESS AND THE FACT THAT --
I GUESS IT'S SAN DIEGO GAS AND
AND I THINK THAT.
ANY ADDITIONAL TOOLS THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE YOU --
WE OUGHT TO DOEVERYTHING WE CAN
TO MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENED SO
I'M REALLY REALLY PLEASED THAT.
THAT WE ARE GOING IN THE DRESS
THAT DIRECTION AND WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN'T IT
SUPPORT THAT.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL.
QUESTIONS BY THE MEMBERS.
I'LL CONCLUDE BY ASKING THE
JUDGE IF YOU GUYS COULD GET US
BY THE COMMITTEE WITH SOME.
FURTHER INFORMATION ON THE
DEPLOYMENT OF THE CAMERAS WHAT
COVERAGE AREAS --
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL I THINK
REMEMBERS.
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR TIME --
IN YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO ITEM THREE
ON THE AGENDA.
HOW CURRENT AND FUTURE
TECHNOLOGY COULD BE USED TO
MITIGATE FUTURE WHILE FOR DAMAGE
WITH ASKED A NUMBER OF EXPERTS?
FROM THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S.
THE STATE RATHER --
TO PROVIDE SOME TESTIMONY ON
RESEARCH PROJECTS AND
INFORMATION ON THESE NEW TOOLS.
TO MITIGATE SO WE WOULD WELCOME
DOCTOR DEAL DRESS SCHOOL --
PROFESSOR OF GEOLOGY AND
GEOPHYSICS AT UNIVERSAL
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO --
CRAIG CLEMENTS PHD SOCIAL
PROFESSOR FIRE WITH THE RESEARCH
LABORATORY SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY [inaudible]
AND WE HAVE DOCTOR --
ALTERNATIVES PHD CHIEF DATA
SCIENCE OFFICER SAN DIEGO
SUPERCOMPUTER CENTER.
AND LOOKS LIKE DOCTORS ALREADY --
WITH THE FIRE RESEARCH GROUP
DEPARTMENT AT THE INTEREST
CALIFORNIA BERKELEY AS WELL AS
CHIEF --
FANTASY FROM GEORGE COVER FIRE
THREE SO THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
ATTENDANCE AND YOUR PRESENTATION
WILL GO AHEAD BEGIN WITH A
DOCTOR JUST CALLED.
CHAIRMAN DOT THE DOG THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
COMMITTEE OF PULLING THIS
TOGETHER --
WE HAD A DEVASTATING YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA HERE IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND WOULD LIKE
TO USE ALL THESE TOOLS AND
TECHNOLOGIES AT OUR DISPOSAL TO
NEVER GO THERE AGAIN.
SO HERE THE WAY WERE SEQUENCING
SOME OF THIS TODAY IS WE'RE
GONNA TALK ABOUT SENSORS FIRST.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
MODELING.
A I AND ALSO --
SO OFF WE GO SO HERE.
ALERT WILD FIRE --
GRAHAM CAN KEN SMITH --
MYSELF ALSO DUG TO ME AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF OREGON WE'RE ALL
SEISMOLOGIST WE STUDY
EARTHQUAKES.
SO YOU MUST BE ASKING YOURSELF
HOW DO WE GET IN THE FIRE CAMERA
BUSINESS.
AND THE REASON WE DID AS WERE
BUILDING LARGE DATA
COMMUNICATIONS CENTERS.
IN IN THE WORLD AREAS AND WE'RE
BRINGING THAT INFORMATION BACK
ON A RESILIENT MICROWAVE
PLATFORM.
OKAY SO WE'VE BEEN BUILDING
THESE NETWORKS FOR EARLY
EARTHQUAKE WARNING.
AND IT WAS GRAHAM KENT'S VISION
THAT WE SHOULD PUT FIRE CAMERAS
ON THESE AND MAKE THE MULTI
HAZARD.
I SHARE THAT VISION.
SO HERE --
SORRY --
CHAIRMAN GRAY STEPPED UP BECAUSE
THIS ANSWERED HIS QUESTION ABOUT
WHERE THE CAMERAS ARE.
AND HERE.
THIS IS A UNIVERSITY CONSORTIUM
BETWEEN UNIVERSITY NEVADA RENO
UC SAN DIEGO AND THE UNIVERSITY
OF OREGON.
IT WAS ESTABLISHED VERSES I TOLD
YOU -- WORK
TAHOE BOB GRAHAM CAN --
STARTED THESE THIS OFF WITH THE
FIRE CAMERAS.
THERE'S A HUNDRED TWENTY CAMERAS
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
OPERATING --
PROJECTED CAMERAS FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN OR TWO TO THREE HUNDRED
MORE.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL GIVE
US GREAT COVERAGE WHEN THE WIND
BLOWS.
FIRES YEAR ROUND WE HAVE FIRE
AND WE HAVE FIRE WHEN THE WIND
BLOWS.
OKAY SO HERE.
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
UTILITIES THEIR VISION SO
CALIFORNIA UTILITY SAN DIEGO GAS
AND ELECTRIC SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON.
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC HAVE
ALL PLAYED A BIG ROLE IN THIS
ROLL OUT OF CAMERAS AND IN FACT
SINCE DECEMBER.
WITH ROLLED OUT EIGHTY FIVE NEW
CAMERAS.
KAY AND THEY'RE ALL ACCESSIBLE
TO THE WILD FIRE DOT ORG WERE
YOU CAN ZOOM YOU CAN TIME LAPSE
YOU CAN SEE WHERE THE FIRE IS
WITH RESPECT TO YOU YOU CAN
TRIANGULATE.
SO THIS TOOL IS NOT JUST FOR THE
FIRST RESPONDER IT'S FOR THE
PUBLIC IT'S FOR CALIFORNIANS
GREATER JACK TO QUICK QUESTION
YES.
DE THESE CAMERAS INCLUDE THE
CAMERAS THAT WE JUST HEARD ABOUT
THAT WE S. OKAY YES.
KAY AND THEY'RE ACCEPTABLE WORK
AND I'LL CALL OUT LATER IN THE
STOCK BUT WE'RE COLLABORATING
WITH ORANGE COUNTY.
WITH MORAN WITH NAPA WAS CINEMA
ALL OF THESE COUNTIES OF COMMON
LINE AND THEY SHARE TOWERS AND
WE SHARE TECHNOLOGY AND THEY
HAVE ACCESS TO LIVE YOU AND
DRIVE THE CAMERAS.
OKAY THESE CAMERAS THERE NOT.
THE END ALL BUT THERE ANOTHER
TOOL WE NEED EVERY TOOL.
SO WE'RE WE'RE REALLY IN THE
BUSINESS OF MULTI HAZARDS QUE.
SO HERE THE ALERT WILDFIRE
NETWORK EMPLOYEES THESE HIGH
DEFINITION PAN TILT ZOOM AXIS
CAMERAS.
THEY HAVE NEAR INFRARED SO WE
CAN DETECT FIRE AT NIGHT.
MICROWAVE COMMUNICATION IS OUR
BACKBONE THIS IS WAS A AND IT
WON'T GO DOWN IF ONE OF OUR
TOWERS BURNS OVER WILL RE PATH.
THE SIGNAL OUT THAT'S WHY WE
NEED SOMETIMES MORE STATIONS IN
CERTAIN AREAS SO WE CAN GET THE
INFORMATION BACK IF WE CAN'T BE
UP DURING A DISASTER.
IT'S NOT A A GOOD SYSTEM.
SO HERE.
PROVIDES UNPARALLELED RESOLUTION
SO WE'RE NOT AN EARLY TO TAPPED
WERE A NINE ONE ONE CONFIRMATION
AND I'LL SHOW YOU HOW THAT WORKS.
NINE ONE ONE BEACH A HIGH.
SO.
WE GET THE CALL.
PEOPLE THE COMMAND CENTERS LIKE
CORE ACOSTA MONTA VISTA OR BEND
NICHOLS UP AND SAYING HOW LLENA.
THE THEY LOOK AND THEY SAY I GOT
A CALL OF A REPORT OF A FIRE IN
PINE MOUNTAIN.
THEY USE THE CAMERA THEY DON'T
SEE IT THERE THEY MOVE OVER AND
LOOK ON THE NEXT MOUNTAIN RANGE
LIKE AND GEYSER PEAK.
THEY FIND THE FIRE AND THEN THEY
CAN DISPATCH ACCORDINGLY AND
SCALE UP OR DOWN [inaudible]
SO HERE.
I WANT TO BRING THIS UP EARLY
BECAUSE THESE FIRES ARE HUGE
IMAGES OF CO. TWO ONE AVERAGE
SIZE FIRE.
A RACES ALL THE GAINS OF CAP AND
TRADE FOR A WHOLE YEAR SO LET'S
LOOK AT THIS CHART.
CAN I GET YOU TO SCOOT OVER GET
SOMETHING OUT OF A SORE NECK BY
THE TIME I'M DONE HERE TALKING
TO THIS.
SO HERE THIS HERE IS MILLION
METRIC TONS OF CO TWO EQUIVALENT.
LAST YEAR WE HAVE DATA IS TWENTY
TRADE WE REDUCED OUR CARBON
EMISSIONS FROM POWER PLANTS CARS
SO ONE BY ONE HALF MILLION
METRIC TONS.
HERE IF YOU LOOK AT THE ROUGH
FIRE.
THE ROUGH FIRE THAT HAPPENED IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN OMITTED ABOUT
EIGHT MILLION TONS OF CO.
TWO THAT ONE FIRE.
ERASED ALL CAP AND TRADE.
WE LOOK AT TWENTY THIRTEEN WE
DID REALLY WELL IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN ALMOST A REDUCTION OF
FOUR MILLION METRIC TONS.
BUT HERE IF YOU LOOK AT THE RIM
FIRE.
THE RIM FIRE NEAR YOU SOMEBODY
THAT RIMFIRE WAS HUGE AND
ADMITTED ABOUT TEN TO FIFTEEN
MILLION METRIC TONS OF CARMEN.
THESE ESTIMATES OF FROM THE
FOREST SERVICE THERE'S SOME
DISCUSSION AND ARGUMENTS ABOUT
HOW PRECISE THEY ARE.
BUT WE NEED TO TAKE THIS INTO
ACCOUNT WHEN WE THINK OF CO TWO
AND OUR CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
AND I JUST WANT TO SHOW YOU
SOMETHING.
IS BEING A GEOLOGIST YOU HAVE TO
DO TIME YOU KNOW DEEP TIME.
SO HERE WE ARE WE'RE LOOKING
BACK FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND YEARS
OKAY THESE ARE GLACIAL CYCLES
INTERGLACIAL GLACIAL
INTERGLACIAL GLACIAL.
LOOK WHERE WE ARE HERE WORK FOUR
HUNDRED AND TEN PARTS PER
MILLION ROGER REVELLE WHO
FOUNDED THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO.
SAID THIS WE ARE CAN.
AND I ADD TO THAT.
WE'RE IN IT.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE IN THIS
EXPERIMENT.
OKAY BECAUSE WE'RE IN A TIME.
OF EXTREME CLIMATE.
WE WOULD CALL IT OUR GROUP WOULD
COLLEGE WEATHER WHIPLASH.
OKAY [inaudible]
SO HERE.
JUST TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF SUMMARY
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IN THE
ADVANTAGES OF LARGE WILDFIRE.
WE HAVE RAPID NINE ONE ONE CALL
CONFIRMATION.
IT ALLOWS DISPATCHERS TO SCALE
THEIR RESOURCES.
THEY HAVE SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
THEY CAN SEE THIS ON THEIR
TABLET WHEN THEY DRIVE TO THE
FIRES HOW IT'S CHANGING IN REAL
TIME.
OKAY DURING EXPLOSIVE FIRE
BEHAVIOR WE'RE WE'RE JUST
SEQUENCING EVACUATIONS AND
MAKING SURE PEOPLE ARE SAFE AS
POSSIBLE THOSE FIRES THAT YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE JUST EXPLODE IN
THAT INCIPIENT.
FIRE -- MODE --
TIME AND AFTER CONTAINMENT.
RECONDITION THE HOLY FIRE IN
ELSINORE REIGNITED ALMOST IN THE
SAME PLACE A FEW WEEKS AFTER THE
INITIAL BURN.
QUE AND WE WERE ABLE TO CATCH IT
EARLY ON THESE CAMERAS.
SO THIS YEAR'S THE WALL FIRE WE
REPURPOSE THE OROVILLE DAM WERE
ABOUT FIVE MILES FROM THE WALL
FIRE.
LOOK AT THIS TORRENT ATTIC
ACTIVITY IN FRONT OF THE FIRE.
THE CAR FIRE HAD TORN ATTIC
ACTIVITY A HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE MILES AN HOUR.
THAT'S IT EF THREE THAT'S LIKE
THE TORNADOES THAT JUST RIPPED
THROUGH YOU KNOW GEORGIA AND
ALABAMA IT TAKES HOUSES OFF
THEIR PLATFORMS IT MOVES CARS.
CASE OF THIS IS ANOTHER THING
AND YOU KNOW WHAT IT DID IT GOT
THE ASHES UP ABOUT EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND FEET INTO THE
TROPOSPHERE.
AND THE SACRAMENTO RIVER WAS NO
FIRE BREAK QUE IT WENT RIGHT
ACROSS CASE OF THIS THIS TORN
ATTIC ACTIVITY WE'RE STARTING TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE DYNAMICS
THE ATMOSPHERIC DYNAMICS OF FIRE.
OKAY SO HERE THIS SITUATION
AWARENESS THIS IS THE PERRY FIRE
IN NORTHEAST RENO.
WE'RE ABLE TO SEE HOW WATER
DROPS AND RETARDED OR WORKING
WERE ABLE TO CONFIRM BACK TO THE
PILOTS TO DISPATCH YES THIS IS
THIS IS WORKING THESE.
DROPS AND I'LL SHOW YOU AN
EXAMPLE FROM THE HOLY FIRE.
UC SAN DIEGO'S ALL IN OUR
CHANCELLOR UNDERSTANDING IN
PROTECTING THE PLANET'S ONE OF
OUR BIGGEST GOALS.
AND IT'S THROUGH TECHNOLOGY LIKE
THIS AND OTHER TECHNOLOGIES WE
HAVE TO USE EVERYTHING.
IT'S NOT ONE OR THE OTHER
THERE'S NO PANACEA HERE WE HAVE
TO WE'RE ALL IN WE HAVE TO GO
ALL IN.
SO HERE WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE THIS
IS DOLLAR POINT LAKE TAHOE
BEAUTIFUL LAKE TAHOE IN THE
BACKGROUND.
WE USE AXIS SIXTY FIFTY FIVE
EACH CAMERAS HIGH DEFINITION YOU
CAN SEE THE CAMERA RIGHT THERE
WE HAVE A MICROWAVE DISH
OPERATING AT FOUR POINT NINE
GIGAHERTZ.
THIS IS A COMBINED FIRE AND
EARLY EARTHQUAKE WARNING SO WE
HAVE A STRONG MOTION SENSOR ON
WERE COLLABORATING WITH CALLOW
YES TO PUT SOME OF THESE STRONG
MOTION SENSORS ON OUR TOWERS
WERE WE HAVE BACK CALL.
AND WE CAN PROVIDE INSTANT --
DATA ON EARTHQUAKES.
SO HERE --
UNIVERSITY OF NEVADA PLAYED A
HUGE ROLE IN THIS.
THEY DEVELOP THE HARDWARE AND
SOFTWARE SO YOU CAN REMOTELY
CONTROL THE CAMERA'S QUE YOU CAN
PAN TILT ZOOM FROM YOUR DISPATCH.
YOU CAN SEARCH FOR FIRES GAY AND
EVERY ONCE IN AWHILE THEY GO
DOWN THIS WAS --
TREAT I GOT TO GO UP THE
BUCKSKIN MOUNT AND FEET.
AND THE ONLY THING THE GUYS FROM
YOU IN OUR SAID IS HE'S IN
SHORTS WELL I'M A CALIFORNIAN.
I WANTED TO WEAR SHORTS TODAY
BUT I GOT TOLD NOW.
SO HERE.
THIS IS THIS IS BUT TELL LAKE
HERE I WANT TO SHOW YOU SO PATEL
LAKES ABOUT FIVE KILOMETERS AWAY.
WHEN WE ZOOM IN THAT'S THE KIND
OF RESOLUTION WE CAN GET FROM
LIKE FIVE MILES AWAY?
SO WE CAN PAN TILT ZOOM WHEN WE
HAVE A NINE ONE ONE CALL AND SEE
WHERE THE FIRE MIGHT BE OKAY.
WE CAN ALSO TIME LAPSE SO WE CAN
GO BACK THROUGH TIME BECAUSE A
LOT OF TIMES DUST LOOKS LIKE
FIRE.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE YOU KNOW
MARINE LAYER THINGS LIKE THIS
YOU WANT TO SEE THEM TIME LAPSE
BECAUSE THEN YOU HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING IF IT REALLY IS
FIRE VERSUS SOME OTHER PHENOMENA.
THEY ALSO HAVE NEAR INFRARED SO
WE CAN SEE FIRES AT NIGHT WE CAN
TRY ANNUALLY THIS WAS AN ROSE
LEGAL SO WE COULD SEE.
THE FIRE DOWN IN MEXICO SO HERE
THE NEAR INFRARED PROVIDES YOU
KNOW DETECTION CONFIRMATION AT
NIGHT.
WE ALSO HAVE A BANNER THAT'S ON
THESE CAMERAS I JUST A LARGE AT
THIS IS CALIFORNIA MONTA VISTA
UNIT.
CORY ACOSTA WHO'S ON THE CAMERAS
ALMOST ALL THE TIME.
AND WE HAVE A ADVOCATE SO WE
KNOW WHO'S ON THE CAMERAS IF
IT'S CAL FIRE WE DON'T MOVE THE
CAMERAS.
OKAY SO HERE THERE'S AN
ETIQUETTE THAT'S BEEN BUILT
BETWEEN THE COUNTIES CAL FIRE
OUR SELVES IN THE UTILITIES OF
WHO MOVES THE CAMERAS.
SO HERE THIS IS THE Y. LACK FIRE
THIRTY FIVE SECONDS AFTER THE
NINE ONE ONE CALL WE DETECTED IT.
YOU CAN SEE IT HERE WE'RE
LOOKING TO THE SOUTH GOING TO
SHOW YOU SOME MOVIES HERE SO
YOU'RE GONNA SEE SOME DUST IN
THIS FRAME.
THATCOULD BE --
MISINTERPRETED AS FIRE ALL UP A
LITTLE BIT THERE VERY WINDY
CONDITIONS THIS WAS A PURPLE
FLAG WARNING THE ONLY ONE I'VE
EVER SEEN.
PURPLE FLAG HIGH WINDS LOW
HUMIDITY AND YOU'RE GONNA SEE
THE FIRE.
IT'S KIND OF SLOW ON THIS --
PC BUT HERE THE FIRE IS GOING TO
START RIGHT IN THIS AREA.
AND IF I CAN GET IT.
LET'S SEE IF I CAN GET IT.
NO I'M GONNA GO BACK ONE MORE
TIME AND SEE IF --
WE WERE WE WERE WARNED THAT
SOMETIMES VIDEOS DON'T PLAY WELL
ON THIS AND I HOPE MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE BETTER LUCK ON SOME OF
THEIR VIDEOS EVER.
IT'S GOING THERE YEAH.
SO YOU CAN SEE THE ANTENNA.
YOU CAN SEE SOME OF THE DUST
HERE SO THIS IS AN ENLARGEMENT
OF THIS CAMERA HERE.
SO WE'RE LOOKING TO THE NORTH
HERE WE'RE LOOKING TO THE SOUTH.
AND SO WE CAN --
IT REALLY ZOOM IN ON THESE FIRES
AND UNDERSTAND THAT AND THIS
EARLY DETECTION I'M GONNA NOT
PLAY THIS WHOLE VIDEO. TO SAVE
SOME TIME FOR THE OTHER MY
COLLEAGUES BUT HERE.
CHIEF MEACHUM WAS ABLE TO USE --
REPORTED IN.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ONE THE
EIGHT AND HE WAS ABLE TO USE THE
CAMERAS AND DETERMINE IT WAS IN
MEXICO SO WAS RESPONSE WAS
DIFFERENT.
THAN IF IT HAD BEEN IN THE
UNITED STATES IT ALSO GAVE HIM
YOU KNOW ON A FASTER RESPONSE
TIME OKAY.
SO HERE ON THAT PURPLE FLAG
WARNING THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
GIGABITS OF EMERGY WAS
DOWNLOADED AND WE'RE DOWNLOADING
TWENTY TERABYTES OF TRAFFIC
MONTHLY TODAY.
ALL RIGHT SO THE SYSTEM DOESN'T
GO DOWN WE UPLOAD IT TO THE WEB
THE CLOUD.
AND PEOPLE CAN ACCESS IT AND
IT'S BEEN RESILIENT.
THIS IS MY CALL OUT --
TO SAY HOW AWESOME IT IS TO SEE
THE UTILITIES ORANGE COUNTY.
OKAY --
DIVISION CHIEF BRIAN --
NORTON CHIEF BRIAN FANTASY --
COLLABORATING WITH THE UTILITIES
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND
THE UNIVERSITY AND IT'S THIS
KIND OF COLLABORATION THAT'S
REALLY PAYING OFF SO THIS IS MY
CALL OUT THAT THIS IS A REALLY
GREAT.
ACADEMIC PRIVATE SECTOR
COLLABORATION.
THIS HERE IS A FIRE FROM RAMONA
SO THIS HAPPENED RIGHT AFTER
VETERANS DAY RED FLAG WARNING.
THERE'S THE HELICOPTER THE SKY
CRANE FROM --
SDG ANY WAS CALLED IN THEY
SUPPRESS THE FIRE IN RED FLAG
WARNING IN AN HOUR.
OKAY IN --
THREE AND SEVEN WHAT --
FIRE CHIEF JOKER WOULD CALL THE
PACIFIC FIRE BREAK OKAY.
I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
AGAIN THEY WERE ON IT LET'S JUST
WATCH THIS AGAIN REAL QUICK
BECAUSE YOU GOT IT FOCUS.
YOU'RE GONNA SEE THE HELICOPTERS
COME IN RIGHT THROUGH HERE.
KATETHERE IT IS DUMPING THE
WATER ON IT AND THEY DUMPED
ALMOST TEN THOUSAND GALLONS OF
WATER IN THIS FIRE THERE WAS NO
SPAWNING.
AND THEY PUT IT OUT THIS IS THE
INCIPIENT FIRE.
ALL FIRES START SMALL.
IT'S HOW WE GET TO THEM AND NEW
TECHNOLOGY SHOULD AFFORD US
OPPORTUNITIES TO GET TO THEM.
SO HERE JUST WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WITH GOT CAMERAS NOW UP IN --
NORTH BAY.
SO HERE THESE CAMERAS OF BEING --
PUT IN WE HAVE FIFTEEN ALREADY
ANOTHER CAMERA JUST ONE UP TODAY
OUR CREW INSTALLED IT AT
PLACERVILLE.
SO EIGHTY FIVE CAMERAS SENSE
MIDDLE OF DECEMBER --
THIS HERE IS THE COYOTE FIRE IT
WAS INITIALLY REPORTED OVER HERE
ON PINE MOUNTAIN --
SHANNON CHRIS AT THE SAME ELENA
DISPATCH.
JUMPED OVER TO GEYSER PEAK AND
FOUND THAT THE NINE ONE ONE
CALLER GAVE MISINFORMATION WHERE
THE FIRE WAS AND IT'S IT'S HARD
WHEN YOU'RE FAR AWAY TO KNOW
WHAT'S RICH WINE IT'S COMING
FROM OKAY.
SO HERE --
NINE ONE ONE CONFIRMATION AND
THEY WERE ABLE THEN TO DISPATCH --
ENGINES TO THIS FIRE OKAY.
SO HERE WE'RE SEEING ABOUT TEN
MILES FIFTEEN MILES FROM OUT
TELL PIOUS ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
THE SAN FRANCISCO.
THESE CAMERAS HAVE GREAT
RESOLUTION.
THE PITCHER I LIKE TO SEE ON THE
CAMERA MOST IS RAIN.
OKAY THAT'S MY FAVORITE PICTURE
RIGHT THERE WHEN I SEE RAIN I'M
REALLY HAPPY.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS IN THIS WEATHER
WHIPLASH IS THE RAINS BRING
FLOODS AND THEY BRING NEW GROWTH
AND THEN WE'RE RIGHT BACK IN THE
HEAT OF IT WHEN THE WIND STARTS
BLOWING SO.
HERE --
PARADISE FIRE THIS JUST IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THIS INCIPIENT FIRE
BEHAVIOR.
YOUR WERE TREATING AND
EVACUATING.
K. -- NINE
JUST THIS IS THAT THIS INCIPIENT
FIRE PHASE WE REALLY NEED TO BE
ON THE FLYER AT THAT TIME.
WE CALLED CASCADING DISASTERS
YOU LOOK HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AIR QUALITY WAS TERRIBLE.
HERE IN THE STATE I FLEW IN THIS
IS MY PICTURE.
COMING IN ON THE END OF THE THE
FILTER OF POLLUTION IS SO HIGH
YOU CAN ACTUALLY SEE THE SUN'S
CORONA.
OKAY THIS AIR QUALITY IS IS HUGE
FOR ONE RELATED DISEASES THE
EMERGENCY ROOMS PEAKED ABOUT
THREE MONTHS AFTER THE CAMP FIRE
FROM ASTHMATICS AND AND PEOPLE
WITH HEART RELATED DISEASES.
OKAY IT JUST THESE THIS THE SAYS
CASCADING DISASTERS TO IT.
GAINES SO THIS IS THE HOLY FIRE --
IF --
DIVISION CHIEF BRYAN NORTON HAS
A CHANCE TO TALK TO THIS.
HIM AND TORY WOMEN WERE
CONTROLLING THE CAMERAS IN REAL
TIME HERE'S THE RETARDANT HERE'S
THE V. Là COMING IN AND MAKING
ANOTHER DOM --
THEY WERE ABLE --
TO KEEP THIS INFRASTRUCTURE ON
SAN DIEGO PEAK SAY FROM THE FIRE
SO IT'S ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF REAL
TIME --
ATTACKING THIS FIRE IN THIS IN
INCIPIENT FIRE PHASE.
SO THIS YEAR'S A MOVIE I HOPE
THIS ONE PLACE.
IT'S JUST REALLY SLOW --
SO THIS SHOWS THE FIRE AND WHERE
WERE WATCHING IT BRIAN'S
CONTROLLING THE CAMERA RIGHT NOW.
AND THE FIRES MOVING UP --
GETTING READY TO BURN OVER.
AND AT THIS TIME I WAS TALKING
TO EDISON AND TORY WITH MEN --
CALLED IN THIS FIRE --
FOR A DUMB FOR VIEW LOT.
AND WE'RE ABLE TO SAY THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE WE HAD
THIS.
CAMERA SYSTEM TO GIVE US
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS.
SO HERE LOOKING AT THE WOLSELEY
FIRE WE HAD JUST PUT UP CAMERAS
AT MOUNT WILSON SO WE SAW THEM
AT NIGHT WE ALSO SAW THEM FROM
OUR SITE THAT WE JUST PUT UP
HERE THERE'S WHERE THE FIRES ARE.
IN MALIBU AND YOU CAN SEE THIS
FIRE JUST A ROCKED AND HOPEFULLY
THIS THIS WILL PLAY BUT HERE
THIS IS THE WALLS THE FIRE YOU
GONNA WATCH IT JUST EXPLODE.
OKAY AND YOU CAN SEE HOW WINDY
IT IS THIS IS AN ANTENNA HERE.
AND IT'S JUST --
THIS FIRE JUST EXPLODED IN THIS
WHAT WE CALL THE INCIPIENT FIRE
PHASE.
OKAY -- I
WISH YOU WOULD PLAY --
THESE ARE ALL UP ON OUR WEBSITE
AT THE AND THE SIZE M<c.cyan> LAB --</c>
AND YOU CAN DOWNLOAD THESE BUT
THIS IS EXPLOSIVE FIRE ACTIVITY
KING.
SO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE'VE GOT
SEVENTY CAN.
YOU'VE GOT THREE OTHER SPEAKER
SO I I I I WISH I ROUTES ARE A
REALLY GOOD STUFF THAT I'D LET
ME I JUST LET ME JUST END UP
THEN.
WITH -- I
WAS GOING TO TALK ABOUT TREES
AND DEAD TREES WHICH THE
FERGUSON FIRE --
BUT HERE ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS THIS
IS MONA SETO TWENTY THREE PEOPLE
DIED OVERNIGHT HERE.
OKAY SO THERE'S THESE CASCADING
DISASTERS.
IMPLICATIONS FOR INSURANCE SO I
WANT TO JUST LEAVE YOU WITH WE
LIVE IN A TIME OF WEATHER
WHIPLASH.
AND EXTREMES AND THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO CHANGE YOUR GO AWAY AND
THE CO TWO IT'S MAKING OUR
ATMOSPHERE AND OCEANS MORE
ENERGETIC.
AND IT'S CAUSING THESE WHETHER
SWINGS FROM FLOODING IN GURNEE
BILL IN MAKING AN ISLAND IN THE
RUSSIAN RIVER. TO BURNING DOWN
WHEN THE WIND BLOWS.
YOU WANT TO PULL OVER YES
[inaudible]
WE GET. THREE MORE WITNESSES SO
CHAIRMAN DODD SAID --
WE'RE RUNNING A SHORTER TIME
HERE WITH THE HEARING ROOM SO
FEDERAL TO TRY TO KEEP THEIR
PRESENTATIONS TO ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES AND THE MORE OF COURSE
HAVE ALL MY CONTACT POLITICS.
YOUR INSPIRED NOTHING WRONG WITH
THAT IT'S GOOD INFORMATION --
WERE HAPPY TO HAVE YOUR DAY
SUPPLY I KEEP TALKING IF YOU
DIDN'T CHAIRMAN DOT DOT DIDN'T
SHOW.
OKAY.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN GRAIN THANK
YOU TRIMMING DOT FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY --
I'M GONNA SKIP TO A LOT OF SITES
TO CATCH UP ON TIME.
SO -- MY
BACKGROUND IS REALLY IN
METEOROLOGY AND SO THE FIRE
WEATHER RESEARCH LAB IS THE ONLY
ACADEMIC PROGRAM IN UNITED
STATES FOCUSED ON FIRE WEATHER
RESEARCH --
WE TEACH ONE OF ONLY TWO CLASSES
AND FIRE WEATHER AS SOON AS A
STATE.
AND SO OUR RESEARCH IS IN FIRE
WEATHER FIRE DANGER AND SUCH SO
I JUST WANT TO KIND OF CLICK
THROUGH A FEW THINGS REAL QUICK.
AS WE KNOW THE FIRE BEHAVIOR
TRIANGLE.
EXTREME FIRE BEHAVIOR IS A
FUNCTION OF FUELS THE STUFF
THAT'S BURNING THE TOPOGRAPHY
AND THE WEATHER AND THE WEATHER
IS THE MOST VARIABLE AND SO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY NEED TO
GET A HANDLE ON AND SO --
WHAT I WANT TO STRESS TODAY IS
WE'RE FAMILIAR WITH THE NEW
NETWORKS EVERYBODY'S PUTTING OUT
MORE WEATHER STATIONS?
THESE ARE THE SERVICE NETWORKS
THE DOTS ON THE MAP THERE ARE
ALL THE WEATHER STATIONS THE POT
OR THE PUBLIC OWNED WEATHER
STATIONS.
IN THE STATE AND PROVIDE REAL
TIME DATA BUT IT'S GENERALLY
HOURLY SOMETIMES FIFTEEN MINUTE.
IT'S REALLY THOSE DATA ARE USED
FOR FIRE DANGER RATINGS SO IF
YOU SEE SMOKEY THE BEAR AT A
PARK IN HIS HANDIS UP HIGH.
POINTING TO HIGH FIRE DANGER
THOSE DATA ARE WHAT MAKE THAT
CALCULATION.
AND SO.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE SERVICE
NETWORK WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IT'S REALLY GREAT TO
HAPPEN WE REALLY NEED IT FAR
WHETHER BEHAVIOR MODELS IS THAT.
IT DOESN'T CAPTURE THESE EXTREME
EVENTS WERE THE WILD FIRES
CREATE THEIR OWN WHETHER WE
STILL DON'T HAVE A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THAT IS.
AND SO --
THIS IS A ACTUAL SIMULATION
USING A COUPLE AND I JUST WANNA
CLICK TO SHOW YOU KIND OF THE
IT'S MOVING BUT THE STATE OF THE
SCIENCE OF FIRE WEATHER MODELING
IS A COUPLED MODEL.
IT'S WHERE THE FIRE IS DRIVEN BY
THE WEATHER AND THEN THE FIRE
ACTUALLY PUTS ITS HEAT INTO THE
WEATHER MODEL AND SO IT'S
COUPLED AND THAT'S KIND OF THE
STATE OF THE SCIENCE THE
COMPUTATIONALLY IS VERY HIGH.
BUT WE CAN DRIVE THOSE MODELS
AND SO IF WE SKEWS ME ASK DOT.
THIS IS THE SAME MODEL
SIMULATING THE TUBS FIRE THIS IS
MY STUDENTS WORK --
THE NUMERICAL SIMULATION OF THE
WINDS DURING THE TUBS FIRE AND
WHAT YOU SEE AND ONLY USES
POINTER HERE.
THIS IS NOT SAY HALINA THIS IS --
THIS COFFEE PARK AND THE REDS
ARE NGUYEN FROM RIGHT TO LEFT
AND YOU CAN SEE WHAT'S CALLED A
HYDRAULIC JUMP.
AND THAT'S EXTREME WHEN.
SURFACING AND WHERE THE
HYDRAULIC JUMP DIES LANDS.
DETERMINES IF IT CAN BE REALLY
REALLY WINDY OR NOT AND SO WE
DON'T REALLY UNDERSTAND
STRUCTURE WE CAN'T MEASURE THE
VERTICAL STRUCTURE IN THE
ATMOSPHERE.
AND AS A RESPONSE AND I JUST
WANNA SKIP TO THE SO WHAT
HAPPENS IS.
THE WINDS MOVE FROM A LAW AFTER
UP ABOVE IN THE HIGHER PART
ATMOSPHERE TO THE SURFACE REALLY
RAPIDLY.
AND SO.
WE DON'T MEASURE THAT WITH
WEATHER STATIONS RIGHT NOW SO WE
DEVELOPED A MOBILE AT MR
PROFILING SYSTEM THAT WE TAKE A
WILD FIRES --
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF INSURANCE ON
IT I WANT TO CLICK THROUGH WITH
TALK ABOUT A DOPPLER LASER RADAR
THIS RONA GET.
TO THIS INSTRUMENT CAN ACTUALLY
MEASURE PLUMES AND REAL TIME ON
A FIRE [inaudible]
SO THAT'S DEL PATEL FIRE PLUME
WE CAN ACTUALLY PROPUBLICA LIKE
X. RAY INSIDE THE FIRE AND WE
CAN MEASURE THE WINDS INSIDE THE
FIRE.
AND SO WE WERE THE ONLY --
ME LOGICAL TEAM IN THE U. S.
THAT'S FIRE LONG QUALIFIED.
AND SO WE OF ACCESS TO GET TO
THE FIRES OR A NATIONAL RESOURCE
WE GET REQUESTED INCIDENTS AS
WELL.
AND SO SEE HERE.
THIS IS THE CAMPFIRE WE DEPLOYED
TO THE CAMPFIRE WHEN IT IGNITED
AND WHAT YOU SEE.
IS THAT THE WINDS ARE REALLY
STRONG ALOFT WELL ABOVE THE
GROUND BUT THEY'RE NOT VERY
STRONG NEAR THE SURFACE EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE.
BUT THEY WEREN'T STRONG AND SO
WHAT WE CAN WHAT WITH THE
LIGHTER ALLOWS US TO DO IS LOOK
AT THE VERTICAL STRUCTURE OF THE
PLUME AND WHERE WE CAN'T WITH
THE SERVICE NETWORK.
WE ALSO FLEW AN AIRPLANE TO A
MAJOR FIRE ICE WHEN I HIGHLIGHT
THE RADAR.
THE LIGHT OR IS REALLY GOOD IT'S
A LASER BEAM THAT WE SIGNED INTO
THE FIRE BUT WITH THE RADAR WE
CAN ACTUALLY MEASURE BIG DEEP
COLUMNS BIG --
FOR PLUME DRIVEN FIRES AND SO F. --
AIRCRAFT WE FLEW IT THROUGH A
FIRE AND AND WHAT HAPPENED WAS
WE REALIZE THE DATE ARE SO GOOD
THAT WE REQUESTED A GREAT WE
PLAYED FOR A GRANT.
AND WE NOW HAVE THE ONLY MOBILE
RADAR IN THE WESTERN US IT IS
THE ONLY RATE ARE ON THE U. S.
TUNE FOR WILDFIRE RESEARCH.
IT'S A SPECIAL K. BEYOND ALLOWS
US TO LOOK AT PARTICLES AND THE
IDEA IS THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY SEE EMBERS BEING
TRANSPORTED IN THE PLUMES OF
WHERE THEY MAY FALL.
AND SO THIS --
READER BE DELIVERED AND APRIL
AND SO WE'LL HAVE IT TESTED BY
THE FIRE SEASON SO GIVE US TO
MOBILE ASSETS --
I'M GONNA KIND OF SKIP TO HEAR
BUT WHAT WE'VE ALSO DONE IS
WE'VE PUT A INFRARED CAMERA
SYSTEM VERY SMALL AND ON THE
SAME AIRCRAFT.
AND WE'RE GONNA BRING THAT
AIRCRAFT TO CALIFORNIA PLACE IN
READING AND TWENTY TWENTY IF WE
GET THE FUNDING.
AND THAT'LL ALLOW US TO DO HIGH
RESOLUTION WE'RE TALKING TWO
METER SIX FOOT RESOLUTION MUCH
HIGHER THAN SATELLITE.
AND ONE SECOND --
DATA THE WHOLE FIRE AND THE
DINNER TRAY A COMPUTER HAND HELD
OR ON THE FIRE LINE AND SO.
GETTING TO THE POINT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE THE ASSETS WE HAVE THE
PLATFORMS WE CAN PUT THIS
TECHNOLOGY ON AND SO IF YOU
COULD YOU COULD PUT THIS ON AIR
TACTICAL AIRCRAFT THAT THE ONES
THAT FLY ABOVE AN INCIDENT THAT
MANAGE THE SUPPRESSION AIRCRAFT.
AND THEN YOU CAN MAP IT OUT IN
REAL TIME AND THE DATA
TRANSMITTED VIA SATELLITE.
SIMILARLY YOU CAN TAKE A TANKER.
AND I'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THIS
MANUFACTURER WITH THE NET DATA
PROBE THE THIS NEW LOGICAL
SENSOR CAN ACTUALLY PROVIDE
NEUROLOGICAL MEASUREMENTS IN
REAL TIME ON ACTIVE WILDFIRE.
FASTER THAN A WEATHER STATION
AND ALL THESE DATA ARE
TRANSMITTED SATELLITE SO WE GET
TURBULENCE IN ADDITION.
THAT SENSOR PACKAGE GIVES YOU
AIRFRAME STRAIN AND SIZE ONCE
GET THROUGH HERE AND FINALLY GET
TO THIS LAST SLIDE.
A NETWORK OF VERTICAL PURFLING
RADAR LEASE RADARS ARE LIGHT
OURS THIS IS SOMETHING WE DO NOT
HAVE IN THE STATE THESE DOTS OF
THESE LEGAL.
OR SUGGESTED LOCATIONS WHERE I
WOULD PUT THESE.
WE DO MAYBE DO THE EIGHTY
CORRIDOR WE DO THE NORTH BAY WE
DO LA BASIN AND THESE CAN
ACTUALLY DETECT SMOKE IN REAL
TIME THEY CAN ALSO MEASURE THE
WINDOWS ARE COMING DOWN.
AND THEY'LL THAT ALL THAT DATA
IN JUST INTO A WILDFIRE --
PROJECTION SYSTEM AND SO JUST
YOUR SCHEMATIC YOU GET ALL THE
DATA FROM THE AIRCRAFT TO GET IT
FROM THE MOBILE --
ASSETS AT SAN JOSE STATE IT GOES
INTO A SUPER COMPUTER IT SPITS
OUT THAT FIRE COUPLE MODELING
SYSTEM.
AND THEN THOSE ASSETS SEE
HAPPENING WE'RE GONNA TEST THE
RADAR THIS SUMMER AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE THOSE MODEL OUTPUTS
ON OUR WEB SO WE'RE WE'RE DOING
THIS NOW.
BUT I THINK.
THE MAIN GOAL IS THE MAIN POINT
I WANT TO MAKE TODAY'S THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF THIS TECHNOLOGY.
WE CAN PUT THIS ON OUR CURRENT
AIRCRAFT AND WE CAN COLLECT MORE
DATA SO WE DON'T HAVE TO PUT NEW
ASSETS OUT IN THE FIELD THAT'S
ALREADY THERE WE JUST HAVE --
TO ADD AND TECHNOLOGY TO THEM.
SO WITH THAT I'LL JUST.
END. FIFTY SIX THANK YOU TO GO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
THREE TO SPEAK --
I'M OKAY OUT ON THURSDAY NIGHT
OF PRESENT A NUMBER OF OF
RESEARCHERS AT THE UC SAN DIEGO --
AND IT'S A PERFECT ACTION SICK
VERY FROM SENSING AND CAMERAS
AND BOTH NEAR AND REMOTE SENSING
TO MODELING.
AND AS YOU SEEN DURING A FIRE
THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION
GOING ON A STRONG THAT.
IN A WAY THE AGENCY IS FOR
MONITORING OF THE FIRE WHICH I
WILL CALL.
NOW CASTING.
AND HAVING THAT INFORMATION AND
USING IT TO PREDICT THE FIRES
BEHAVIOR ITS DIRECTION THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE CAN HELP THE
DECISIONS RELATED TO IT WHICH IS
WHAT WE CALL FOR CASTING.
SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
WAYS FOR CASTING CAN BE DONE BUT
WHAT'S GOING ON TODAY IS.
LINKING ALL THIS MODELING AND
THE DATA THAT WE COLLECT DURING
THE FIRES. TO WHAT I WITH COOL
DISASTER INTEL INTELLIGENCE.
SO.
THE SOLUTION HERE IS TO BUILD A
AS CHAIRMAN DOT SAID A CLEARING
HOUSE SO TO SAY THAT'S
INTELLIGENT AND NEUTRAL.
SO IT'S NOT --
TRY WITH IN THE SENSE THAT THE
BOND.
PARTY OWNS THE DATA.
AND INTEGRATE TO IT AS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CATALOG CURATE --
EXCHANGE --
ALLIES AND COMMUNICATE
INFORMATION TO THE AGENCY IS TO
THE SCIENCE COMMUNITY AND ALSO
TO PUBLIC FOR PUBLIC EVER IN
THIS INSPIRATIONAL.
NEEDS THAT CAN ARISE AROUND FIVE
YEARS BEFORE AND AFTER FOR
RESILIENCE --
SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE
RECEIVED A GRANT FROM THE
NATIONAL SCIENCE FOUNDATION AND
OVER THE LAST TEN TO FIFTEEN
YEARS WE'VE BEEN BUILDING
AUTOMATED WORKFLOWS TO COLLECT
DATA.
AND USE THEM FOR MONITORING
VISUALIZING AND PREDICTING FIRE
BEHAVIOR IT'S CALLED THE WHY
FIRE INFRASTRUCTURE AND THERE'S
A PHONE BECAUSE OF THAT I
DISTRIBUTES A HOPEFULLY IT WAS
DISTRIBUTED DURING MY TALK --
SO THE IDEA IS COLLECT ALL THE
DATA AND SERVICE IN A WAY THAT
MODELS CAN INGEST.
AND OF COURSE IS A PART OF OUR
EFFORTS FEE BILL DYNAMIC DATA
DRIVEN FIRE MODELS FOR THREE MY
TO BE COLD AND DYNAMIC DATA
DRIVEN BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT MODELING IS GETTING THE
DATA IN REAL TIME.
AND MAKING SURE WE CAN ADJUST
THE MODELS.
SO WE CAN ACTUALLY COME FROM THE
UPDATES.
YOU CAN LOOK AT THE MONITOR AND
CHANGE THE FIRE SEE IT IS BEING
FOUGHT HOW THE RAIDERS CHANGING
LOCALLY AND GLOBALLY.
AROUND THE FIRE AND HOLLOW.
THE PERIMETER IS EVOLVING BUT
HOW BOUT EVACUATIONS HAVE BEEN
DONE AND ALL THAT INFORMATION
CAN BE SERVED THROUGH ONE
PLATFORM. TO ANYONE WHO'S TRYING
TO MODEL THE FIRES WAS TRYING TO
MAKE DECISIONS.
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO THE FIRE ENOUGH TOOL IS THE
RESULT OF THIS THREE MILLION
DOLLARS NATIONAL SCIENCE
FOUNDATION SUPPORT THAT WE
DEVELOPED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE LA FIRE DEPARTMENT --
ME GOOD ADVICE FROM A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT AGENCIES HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX AGENCIES ACTUALLY
COLLABORATED WITH US TO
UNDERSTAND LIKE YOU'VE BEEN
DOING IN RESEARCH MODE --
OVER THE LAST YEAR BEAVER
SUPPORT OF AN OPERATIONAL FORM
OF ID LA FIRE DEPARTMENT AWAY
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT VENTURA
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT.
AND SHE FANTASY MIGHT SPEAK
LATER --
ALSO THE ORANGE COUNTY FIRE
AUTHORITY.
SO THIS IS A PLATFORM TO TAKE
ALL THAT DATA THAT COULD ANYONE
CAN USE AND US US BOTH IN THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE THE MAIN.
PUT THE LAYER ON TOP OF IT TO
COMMUNICATE ENVIRONMENTAL DATA
AND OTHER FIRE RELATED DATA
INFRASTRUCTURE CENSUS POPULATION
SMOKE AIR QUALITY IN YOUR NAME
AT ANY DATA THAT CAN RELATE. TO
ALL HAZARDS IN NASA'S NOT JUST
FIRED ABOUT THE USE THAT IN THE
CONTEXT OF FIRE MODELING AND WE
HAVE OUR OWN FIRE BEHAVIOR
MODELS THAT BE INTEGRATED BUT WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO INTEGRATE.
ANY MODEL.
THAT OF THE STATE IS USING ARE
WILLING TO USE IN THE LONG TERM.
SO WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE STARTED
TO THINK ABOUT FIRE NOT TO GET --
DURING THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CAN ORDER IN
CALIFORNIA FIRES.
THIS INFO INFRASTRUCTURE TO WORK
ON THIS GOT OUT OF COURSE WE
DON'T MAKE THE FORECASTING OF
THE FIRE AVAILABLE TO PUBLIC.
BUT THE REST OF SAID FRUSTRATION
THE VENISON ON THE EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND PUBLIC USERS ALONG WITH
THOSE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
FIRE AGENCIES GOT ON THE SITE.
SO THAT SHOWS ALSO THE PUBLIC'S
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON AND
DISINTEGRATES AS YOU SEEN SOME
OF THE BETTER STATIONS THAT YOU
SEE IN CAMERA DATA.
SMOKE PLUMES RED FLAG ALERTS.
ANNOUNCED FIRE PERIMETERS
DETECTIONS FROM SATELLITES AND
ANY OTHER INFORMATION WE CAN
BRING. FOR SITUATION LIVE IN
THIS.
IT WAS ALSO USED IN SOME OF THE
LA COUNTY FIRES LA ACTUALLY HAS
A WORK FLOW MANDATE START TO
MODELING THE MOMENT THEY RECEIVE
THE ALERTS.
AND SOME OF THOSE ALERTS COME
FROM FOR INSTANCE ALERT WELFARE
CAMERAS.
YOU CAN EVEN GO TO A CAMERA AND
WHICH ON THE SMOKE AND THAT
INFORMATION GETS INGESTED INTO
THE PLATFORM AND THE MODELING
STARS FROM THEN ON SO IT CAN BE
MADE IN A SEAMLESS FASHION USING
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE AND DATA
SCIENCE TECHNIQUES THAT.
THE MOMENT A FIRE IS DETECTED
AUTOMATICALLY --
IN MODEL CAN BE START IT CAN
EVEN BE DONE --
BUT NOT REALLY ON THE WERE
ADVISED BY T. FORDER ON THIS.
THE DAY BEFORE TO FIRE REYES ON
THOSE DANGER ALERTS BUT IF A
FIRE HAPPENED HOW DO YOU --
OKAY THREE SOURCES WHAT'S
INITIALLY SAN DIEGO FIRE
DEPARTMENT NOW ORANGE COUNTY
FIRE AUTHORITY AFTER CHIU
FANTASIES MOVE THERE --
THAT -- THE
AIRCRAFT FROM GENERAL ATOMICS
FLIES VERY ABOUT THE FIRE.
SUPPRESSION OF FOR EFFORTS TO AT
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND FEET --
THE DATA HE GOT --
AND THE THE SORT OF A RADAR AND
OTHER INTERNET BASED SENSING
THAT'S EXTENSIBLE --
THE PERIMETERS WE CAN GET PRETTY
DETAILED PARAMETERS DURING A
FIRE FROM THESE AIRCRAFT THAT
INFORMATION WE ARE USING TO
ASSIMILATE INTO FIRE MODELS SO
WE CAN CONSTANTLY GENERATE NEW
FIRE MODELS AND IN THE MODEL CAN
BE GENERATED IN A MATTER OF
MINUTES.
IS IT ACCURATE.
IT SCIENTIFICALLY THE ACCURACY
CAN DID CHANGE BUT IS IT FAST
AND IT DOESN'T HELP WITH
DECISION SUPPORT YES IT DOES
ABSOLUTELY A 100%.
AND HERE WE'VE SEEN A DURING
JULY LIKE FUN IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EVERITT THE STF.
THREE EMERGENCY COMMAND CENTER
AND THE AIRCRAFT WAS FLYING YOU
WERE GETTING THEIR PAYMENTS ARE
SENATE WAS BEING FED THE
CALLAWAY SCOTT SYSTEM THAT THE
DIRECTOR DO OUTREACH EMISSIONS.
QUITE BRIEFLY.
SO DURING THOMAS FIRE WHAT
HAPPENED UNTIL NOW I SHOWED
INITIAL ATTACK SCENARIOS.
DURING THE THOMAS FIRE WHAT
HAPPEN IS THERE WERE FOUR
DIFFERENT BETTER EVENTS
SIGNIFICAN ROTARY VENTS THE FIRE
STARTED IT'S MOVED IT'S MOVED
AGAIN IT MOVED AGAIN SO
MANAGEMENT OF THE FIRE AND
HOLLYWOOD EVEN THOUGH BACK BURN
TYPE OF SCENARIOS.
WHAT HAPPENS IF SOME AREA BURNS
FOR THE FIRE GO THROUGH THAT
AGAIN THIS TYPE OF SCENARIOS?
OF WAS.
ANALYZED IN THE FIRE CAMP I'M
GONNA LEAVE YOU WITH THOSE FOUR
BETTER EVENTS AND WHAT ELSE CAN
BE DONE.
IF I MAY SAY ONE LAST THING
THERE'S A HUGE UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE SATELLITE DATA WAS
DISCUSSED WE HAD SOME --
COLLABORATIONS WITH HIGH
RESOLUTION SATELLITE COMPANIES --
INCLUDING PLANET VERY CAN GET
DATA AT THIRTY CENTIMETERS TO
FOOT FIFTY CENTIMETER RESOLUTION
USING THAT MEANS RIGHT NOW WE
CAN USE THAT DATA YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND LAND COVER AND OTHERS.
CHANGES ON OVER TO LAND JUST
LOOKING AT THESE PICTURES I
RESOLUTION PICTURES.
SO THAT MEANS THE FUEL MODELS
FOR INSTANCE WHAT BURNS DURING
THE FIRE CAN BE UPDATED ON A
REGULAR BASIS EVEN ON THE WEEKLY
FASHION --
USING EFFICIENT ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE TECHNIQUES AND WHAT
WE GET FROM THEM LIKE VEGETATION
CLASSIFICATION CAN BE MADE AS A
PART OF THESE FIRE MODELS.
AND CAN YOU SORT OF TO THE
MODELING COMMUNITY AT LARGE.
THROUGH THIS NEUTRAL PLATFORM --
THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT WITH THE
WIFI.
ANOTHER THING HERE THAT YOU SEE
IS HOW YOU CAN ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THE PREVENTION CAPABILITIES
BECAUSE BY PUTTING ENOUGH A
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AROUND HOMES
AND IDENTIFYING WHAT AREAS NEED
FOR ORDER DEFENSIBLE SPACE FROM
THIS IMAGERY.
IT ACTUALLY CAN HELP WITH WHAT
BURNS OR WHAT SHOULD AND BURNED
DURING THE FIRE SO WE CAN
ACTUALLY REDUCE DAMAGE BY
CAREFUL ANALYSIS USING THESE
TECHNIQUES.
SO AND THESE EMISSIONS FORTIES
WILL BE IN THE COUPLE OF MILLION
DOLLARS RANGE BUT IT CAN SAVE
BILLIONS AT TIMES --
AND LIVES OF COURSE WHICH ARE
PRICELESS THANK YOU.
THEY FOR TESTIMONY.
SO MY NAME IS TAREQ SODIUM A
PROFESSOR OF MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING AT UC BERKELEY AND
I'M AHEAD OF THE FIRE RESEARCH
GROUP --
THAT'S A COLLECTION OF PEOPLE --
THAT ARE WORKING PRIMARILY AND
ENGINEERING TECHNOLOGY --
CAUGHT FIRE.
WHICH SO.
I'LL SIMPLY CLICK FORWARD --
IN THE EASY WAY TO PDF SO
BASICALLY THE THE MAIN.
IMPETUS OF THIS WAS A COLLECTION
OF SCIENTISTS FROM UC BERKELEY
LAWRENCE BERKELEY NATIONAL LABS
NASA.
SPACE SCIENCES LABORATORIES AND
WITH FIRST RESPONDERS AND WE'RE
ROUGHLY THIRTY PEOPLE THAT HAVE
DECIDED TO LOOK AT ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT TECHNOLOGIES THAT
EXIST RIGHT NOW IN THE FIRE
SPACE.
AND SEE WHETHER WE CAN REDUCE
THE COSTS AND MAKE THEM EASY TO
PRODUCE.
AND UBIQUITOUS SO THAT THEY'RE
BASICALLY --
READILY AVAILABLE TO FIRST
RESPONDERS SO WE'RE WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH FIRST RESPONDERS
TO DEVELOP THE GADGETS AND TO
REDUCE THE PRICES ON THE COSTS
USING ADVANCED MANUFACTURING
TECHNIQUES.
I WON'T BORE YOU WITH ALL THE
DETAILS AND FOR RUNNING VERY
SHORT ON TIME BASCALLY THE MAIN --
FOR THRUSTS THAT WE HAVE ARE
DEPLOYABLE SENSOR SYSTEMS IN
REAL TIME MOBILE OF FIREFIGHTING.
THAT MEANS ESSENTIALLY --
WORKING CONSTANTLY ON U. A. V.
TECHNOLOGIES MAKING THEM CHEAP
INEXPENSIVE AND ALSO ADAPTIVE.
SO THE MAIN IDEA HERE IS TO
AVOID --
LARGE --
UAVS THAT ARE QUITE EXPENSIVE TO
REDUCE THE COSTS AND MAKE THEM
EASILY DEPLOYABLE AND EASY TO
LOSE AN EASY TO REPRODUCE SO THE
MAIN IDEA HERE IS WE DON'T
INVEST A LOT OF MONEY IN EACH
INDIVIDUAL GADGET.
WE'RE TRYING TO PRODUCE MASS
PRODUCTIONS OF THESE GADGETS SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN USE THEM AT AT
ANY GIVEN TIME SO THE IDEA IS IS
VERY MUCH LIKE A CELL PHONE.
REDUCE THE COSTS MASS PRODUCTION
USED THROUGH ADVANCED
MANUFACTURING SO THAT REALLY
LEVERAGES WHAT BERKELEY STRENGTH
THIS AND ESSENTIALLY AND SILICON
VALLEY.
IT IS THE MASS PRODUCTION OF
MANY GADGETS AND MAKING THEM
CHEAP TO DRIVE DOWN THE COST.
WE ARE NOT NECESSARILY FIRE
PEOPLE I MEAN MANY OF US HAVE
BEEN WORKING IN FIRE
TECHNOLOGIES FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS WERE MAINLY PEOPLE THAT
ARE WORKING IN THE MANUFACTURING
ASPECTS REDUCE THE COSTS AND THE
MAN IN THE GADGETS THEMSELVES.
BECAUSE THEY SAID THE FOUR MAIN
THRUST ARE YOU A VIS MOBILE REAL
TIME COMPUTING.
THAT MEANS SIMPLY PUTTING THE
COMPUTERS ON THE UAV'S DIRECTLY.
SO THE IDEA IS IS NO MORE SUPER
COMPUTERS EVERYTHING IS LOCAL
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO BE A SEAT
BASED ESSENTIALLY ON THE U. A.
V. DIRECTLY ITSELF.
AND IT'S GOING TO BE CHEAP AND
REPRODUCIBLE AND THAT TECHNOLOGY
DOES EXIST NOW.
HI WE'RE ALSO LOOKING GET A
LARGE WE'RE TEN LEND MUCH OF OUR
MOBILE COMPUTING --
WITH THOSE KINDS OF SYSTEMS AND
THEN THEY KEEP STRENGTH AND I
GUESS STRENGTH NUMBER FOUR IS
REALLY WHERE --
WE PUT A LOT OF TECHNOLOGIES AND
THREE D. PRINTING AND ADDITIVE
MANUFACTURING SO THE MAIN IDEA
THERE IS HOW TO PRODUCE THESE
TYPES OF DEVICES INEXPENSIVELY.
AND IN THE LARGE SCALE SO --
THE TYPICAL APPROACH OF COURSE
IS TO TAKE A U. A. V. MOUNTED
CAMERA ON IT AND SIMPLY PEOPLE
DEPLOY IT.
THE MAIN PROBLEM WITH MOST YOU A
VISA IF YOU'VE EVER HAD ONE AND
I'VE HAD MANY OF THEM.
IS ARE NOT SIMPLY.
EASY TO CONTROL IN A TURBULENT
ENVIRONMENT IN A FIRE LIKE
ENVIRONMENT IS SEEN IN MANY OF
THE VIDEOS ALREADY BEFORE.
A U. A. V. IS GOING TO FAIL I
MEAN THEY'RE BASICALLY GOING TO
BE PUT INTO SOME TYPE OF HIGH
VORTEX --
TYPE OF THE SYSTEM THE CAMERA
SILLY RAYCROFT WHERE THE U. A.
V. SO BASICALLY COLLAPSE SO WHAT
WE'RE WORKING ON ADAPTIVE
CONTROL STRATEGIES. TO HAVE
THESE THINGS ADAPT TO THEIR
ENVIRONMENT --
IN EXISTING A TURBULENT SYSTEM
THAT MIGHT BE IN A FIRE
SITUATION THE KEY HERE ALSO WITH
THESE ARE INEXPENSIVE IF WE LOSE
A HUNDRED OF THEM WHO CARES
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THEM.
SO IT'S EXACTLY LIKE WE HAD WITH
CELL PHONES WE'RE NOT GOING TO
PUT A LOT OF EMPHASIS ON
INDIVIDUAL GADGETS THAT COST A
LOT WE WENT TO MASS PRODUCE THEM.
WE WANT TO ALSO THEN LOOK AT THE
ECONOMICS OF EXACTLY HOW YOU
MAKE THESE --
YOU KNOW --
AVAILABLE EASILY TO ROUTE FIRST
RESPONDERS --
SORT OF FOR THE WHERE DID ALL OF
THIS STUFF COME FROM IT WAS A
LARGE SUPER COMPUTING CENTER
THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED BY THE US
ARMY FOR ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS BETWEEN BERKELEY
AND STANFORD.
PRIMARILY INTERESTED IN
EXPLOSION TECHNOLOGIES WHAT WE
WERE LOOKING AT WORK.
GADGETS THE COULD PREDICT HOW
EXPLOSIONS OCCURRED --
THIS WAS PRIMARILY DONE ON THE
EAST COAST WITH THE ABERDEEN
PROVING GROUNDS WHAT WE DID IS
WE USED TECHNOLOGIES FOR FAST
CALCULATIONS ON PREDICTING WHERE
IEDS WOULD BASICALLY --
EMITS AND PRODUCE HOT FRAGMENTS
FROM THEIR WITHIN BRANCH ON TO
HOW WE DO THE COMPUTING LOCALLY
AND THEN HOW THE CAMERAS WOULD
BE DEPLOYED SO THAT WE COULD
ESSENTIALLY.
PROBE INTO EXTREMELY TURBULENT
AND VIOLENT ENVIRONMENTS WITH
RELATIVELY FAST AND EASY GADGETS
AND TECHNOLOGY SO --
FOR THE SAKE OF TIME ASSEMBLY
SAY THAT WHAT WERE --
CURRENTLY WORKING ON A SWARM
TYPE TO AS OF THOUSANDS OF
DRONES RELATIVELY INEXPENSIVELY
AND TRYING TO MIMIC THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR USING ANIMAL --
TYPE PSYCHOLOGIES IN USING THOSE
AS CONTROL ALGORITHMS FOR THE
DRONES TO THE BASIC IDEA IS AS
MUCH LIKE YOU HOW YOU SEE HOW
STARLINGS BEHAVE.
WERE EMBEDDING THOSE KINDS OF
TECHNOLOGIES INTO THE DRONES
THEMSELVES SO THEY CAN MOVE
ESSENTIALLY IN AN ECONOMIST
FASHION.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE A FIRST
RESPONDER ON HAND SO.
THE BOTTOM LINE HERE IS IT'S
ADVANCED MANUFACTURING --
IMP LEVERAGING ALL OF THE
TECHNOLOGIES AND THREE D.
PRINTING --
THAT'S OF COURSE ESTIMATED TO BE
A ONE TRILLION DOLLAR ECONOMY --
BUSINESS OVER THE LAST HOUR THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS I THAT'S
PRIMARILY THROUGH DIGITIZED
TECHNOLOGIES --
THE BENEFIT OF COURSE THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY IS RELATIVELY
CLEAR SMALLER CARBON FOOTPRINT
INCREASED DEMAND FOR NEW
PRODUCTS --
AND THEN OF COURSE IMPROVED
PRODUCTIVITY PROFIT MARGINS AND
SO FORTH I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
TO SELL ADVANCED MANUFACTURING
IN THE STATE.
SO THAT'S ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING REPLYING ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGIES TO THE FIRE --
ECO SYSTEM SO I THINK IT ECHOES
WHAT REPRESENTED DODD HAD
INDICATED BUT CLEARING HOUSES.
THE ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS
THAT ARE INVOLVED I'VE WILL THAT
WERE WERE RIGHT YOU DIFFERENT
AND METHODS [inaudible]
DIFFERENT FOR WE FELT THAT IT
WAS VERY IMPORTANT SINCE WE WERE
ALL CHOKING BASICALLY LAST
NOVEMBER --
ESSENTIALLY AS YOU CAN SEE THE
BAY AREA WAS BASICALLY
SUFFOCATED AT THAT POINT WE
COLLECTED EVERYONE TOGETHER AND
WE DECIDED WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT
EACH TECHNOLOGY SCRUTINIZE IT
AND DETERMINE HOW WE CAN MAKE IT
IN EXPENSIVE.
AND EASILY DEPLOYABLE SO THAT'S
BASICALLY OUR MISSION THANK YOU.
IMPRESSIVE THANK YOU.
THIS TIME WILL WELCOME.
CHIEF --
FIRST EMERGED FIRE THREE UP
[inaudible]
TO ONE BUDGET TESTIMONY.
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS SOME FOLKS
MAY HAVE SOME TRAVEL PLANS IF
YOU HAVE.
BENDING FLIGHTS THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO MESS CERTAINLY --
LEAVE THE INFORMATION BEHIND AND
WE'LL CALL YOU WITH QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU WE HAVE WE ADJUSTED
OUR TRAVEL PLANS IT WAS
IMPORTANT WE GOT IN FRONT OF YOU.
AND SURE BUT WE NEED TO SHARE
WITH YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
YEAH THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF TALK
TODAY BY YOU KNOW BOTH PANELS
ABOUT YOUR CONCEPTUAL MODELS AND
WHATNOT I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
TODAY ABOUT TO TECHNOLOGIES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW.
THAT WITH FUNDING I WILL MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE NOT ONLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BUT THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
FIRST OFF MY NAME IS BRIAN
TENNESSEANS MENTION ON THE FIRE
CHIEF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY FIRE
AUTHORITY.
THE CFA IS RESPONSIBLE FOR FIRE
TWENTY THREE CITIES IN THE
UNINCORPORATED AREAS OF THE
COUNTY WE SERVE ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION RESIDENTS FROM SEVENTY
TWO FIRE STATIONS.
PRIOR TO MY APPOINTMENT A FIRE
CHIEF AN ORANGE COUNTY LAST YEAR
SPENT TWENTY EIGHT YEARS WITH
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO FIRE
DEPARTMENT. THREE THOSE YEARS IS
THE CITY'S FIRE CHIEF.
MY FIRE SERVICE CAREER BEGAN IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IS AN
EMPLOYEE WITH THE U. S. FOREST
SERVICE IN ALTERNATELY WITH THE
BUREAU OF LAND MANAGEMENT THIS
IS MY FORTY FIRST YEAR.
IN THE FIRE SERVICE IN OVER THE
YEARS A RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
LARGEST WILDFIRES IN THE WESTERN
US.
IF THERE WAS EVER ANY QUESTION
AS TO WHAT THE SINGLE HIGHEST
THREAT TO LIFE AND PROPERTY IS
IN CALIFORNIA.
IT WAS ANSWERED IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND AGAIN IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I
RECOGNIZE THAT THE FEDERAL STATE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FAR AGENCIES DO
NOT HAVE UNLIMITED BUDGETS
HOWEVER.
MORE MUST BE INVESTED IN TESTING
NEW OR EXISTING TECHNOLOGY THAT
WILL AID FIREFIGHTERS ON THE
GROUND.
CONCEPTUAL MODELS AGAIN AND THEN
SHARED TODAY.
I'M THE ONLY ONE THAT HAS REAL
EMERGING TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS
THROUGH THE VISION OF TWO PILOT
PROGRAMS TO THAT IN AGAIN I'D
LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU THE
PROJECT THAT WE HAD ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY.
OR WORKING.
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO WILL STILL
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO'S FIRE
CHIEF AMID A LOCAL --
DEFENSE CONTRACTOR GENERAL
ATOMICS.
THEY BUILD AND FLY A VARIETY OF
PREDATORS IN IN WAR THEATER --
THEY APPROACHED US AND WE'RE
WILLING TO PROVIDE MANNED
AIRCRAFT THAT COULD BE USED
DURING A WILDLAND FIRE.
WE ALSO DISCOVERED THAT THE SAME
STATE OF THE ART TECHNOLOGIES ON
BOARD THE GENERAL ATOMICS
AIRCRAFT IN HOUSTON WARTIME
THEATER APPLICABLE WITHIN OUR
OWN WILDLAND FIRE ENVIRONMENT.
FIRST RESPONDERS LACK RESOURCES
THAT PROVIDE REAL TIME
INFORMATION SUCH AS VIDEO AND
FIRE PERIMETER MAPS.
DURING THE INITIAL ONSET OF WILD
LAND FIRES AND I'LL GET BACK TO
WHY THAT IS SO IMPORTANT.
PROVIDING FIRST RESPONDERS WITH
DEDICATED AERIAL RESOURCES THE
POSSESS TECHNOLOGIES DEDICATED.
TO INCLUDING VIDEO AND DATA LEE
ENHANCE INCIDENT DECISION MAKERS
SITUATED WITH SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS THUS IMPROVING THE
PROBABILITY OF SAVING LIVES IN
PREVENTING A LOSS.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE ORANGE
COUNTY FIRE AUTHORITY GENERAL
ATOMICS AERONAUTICAL SYSTEMS IS
LEVERAGING THESE AND OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES.
THEY CAN PROVIDE ACTIONABLE
INTELLIGENCE DURING THE INITIAL
ATTACK OF A WILDLAND FIRE.
AND OTHER EMERGENCIES THE SYSTEM
IS PROVEN.
INDUSTRY USED SUCCESSFULLY IN
PAST INSISTS THE LILAC FAR WAS A
GOOD EXAMPLE THAT THE PREVIOUS
PANEL --
DISCUSSED BECAUSE THIS SYSTEM IS
TURN KEY THERE ARE NO
DEVELOPMENT COSTS.
IT WILL EMPLOY QUALIFIED PUBLIC
AGENCY PROFESSIONAL FIRE FIRST
RESPONDERS FIRST RESPONDERS
TRAINED IN TACTICAL AIRSPACE
COORDINATION.
IT WILL CAPITALIZE THE GENERAL
ATOMICS MILITARY INTELLIGENCE
SURVEY AND RECONNAISSANCE
PERSONNEL EXPERTISE.
IMAGINE.
AND ALL WEATHER AIRBORNE
PLATFORM OPERATING EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND FEET WELL ABOVE ALL
OTHER TACTICAL AIRCRAFT
PROVIDING REAL TIME IMAGERY MAPS
FIRE PROGRESSION MODELING.
ASSISTING GROUND BASED INCIDENT
COMMANDERS AND DETERMINE AREAS
OF NEED FOR IMMEDIATE EVACUATION
AND RESOURCE DEPLOYMENT.
THIS IS AVAILABLE NOW.
IN A FUNNY BECOMES AVAILABLE THE
ANY POINT COULD BE PUT IN A
SERVICES SOON AS THIS SUMMER.
THERE ARE OTHER SIMILAR ASSETS
AVAILABLE BUT NONE.
THAT ARE RESPONDING ON INITIAL
ATTACK FIRE RESPONSE WERE REAL
TIME INFORMATION SLOW SPEED THE
NATIONAL GUARD.
THE BOISE THERE A LOT OF OTHER
PLATFORMS A PROVIDE SIMILAR
INFORMATION SURVEILLANCE
RECONNAISSANCE --
INFORMATION BUT TYPICALLY WHAT
YOU'LL SEE IS THOSE DEPLOYED
WELL AFTER THE FIRES BEGUN WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS AN
AIRCRAFT SITTING ON THE GROUND
READY TO RESPOND.
WHEN OUR HELICOPTERS RESPOND
WATER AIR TANKERS RESPOND IT'S
IN THE AIR PROVIDING REAL TIME
DATA TO THOSE PEOPLE THAT ARE
OPERATING IN THE BACK OF THE
BACK OF THE SUBURBAN?
AND ALSO BEING COMMUNICATED TO
THE YOUR SMART DEVICES WHATEVER
IT IS THAT'S AVAILABLE NOW.
AVAILABLE GO IN SERVICE --
THE GENERAL THOMAS MANN PLATFORM
IS ALSO USING --
WHAT WE HEARD HERE TODAY THE
UNIVERSITY SAN DIEGO'S WHY FIRE
PROGRESSION MOLLY YOU SAW A
GREAT MAP FROM THE LILAC FIRE UP
THE DOCTOR OTAGES FLASHED UP?
THAT REALLY KIND OF YOU KNOW PUT
WE'LL VALIDATED THE THE ACCURACY
OF THE TOOL --
THE TECHNOLOGY ISSUE DISCUSSES
BEEN USED BY LA FIRE THE BIG
DIFFERENCE IS LA FIRE GETS A
RESPONSE.
THEY GET A LOCATION ON THE MAP
THE PAIN GETS DROPPED IT GIVES
US COMMANDERS.
WHERE THAT FAR PROGRESSION
MODELING IS THE DIFFERENCE IS
THE AIRBORNE PLATFORM OVER THE
TOP THAT FAR PROVIDING
CONTINUOUS AS LONG AS THAT
CAMERAS ON IT?
IT'S CONTINUOUSLY CHANGING THE
MODEL AND SO EITHER NOT ASKING
FOR CALLING BACK AS IN DROP A
PIN DROP ANOTHER PIN DROP.
IT IS CONTINUOUSLY MODELING.
ANOTHER VALUE ADD IN THIS IS ONE
THAT I THINK YOU'LL APPRECIATE
ONE WE GET ALL THE TIME AS FAR
APART AS IS YOU KNOW.
WHAT WAS YOU KNOW WHAT WAS THE
THE THE END RESULT THAT FAR WILL
TELL YOU --
WE LOST THREE HUNDRED STRUCTURES
YOU KNOW HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF DAMAGE.
IMAGINE YOU'RE HAVING THAT FIRE
MODEL MAP.
COMPARING IT AGAINST THE ACTUAL
SUPPRESSION MAP IN BEING ABLE TO
GO BACK AND SAY YOU KNOW HAD WE
NOT STOPPED HERE ON THIS REGION
THIS ROAD WE HAVE LOST TWO
HUNDRED HOMES POTENTIALLY
ANOTHER HALF A MILLION DOLLARS.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A TOOL LIKE THAT
THAT THAT ALLOWED US TO QUALIFY
THAT IS IN THE OTHER.
VALUE AT NOT TO MENTION DIRECTOR
GIL ARE DUE TO TALK ABOUT.
THIS FEEDS DIRECTLY INTO IT SO
YOU'RE GETTING ALL OF THIS
INFORMATION ALL THE STATE EOC IS
OF A LOCAL UC'S THIS IS
AVAILABLE.
NOW -- ONE
OTHER PROGRAM THAT WE'RE WORKING --
CLOSELY WITH IS --
CALLED THE IT'S A IS A NIGHT
TIME TYPE ONE HELLO TACK OR
HELLO TANKER HUBBLE FREEL
PROGRAM THERE SOME GREAT
QUESTIONS EARLIER BY SOME OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ABOUT NIGHT
TIME FIRE FIGHTING.
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN AYE TIME
FIRE FIGHTING FOR FIFTEEN YEARS
DEVELOPED A PROGRAM AND HAVE
INTIMATE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THAT
WHAT IS VERY DIFFERENT ABOUT THE
PROGRAM THAT WE'RE WE'RE GONNA
SHOW UP.
PROBABLY LESS THAN A MINUTE
VIDEO ON IT.
IS THIS IS WITH WHAT WE CALL A
TYPE ONE HELL ATTACKER OF VERY
LARGE HELICOPTER DRINKING.
DROPPING LARGE VOLUMES OF WATER.
AT NIGHT.
BIG DIFFERENCE IS THEIR HOVER
FILLING FROM NATURAL WATER SIZE
SOURCES WE SEE THAT ALL THE TIME
FOR THE DATE TIME THE GOING TO
THE LAKE AND THEY COME OUT WE
DON'T DO THAT.
NO IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AGAIN I'VE I'VE OPERATE NIGHT
AND HELICOPTERS WE HAVE TO LAND.
HOSE COMES OUT WE PLUG IN WE
FILL TAKE SOME TIME.
SOON AS IT'S DONE WERE OFF THE
RECORD MANY FIRE. TO BE ABLE TO
HOVER FILL IN A SOURCE NEXT THE
FIRE OR IN A TANK.
MEANS WAR WATER MORE PRODUCT IS
GOING ON THAT FAR THAT IS
AVAILABLE NOW --
IT IS BEEN SUCCESSFULLY USED
THIS MODEL IN AUSTRALIA QUITE
FRANKLY AUSTRALIA'S DOING SOME
THINGS ARE RIGHT NOW AT NIGHT
WITH AVIATION RESOURCES THAT
WE'RE NOT --
DIRECTOR PORTER --
TALKED A BIT ABOUT THE NIGHT OF
FIXED WING AIR TANKER PROGRAMS
THAT WERE NOT DROPPING AND I
HE'S ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
YOU'RE ABOUT TO EMBARK ON A
PROGRAM IN AUSTRALIA WHERE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE DROPPING
**** OUT OF FIXED WING AIRCRAFT
AT NIGHT.
EACH YEAR THE TECHNOLOGY IS ON
THE DOORSTEP --
WE'RE JUST NOT QUITE THERE YET
HERE LOCALLY --
WHAT IS UNIQUE ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM AGAIN AND IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MOST COUNTIES OURS
INCLUDED OPERATE NIGHT TIME
FIREFIGHTING AIRCRAFT?
BUT IF YOU LIVE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA NAME ANY OTHER
LOCATION A STATE YOU HAVE A FIRE
AT NIGHT.
YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT GETTING
ORANGE COUNTY OR LA COUNTY
VENTURA COUNTY THEY'RE NOT
COMING UP YOUR FIRE.
THE FOREST SERVICE DOES OPERATE
ONE HELICOPTER AT NIGHT IT'S OUT
OF FOXFIELD LANCASTER.
IT MAY COME UP TO YOUR FIRE TAKE
SOME TIME THIS PROGRAM IS FUNDED
THIS PILOT PROGRAM.
PUTS A NIGHT TIME.
HEAVY HELICOPTER TYPE ONE HELL
ATTACKER AVAILABLE TO ANY.
ANY FIRE DEPARTMENT ANY
JURISDICTION STATE LOCAL FEDERAL
ANYWHERE THE STATE.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS AVAILABLE NOW --
ALL PLAY A QUICK VIDEO IN THE
ESSENCE OF TIME AND THEN WE'LL
WRAP THIS UP.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING THE LAST TEN
YEARS -- IN
NORTH AMERICA ON A LIFELINE
PROGRAM THAT INVOLVES THIS
AIRCRAFT WHICH IS THIS COURSE
GUESS.
SEVENTY SIX HAS A THERMAL
IMAGING CAMERA ON THE NOSE OF IT.
AND WORKING ON WITH A
FIREBOMBING HELICOPTER WHICH IS
THE S. SIX IT LIES ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND FEET ABOVE THE GROUND.
AND IT'S USED TO PROTECT THE
FIREBOMBING HELICOPTERS SO WE
REALLY TAKE THE RISK OUT OF THE
FIRE BOMBING OPERATIONS.
SO THE AIR TAC OFFICER WHO'S UP
IN THE FRONT --
WILL --
SELECTED TARGETS AND THEN I WILL
MOVE THE CAMERA ON TO THAT
DESIGNATED TARGET --
TURN ON THE LASER --
WHICH STAND ELIMINATES THAT AND
THE SIXTY ONE JUST FOLLOWS THE
BEAM DOWN TO THE LASER ON THE
GROUND AND DROPS THE WATER.
IT'S AN OPERATION WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT OPERATING LIKE THIS
THE UNITED STATES AND I AND I
CAN SAY THIS AGAIN HAVING --
VAN A NIGHT TIME WATER DROP
OPERATIONS IS.
TWO THOUSAND FOUR YOU KNOW THERE
WAS A QUESTION EARLIER BY ONE OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT ASKED
ABOUT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
DROPPING WATER DURING THE DAY
AND AND AT NIGHT TIME --
THE TYPICALLY IN THE WINDS ARE
BLOWING IS IS STRONGLY AT NIGHT
TO WE'RE NOT TALKING TO SANTA
ANA WIND DRIVEN FIRE.
TYPICALLY THE RELATIVE HUMIDITY
IS ARE UP.
ARE DROPS ARE ACTUALLY MORE
EFFECTIVE ALL THE AIRCRAFT
BECAUSE IT'S JUST A FEW FLYING
WHICH READS COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN THE GROUND OF THE AIR
MUCH MORE CLEAR --
IT'S A GAME CHANGER. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THIS PROGRAM DOES
THAT OUR CURRENT PROGRAMS ARE
NOT IS IT MEASURE SUCCESS.
WITH THE THE LASER BEAM THAT CAN
ONLY BE SEEN THROUGH THE NIGHT
VISION GOGGLES THEY'RE
IDENTIFYING ANY HAZARDS IN THE
AREA THAT THAT HELICOPTER THIS
GOING BACK AND FORTH THE FIRE
MAY RUN YOU KNOW THAT THEY COULD
CAUSE A HAZARD.
IN IDENTIFIES WHERE EXACTLY IS
TO DROP WHERE THE DROP INS.
AND THEN THE STRING TOGETHER IN
YOUR ABLE ACTUALLY COME BACK TO
SAY LOOK WE'VE MEASURED SUCCESS
THIS IS WHAT WE DID THIS OF WHAT
LOOKED LIKE.
AN FOR NOT BEING SUCCESSFUL WE
REDUCE THE RISK WE SHUT DOWN IF
WE'RE NOTBEING SUCCESSFUL WE
SHOULDN'T BE FLYING IN PUTTING
PILOTS AND OTHER PEOPLE AT RISK.
THIS IS THE ONLY PROGRAM THAT
DOES THAT THIS IS OPERATING NOW
IN AUSTRALIA IT'S AVAILABLE HERE
THE STATE.
AND IS SOON WILL BE OUT SEEKING
FUNDING TO TRY TO MAKE THIS A
REALITY.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME --
AGAIN I I RUSHED THROUGH A A
PROBABLY WELL SCRIPTED
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR BACK IS
PROBABLY GONNA BE PRETTY GOOD ON
THE FLIGHT HOME BECAUSE SHE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON THIS BUT
I REALLY WANT TO GET THIS
INFORMATION OUT YOU.
YOUR QUESTIONS RELATED TO EITHER
SO THANK YOU.
EIICHIRO TESTIMONY IN THANK YOU --
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME MOVIES
FOR SENATOR DIES ASSURED ME THAT
WILL COME DOWN AND TAKE THE
COPTERS OUT FOR A SPIN CAN YOU
COME ON DOWN WE'LL TAKE KERRY.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS OR HAVING --
QUESTIONS FOR THE CHIEF.
I'M SORRY MAN.
SO RUBIO AND I APOLOGIZE HAVE TO
STEP OUT I WANT TO KNOW HOW WHAT
IS THE COST OF A ONE AIRCRAFT
YOU KNOW WHAT THE THE CONTRACT
PROGRAM. FOR THE GENERAL ATOMICS
PROGRAM INCLUDES YOU KNOW THE
TWO PILOTS YOU KNOW ON THE RAMP
A TACTICAL FLIGHT ALL THE
EQUIPMENT THE RADIO
INFRASTRUCTURE. ONE TIME
EXPENSES SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A HUNDRED FIFTY DAYS
ONE POINT ONE MILLION OF THAT IS
THE RADIO INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
A ONE TIME EXPENSE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT THAT OWNS IT'S A
PLACE.
WILL BE ABLE --
TO ON ALL THE LOCAL MOUNTAIN
TOPS TO BE ABLE TO THE CALL THE
MEASURE THAT WORK TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM.
THE HELICOPTER PROGRAMS ABOUT.
THREE AGAIN 424- HOUR COVERAGE --
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY DAYS IN
AVAILABLE TO PICK UP AND PRE
POSITION OF LIGHTNINGS BEING
FORECASTED FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHERE IS IT CAN PICK
UP MOVE AND BE AVAIL RESPONDED
EIGHT OR NINE IN THOSE AREAS.
IT BECOMES A STATE RESOURCE ONCE
IT'S IN THERE THE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU
CHAIR.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
IN THIS QUESTIONS I'M ASKED THE
THE FOLKS ARE GONNA COME UP AT
YOU KNOW AFTER YOU THERE WERE
ALREADY UP HERE.
THIS IS GREAT FOR US TO SEE THIS
STUFF BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY
POWERFUL AND ULTIMATELY WHEN
BUDGETS COM YEAH WE NEED TO SEE
THIS.
BUT I GUESS I I I'M HOPING.
THAT THERE'S AN OUTLET FOR
EVERYBODY HERE.
WITH THE STATE --
WE US AND WITH AL FIRE.
AND THEY KNOW ABOUT THIS STUFF
IT'S NOT LIKE WE'RE NEW
TECHNOLOGY OR NEWER TECHNOLOGY.
YOU KNOW I I HATE TO PUT YOU ON
THE SPOT BUT WE DID WE JUST
BOUGHT THESE OR THE CALL ON THAT
HOT.
BLACKROCK.
RIGHT IT NO YOU'RE NOT THE
DIRECTOR --
DIRECTOR POOR AND I'VE HAD LOTS
OF CONVERSATIONS FAQ HOW FAR
UTILIZED THE GENERAL ATOMICS
PLATFORM BOTH IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FOR THE FIRES IN SANTA
ROSA THE TUBS FAR SO THE RARE IN
FACT I'M VIOLATE THE TIME --
DIRECTOR PIMLOTT ANGULAR DUTY
DOWN TO SAN DIEGO SO YOU GUYS
GOT TO SEE THIS THIS IS THERE'S
NOTHING LIKE THIS THEY GOT ON A
PLANE CAME DOWN WENT WILD.
OKAY WAITED NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND AGAIN LAST YEAR WOLSEY THE
CHALLENGES.
WHEN GENERAL THOMAS GETS THE
PHONE CALL DURING THE MIDDLE FAR
SAYS YOU GOT TO GET THIS PLANE
UP THERE THERE'S NO CONTRACT IN
PLACE OR NO MECHANISM --
YOU TALK TO THE FOLKS ON THE
WALL SEE FAR THEY'LL TAKE A LOT
OF THEM THAT WERE MAKING
DECISIONS IT WAS IT WAS SEVERAL
DAYS IN DID KNOW THE PLATFORM
WAS UP THERE THEY WERE DOING
DISASTER --
ASSESSMENT WHICH WAS NECESSARY.
BUT THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY SO
THE TRICK IS TO GET IT ON
CONTRACT GET IT INTO THE SYSTEM
THAT ALL OF US TO THE MUTUAL AID
SYSTEM HAVE ACCESS.
TO YOU KNOW HOW FAR NEEDS IT
THEY PLACE AN ORDER IT'S IN THE
AIR AND ON THE WAY THE FOREST
SERVICE I'VE ALSO TALKED TO THE
DIRECTOR FAR AVIATION.
HE AND I HAD A VERY LONG
CONVERSATION WITH --
WAYNE COLSON.
WE CALLED ONE THIRTY THIS YEAR
UNDER CONTRACT TO CAL FIRE SO
WE'RE ALL WE'RE ALL VERY WELL
CONNECTED WHERE TRUST WE WERE
WE'RE TALKING A LOT THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR OKAY GREAT.
HEY THIS LITTLE OR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU.
CHIEF.
THIS TIME WE'RE GONNA MOVE --
TO PUBLIC COMMENT SO ANYONE.
IN THE AUDIENCE TO ANY QUESTIONS.
FOR ANSWERS IF YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR THE OTHER
FOR THE PREVIOUS PANEL THAT
STILL HERE.
I GUESS I HAVE THAT SAME
QUESTION SO IF ANYBODY WANTS TO
A PINE IN TERMS OF YOUR
TECHNOLOGY INTEGRATING INTO.
THE STATE SYSTEM YOU KNOW WHAT
YEAH WHAT'S HAPPY YOU'RE WORKING --
COLLABORATE COLLABORATIVELY WITH
EACH OTHER YOU KNOW WITH THE
STATE HOUSE AT ALL WORK IT OUT.
THE COURSE IS THREATENED TO THE
RESEARCHERS THERE IN THE FRONT
ROW.
CAN REPEAT THAT AGAIN.
I I'M INTERESTED IN IN THE IN
THE LEVEL OF COOPERATION WITH
CAL -- YES
CAL FIRE --
JUST IN TERMS OF IN AGREE HAVE
WITHIN THE STATE.
YEAH OF THE APPARATUS IF YOU
WILL IN IN IN IN TRYING TO
WORKED.
YOU KNOW TOWARDS A NUMBER --
ONE I PREVENTION OF FIRES INTO
SUPPRESSION OF FIRES.
FIRST AS A STATE ONE THING IS WE
ARE INTEGRATED WITH A LOT OF THE
FIRE INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TEAMS
WE GET REQUESTED TO THE FIRES.
TO PROVIDE THE ATMOSPHERIC
MEASUREMENTS AND SO THOSE DATA
ACTUALLY ARE PROVIDED TO THE
INCIDENT METEOROLOGISTS.
DATE WE'VE ACTUALLY WORKED ON
THE DETWILER FIRE WHERE THEY
CLEARED AIRSPACE SO WE CAN A
WEATHER BALLOON UP BECAUSE
AIRCRAFT SUPPRESSION --
WAS REDUCED BECAUSE THE SMOKE A
LOT OF TIMES SMOKE HINDERS THE
SUPPRESSION EFFORTS SO GETTING A
THESE TYPES OF SOUNDINGS ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT.
IT'S NOT EASY TO DO BECAUSE OF
ALL ACTIVE --
AIRCRAFT --
OPERATION SO WE INTERACT A LOT
OUR DATA GOES OUT AND WE MAKE IT
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AS WELL AS
SAME WITH THE SENATE THE STATE --
WEATHER FORECASTING MODEL IT'S
UP ONLINE ONE KILOMETER OVER THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SO YEAH.
SAME THING WITH UC BERKELEY WERE
LOOK WE'RE WORKING WITH A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT COMPANIES --
PHILANTHROPISTS AS WELL AND
SILICON VALLEY OBVIOUS IS A LOT
OF WEALTHY PEOPLE THAT CARE
ABOUT THEIR AIR QUALITY --
AT LOT OF INTERACTION ALSO FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY BOARD --
TO MONITOR CONTROLLED BURNS AND
TO TRY TO USE TECHNOLOGY TO
SHARPEN THE PERMITTING PROCESS
SEES.
OF WHEN YOU DO --
CONTROLLED BURNS JUST TO GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE --
WHEN A FIRE DEPARTMENT WANTS TO
DO A CONTROLLED BURN THEY HAVE
TO GIVE A TWO WEEK NOTICE THEY
GIVE A TWO WEEK NOTICE THE FOR
AIR QUALITY BOARD DETERMINES?
YES YOU CAN DO A A CONTROLLED
BURN BUT THEY CAN YANK THAT
PERMIT UP UNTIL THE DAY BEFORE.
AND IT SIMPLY BECAUSE THE THE
TYPE OF TECHNOLOGIES THAT ARE
USED TO BASICALLY PREDICT THESE
KINDS OF THINGS ARE SOMEWHAT
COURSE.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO WORK WITH
THIS STATE AGENCIES TO BRING THE
TECHNOLOGY TO BEAR THAT SHARPENS
THESE KINDS OF ESTIMATES THAT
PEOPLE CAN MAKE. TO THEY REDUCE
THE COSTS OF THE FIRE THE FIRST
RESPONDERS THEMSELVES SO FOR
EXAMPLE A FIRE DEPARTMENT WHEN
THEY'RE PERMIT GET YANKED A DAY
BEFORE COSTS ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
GOT DEPLOYED.
AND THEY BASICALLY YOU KNOW --
LOSE A QUITE A BIT OF MONEY SO
IS THAT KIND OF ACTIVITY THAT
WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO FOCUS IN
ON WHICH IS COST REDUCTIONS I
THINK THAT'S AGAIN OUR THEME.
THERE MANY PEOPLE THAT ARE
EXPERTS IN FIRE TECHNOLOGIES
RINSES IN THE LARGE SCALE
MANUFACTURING MAKING THINGS
CHEAP AND WORKING WITH ANY
AGENCY THAT WANTS TO REDUCE
COSTS --
ALSO.
GOING GREEN ON THE DATA
TECHNOLOGY PART THE BEEN
COOPERATING CLOSELY --
IN RESEARCH MODE --
WITH THE NUMBER OF FIRE
DEPARTMENTS CAL FIRE AND HELLO
YES AND SEE IF YOU.
ANA'S VIEW GOING FROM THAT MOTOR
HOW CAN MAY ACTUALLY BE THE
NEUTRAL PLATFORM THAT CAN INGEST
DATA FROM STATES NETWORK SOME
SORT OF DONE TO MODELING
COMMUNITY AND OTHERS.
OF INTERFACES TO THE STATE ALL.
I THINK IT ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THERE IS RIGHT NOW WE ARE BEING
SUPPORTED BY INDIVIDUAL FIRE
DEPARTMENTS BECAUSE THEY'D LIKE
TO SUSTAIN THESE TOOLS.
I THINK A PROFESSIONAL FUNDING
AT THE STATE LEVEL WOULD HELP
THESE INDIVIDUAL FIRE
DEPARTMENTS AND THE OVERALL
COMMUNITY AND THIS IS COMPLETELY
AN OPEN PUBLIC PLATFORM.
SO IN A SENSE BY FIRES HAVING
NOT GROWTH CHALLENGE OF YOU KNOW
THERE'S A USEFUL RESOURCE
PRODUCT THAT IS BEING
OPERATIONALIZE AND HOW CAN ME.
OF MADE OF RACIALIZED AT SCALE
YOU -- CAL
FIRE DISPATCH --
SENT ELENA ALSO MONTAVISTA SO
WE'RE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEM
SO THEY HAVE LIVE CONTROL OF THE
CAMERAS.
GAS AND CONFIRM NINE ONE ONE
WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH CALLOW
YES -- TO
LOCATE --
STRONG MOTION SENSORS ON SOME OF
OUR TOWERS SO THAT THEY BECOME
MULTI HASN WE'RE ALSO WORKING
WITH CINEMA WATER.
DISEASE FIRES A REAL PROBLEM FOR
WATER QUALITY AND SO WE HAVE
MOISTURE SENSORS AN ATMOSPHERIC
RIVER SO WE CAN DETECT --
AND TRY TO BETTER PREDICT AND
UNDERSTAND HOW THESE ATMOSPHERIC
RIVER SET UP AND WHAT KIND OF
FLOODING AND RESULTS GONNA
HAPPEN SO WE'RE TRYING TO WORK
ACROSS THE BOARD WITH ALL THESE
AGENCIES BUT WE ALSO.
HAVE --
PUBLIC WEBSITE THE PEOPLE CAN
GET ON AND AND CHECK THEIR OWN
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS AND THANKS
AGAIN FOR TODAY.
SO I THINK THE GENERAL TAKE AWAY
THERE'S THAT YES THERE'S A LOT
OF COLLABORATION GOING ON BUT WE
COULD DO BETTER.
DOCTORS GIVE YOU COULD --
THE BEER TEN THE QUESTION I
ASKED I THINK TO PREVIOUS PANEL.
WE HAVE A DISCUSSION ABOUT
CAMERAS THE DEPLOYMENT AND SOLD
CURRENTLY GOT EIGHTY FIVE
CAMERAS I THINK IT WAS DEPLOYED
MOSTLY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
AND THAT WE HAVE WITH THIS TO DO
NOT TO TO ADD ADDITIONAL ONE
HUNDRED CAMERAS.
I ASSUME MOST WAS CAMPUS WILL BE
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA --
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE EIGHTY FIVE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COURSE
MAYBE IT WORKS LIKE THE
LEGISLATURE DOES IN MOST THE
RESOURCES GO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
BUT SO GEN.
EDUCATE ME ON THE SUBJECT SO SO
HERE HOME.
I DO HAVE A SLIDE THAT SHOWS WE
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
CAMERAS IN CALIFORNIA NOW --
EIGHTY FIVE WHEN IN SINCE
DECEMBER.
AND WE'RE POPULATING WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE THREE UTILITIES
P. JEANNIE --
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON AND
ES DE JEANNIE. TWO YEARS AGO WE
INSTALLED CAMERAS FOR SDG AND IT
WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL PROJECTS
STILL IS AND THEIR COMMAND
CENTER --
WITH MOVED UP AND WORKING WITH
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
AND PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC SO
YES WERE POPULATING THE NORTHERN
PART WE HAVE CAMERAS IN ORTH
BAY -- WHERE
THE TUBS FIRE NUNS FIRE WERE AND --
THE CAMERAS THAT WOULD BE FUNDED
BY THIS --
ASK WOULD BE CAMERAS THAT ARE
OUTSIDE OF THE THREE MAJOR
UTILITIES.
SO THAT WE COULD POPULATE THIS
AND SO THE THE UTILITIES OF
STEPPED UP IN A BIG WAY AND HAVE
A GREAT VISION BUT THERE
POPULATING THEIR TIER.
TWO TIER THREE FIRE HAZARD
REGIONS AND THE MONEY WOULD BE
TO POPULATE THE REST OF THE
STATE WITH CAMERAS SO THAT WE
HAVE A GOOD COVERAGE OF THE VIEW
SHED.
IT IS YOUR PAIN IS A HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL CAMERAS IS --
IS ADEQUATE OR IS IT IS THERE A
A PERFECT WORLD NUMBER WE SHOULD
BE IT GETS OLDER SO WHAT WE'RE
DOING WITH THESE --
CHAIRMAN AS WE INSTALL THE
CAMERAS AND TRY TO DETERMINE --
THE VIEW SHEDS AN OPERATION AND
SO THERE'S INSTALL ASSESS THEN
FILL IN.
SO -- RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
CAMERAS TO GO IN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN SO THAT'LL ADD THAT'S
FUNDED BY UTILITIES.
AND THEN THE HUNDRED CAMERAS TO
PUT IN THE AREA WHERE IT'S
OUTSIDE THEIR OPERATION.
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT PROBABLY
THREE TO FOUR HUNDRED CAMERAS BY
TWENTY NINETEEN MIDDLE.
TWENTY TWENTY AND ON THE
ESTIMATES VARY BUT WORKING
THROUGH THE VIEW SHED AND
TYPOGRAPHY WERE ENVISIONING
PROBABLY ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
CAMERAS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
GIVEN ANSWERS WERE SO I WENT UP
TO THE THESE VIEW SHOWS ACTUALLY
ARE WAS OF ALL ON THE MAP SO HE
COULD SEE THE COVERAGE OF THE
CAMERAS AND ANOTHER THING ABOUT
THE DATA SYSTEM THAT CAN THEN
JUSTICE CAMERAS AND OTHER FORMS
OF SENSING PLATFORMS AND
INFORMATION THAT AMOUNT.
THE SENSE DATA IS THERE IS A
CAPABILITY THERE ARE TO BE ABLE.
TO FILL IN THE BLANKS WITH
DIFFERENT FORM --
OTHER FORMS OF INFORMATION CAN
BE USE AN INFORMATION COULD BE
MADE AS ACCURATE AS POSSIBLE ON
THE FLY SO THAT'S WHAT WE MEAN
BY CURATION AND CLEANING OFF
THESE DATA SETS.
AND SERVING THEM.
SO THERE IS ALSO AN ABORTION TO
USING THESE PAST FIVE YEARS AND
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE PAST
UNDERSTAND WHAT ARE THOSE
CRITICAL PLACES TO PLACE THE
CAMERAS AND STRATEGIC DEPLOYMENT
AS POSSIBLE USING THIS TYPE OF
DATA.
THANK YOU NAPA NAP I HAD YOU
KNOW THESE FIRES A KEEP SPARKING
UP IN THE SAME AREAS THERE SEEMS
TO BE.
YOU KNOW CERTAIN VALLEY'S
TOPOGRAPHY VENTURI EFFECT THESE
DROPS AND AND THEY SEEM TO BE
THE SAME IGNITION POINTS OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
SO BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THESE
AND AND TO GET EARLY THIS EARLY
INCIPIENT FIRE PHASE IS CRITICAL.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THOSE
ANSWERS AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
MAKING THE TRIP THE NEW TEST ME.
OKAY AT THIS TIME WE'LL GO AHEAD
MOVE BACK TO PUBLIC COMMENT I
SEE OUR FIRST --
PUBLIC COMMENTER RIGHT THERE.
HI CHRIS FOR SITES REPRESENTING
OPPY STREAMS ARE CALIFORNIA
COMPANY THAT MANUFACTURES AMONG
OTHER THINGS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
INDEPENDENT MOBILE OPERATING
SATELLITE EMERGENCY SYSTEM.
A SINGLE SMALL UNIT ARE HIGHLY
MOBILE CAN PUT UP ON NINE
HUNDRED SQUARE MILE
COMMUNICATIONS BUBBLE IN JUST
FIFTEEN MINUTES.
WE SUPPORT THE TECHNOLOGIES THAT
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED HERE TODAY --
THE WE WOULD POINT OUT THAT WHEN
OUR COMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE IS INEVITABLY
COMPROMISED LIKE THE HUNDREDS OF
TOWERS THAT WE'VE LOST.
THAT THE STATE SHOULD HAVE --
IN INFRASTRUCTURE INDEPENDENT
OPTION THAT CAN BE ROLLED OUT
THAT QUICKLY REESTABLISHES
COMMUNICATIONS TECHNOLOGY.
I IT'S A GAP IN OUR TECHNOLOGY
TO SENATOR DODD'S SENTIMENTS
THAT AT SOME KIND OF ONE STOP
SHOP.
NOW WOULD BE A GOOD THING.
THANK YOU.
I FIRST I SAY THANK YOU TO
CHAIRMAN DODD AND CHAIRMAN GRAY
MY NAME'S SERRA CONCERNED I'M
LISTEN TO AND ENERGY.
I'M TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE TECHNOLOGY OF PREVENTING THE
IGNITION.
SO PREVENTION IGNITION AS WE
KNOW IS THE MOST IMPORTANT STEP
IN WILDFIRE PREVENTION.
AND TO ACHIEVE THIS THE
CALIFORNIA TOADIES HAVE BEEN
USING WITHIN A POWER SHUT DOWNS.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT OUR
SOLUTION WHICH IS GREAT IGNITION
SOURCE DETECTION WHICH
IDENTIFIES GREAT EVENTS SUCH AS
SPARKS AND VEGETATION CONTACT.
THAT OFTEN LEAD TO WILD WILD
FIRE IGNITION.
THIS CAN TECHNOLOGY CAN FOCUS
BOTH ON PREVENTIVE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND POWER SHUT DOWNS
TO LOCATIONS WITH THE HIGHEST
RISK OF WILDFIRES [inaudible]
SO -- LET ME
TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
SYNDICATE THIS --
THIS TECHNOLOGIES AVAILABLE
TODAY WITH US WE ARE CALIFORNIA
COMPANY.
AND A STATE WIDE DEPLOYMENT OF
GREAT IGNITION SOURCE DETECTION
TO CALIFORNIA.
HI FIRE DETECTION THERE IS TO BE
COMPLETED VERY QUICKLY IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND WOULD
BENEFIT FIRE PREVENTION FOR MANY
YEARS TO COME.
AT ONE TIME COSTS THAT PRESENTS
A SMALL FRACTION OF THE BUDGETS
PROPOSED.
SO WE URGE THE STATE UNTIL THE
LEADERS TO PRIORITIZE SENTENCE
VAST TECHNOLOGY IN THE BATTLE
AGAINST WILDFIRES TO GET RESULTS
QUICKLY AND AFFORDABLY.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
COURCELLES --
HERE ON BEHALF OF GEO LINKS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING
THIS HEARING TODAY --
WE'VE BEEN COLLABORATING WITH
MANY OF THE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSED HERE TODAY --
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO THE
INSTALLATION OF FIRE DETECTION
CAMERAS AND COMMUNICATING THE
DATA THAT THEY PROVIDE --
THROUGH WIRELESS CONNECTIVITY --
INFO IN THE INSTALLATION OF
DOZENS THESE PROMOTE AREAS SOLAR
POWERED CAMERAS --
WE'RE WELL POSITIONED IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF A STATEWIDE SYSTEM TO
EXPAND THE USE OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND OTHERS TO HELP
PREVENT DETECT WILDFIRES WITH
FOUR TO BEING A RESOURCE TO YOU
AND YOUR STAFF AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PLAN.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR --
JOKER --
FORMER A FIREFIGHTER AND RETIRED
FAR KEPT ORANGE COUNTY FIRE
AUTHORITY SAME FIRE THIRTY THAT
THAT YOU CAN CHOOSE FROM.
FORMER WHILE AND FAR DEFENSE
PLANNER FOR THE COUNTY OF ORANGE
AND OF FOR PRESIDENT OF ORANGE
COUNTY FIREFIGHTERS FOR VICE
PRESIDENT THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
NOW FORMALLY WITH A DISTRICT
FIELD REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
FIREFIGHTERS AND AND THANK YOU
FOR HOLDING THE HEARING I REALLY
APPRECIATE.
IT WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE LORD WILD FIRE AND THE FIRE
CAMERA SYSTEM THE THE SAME
FORMER GOVERNOR TO GET YOU
INVOLVED IN THIS GOT ME INVOLVED
IN THIS BECAUSE IT'S A TOOL IN
OUR ARSENAL.
THAT WE'VE NEVER HAD BEFORE --
AS CHIEF FANTASY KIND OF
REPORTED ON THE HOLY FIRE WE CAN
SEE THAT FIRE STARTED WAS A
FIELD DRIVEN FIRE HE COULD PICK
UP HIS PHONE AND IN REAL TIME
WITH A HAND HELD DEVICE.
A TO GIVE HIM A LOT OF
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE NEVER HAD
IN THE PAST.
HE WAS ABLE TO SEE THE THE FIELD.
HE'S ABLE TO SEE THE FIRE HUSING
THE FIRE WAS A FEDERAL LAND
HEADED TOWARD STATE LAND IN A
TOWARDS RIVERSIDE WHICH IS
AGAINST USUALLY THE NORMAL FIRE
CORRIDOR.
HE COULD SEE THE TONNAGE OF THE
FIELD DEAD ALIVE RATIO AND HE
COULD GET AN UNDERSTANDING OF
THIS IS GOING TO BE A MAJOR
INCIDENT.
NOT SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
OVERNIGHT BUT OVER IN A WEEK.
SO THE INFORMATION THAT YOU HAVE
IN REAL TIME IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE NEVER HAD BEFORE.
WHAT THE DIRECTORS KIND OF RAW
RESPONDED TO IS THE AMERICAN
FIRE SERVICE DOESN'T REALLY HAVE
A LOT OF OUR INDIE WHEN IT COMES
TO NEW TECHNOLOGIES WE HAVE TO
PARTNER WITH A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS OR NOT?
NEW TECHNOLOGY INTUITIVE OUR
JAWS OF LIFE USUALLY COME FROM
PLACES LIKE NASCAR BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE MONEY FOR OUR DAY ARE
SELF CONTAINED BREATHING
APPARATUS.
COMES FROM NOW SO AND MINE
SAFETY AND THIS TECHNOLOGY FROM
THE ACADEMICS FROM.
THE FOLKS WHO SPOKE TODAY IS
AMAZING THE SECOND THING THAT
THAT TECHNOLOGY DOES BESIDES
LETTING YOU KNOW WERE FIRE IS SO
YOU COULD AUGMENT RESOURCES
PROPER RESOURCES.
SAVE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO MAKE
SURE YOU GET THE RIGHT UNITS
TYPE ONE ENGINES STRIKE TEAMS
FOR STRUCTURE PROTECTION TYPE
THREE ENGINES DOZERS HAND CREWS
AIRCRAFT ROAD RE FIXED WING.
THE SECOND THING IT DOES IS
WE'VE SEEN IT --
ALSO WELL WORN OF ARSONS ARSON
FIRES WHEN THERE'S A
DIVERSIONARY FIRE LIT.
ALL RESOURCES GO TO THAT FIRE
LIKE MOTHS TO A FLAME AND I'VE
SEEN THE CAMERA SHOW THAT
SECONDARY FIRES HAVE BEEN LED TO
TAKE ON HOMES AND THE THIRD
THING.
AND WE SEEN ON THE HOLY FIRE IN
THE CANYON FIRE ONE CANYON FIRE
TO IS REKINDLES REKINDLES ANY
CELL VIDEO OF IT TODAY.
ARE ARE A BIG PROBLEM FIRES ONCE
THEY'RE OUT IN THE AIR OF
DROUGHT THEY DON'T STAY OUT THEY
COULD SMOLDER UNDERGROUND IN OAK --
ROUTES AND SMILING FACE FOR MANY
MANY WEEKS UNTIL WE GET
MEASURABLE RAIN WHAT WE SAW IN
THE HOLY FIRE WAS A RE CANDLE
THAT NO ONE SAW.
WAS IN FEDERAL LAND ABOUT TO
TAKE OUT COUNTY ORIGIN
SURROUNDING AREAS THEY WERE ABLE
TO GET ON THE CAMERA'S ALERT THE
LOCAL FIRE OF THORNY THAT THERE
WAS A FIRE FEDERAL LAND AND
AGAIN THREATENING STATE AND
LOCAL AREAS.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE NEVER
HAD BEFORE IT'S A TOOL IN THE
ARSENAL THAT I THINK CHANGES
EVERYTHING IT'S KIND OF A GAME
CHANGER AS FAR AS OF THE
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS ON FIRES
AND SO FORTH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
I REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOU SIR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN TERRY MCHALE
WITH ERIN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING CAL FIRE LOCAL.
TWO EIGHT EIGHT ONE I'M AFRAID
HAVE BEEN AROUND LONG ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSIONS IN THE NINETIES AND
THE BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO GRAY DAVIS'S
REPORT IN TWO THOUSAND THREE THE
MAJOR REPORT AFTER THE FIRE IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE WHITE
PAPERS IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
AND TWELVE IN THIS NEW REPORT
THAT JUST CAME OUT.
THEY ALL SAY THE SAME THING
ALTERNATELY.
THAT NEW TECHNOLOGY IS GREAT WE
WANTED IT'S HELPFUL.
BUT IS THE DIRECTOR SAID ALSO.
AIRPLANES AND HELICOPTERS DO NOT
PUT OUT FIRES.
THEY CAN PROVE THEY CAN STOP
THEM IN THEIR TRACKS THEY CAN
KEEP THEM FROM SPREADING AS FAST
AS THEY WOULD.
BUT WHAT PUTS OUT THE FIRE OUR
BOOTS ON THE GROUND OUR MEN AND
WOMEN PUTTING OUT THE FIRES
THEMSELVES.
I WOULD REMIND THIS COMMITTEE
THAT CAL FIRE HAS THIRTY ONE
FEWER.
ENGINES THEN THEY HAD IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE THEY CAL
FIRE HAS FEWER INDIVIDUALS TO
DEAL WITH STATE RESPONSIBILITY
AREA THEN THEY HAD A GENERATION
AGO.
I'LL CLOSE BY SAYING THIS YOU
KNOW MISTER CHAIRMAN GREAT
QUESTIONS ON THE CAMERAS IT'D BE
GREAT TO HAVE CAMERAS EVERYWHERE.
AND WHILE THE MATH ISN'T EXACT
CAL FIRE HAS ONE ENGINE FOR
EVERY NINETY THOUSAND MILES A
STATE RESPONSIBILITY AREA.
SO AS WE PLAN ON THE FUTURE
LET'S REMEMBER LET'S TAKE CARE
OF WE NEED MORE PEOPLE WE NEED
MORE ENGINES.
IN TERMS OF THE INMATES.
THE INMATES DO THE JOB THAT THEY
DO.
BUT WE HAVE SPENT THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS EMPTY IN OUR
PRISONS.
SO THERE'S A REASON THAT WE HAVE
THIRTY FEWER ENGINE THIRTY FEWER
CREWS FROM THE STATE PRISONS AND
IT'S BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
PRISONERS WHO QUALIFY FOR THEM.
AND AS WE CONTINUE TO EMPTY
THOSE PRISONS WERE GOING TO LOSE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WE NEED
FIREFGHTERS WE NEED ENGINES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PAGE MISSED CARE PROCEDURE TEST
WELL YOU DON'T LOOK NEARLY OLD
ENOUGH TO PROVIDE THAT KIND OF
INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY.
HI MY NAME IS LIKE AND I MADE AT
THE TIME THEY AND DIRECTOR OF
TENNESSEE LEVINE ALSO PROFESSOR
OF DENTAL USE ONLINE FIRES ON
THE ONLY MASTERS IN EUROPE.
THE UNIVERSITY ALONE --
RUNNING THE COMPANY FROM SOME
DEAL WHERE THE COMPANY AT THE
BUILD THE SYSTEM FOR THE SAN
DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC ON THESE
WORKING IN THE REST OF THE
UTILITIES TO BUILD A MODEL A
NUMBER THAT THE CAPABILITIES TO
BETTER OPERATE THE NETWORK.
I'M PROVIDE A SAFER BUT EACH AND
FOR THE FOR THE CALIFORNIANS.
AS A THE KNOWLEDGE USE TWENTY
TWO YEARS OTHER THAN ALL OF YOU
YEAH I WOULD SAY THAT EVERYTHING
THAT WE PROVIDE THE OLD THAT
TOYS HOLD IT.
ALL THE TOOL I MEAN EVERYTHING
OF THE BILL SO WE SO THAT WE CAN
AGREE THEN THAT THE NO YOU SITE.
IN THE END IT HAS TO BECOME A
TOOL FOR THE GENTLEMAN THAT THEY
WERE TALKING BEFORE TO MAKE
THEIR JOB AND THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT HE THOUGHT THAT IS
HAPPENING OKAY A WHAT WE REALLY
NEED THINGS FROM USE THE SUPPORT
TO THE UNIVERSITIES THE SUPPORT
TO THE TRAINING CENTERS. TO HOP
BEARS SCIENCE BECAUSE THE
INDUSTRY WE'RE DOING THAT WE'RE
BUILDING DAY.
FUNDS UNABLE THEY WATER
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM FOR FLORIDA
STATE WITH THE TEXAS BUDDIES
COLOMBIA CHILE THAT IS WORKING
ON WHAT IS NEEDED.
IT REALLY TO HAVE TO SUPPORT FOR
THESE PEOPLE TO REALLY TRUST ON
TOOLS THAT ARE BASED ON THE
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THINKS TIME AND
THAT THIS TRAINING OKAY.
THE SECOND THING THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY IS THAT EVERYTHING
THAT WAS C. OR REGARDING.
TECHNOLOGY THE NUMBER YOU GET IS
NOT GONNA SAFE OUT ALL THE
REALITY THAT IS HAPPENING IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT WE'RE LEAVING SOON IT IS A
PLACE THAT?
WITH ALL THIS CAMERA WE'RE GONNA
SEE BURNING.
PROBABLY IN THE NEXT TWENTY
YEARS WE MAY SEE FROM ANY OF
THIS COMING US OUR LANDSCAPE
CHANGING.
SO WE NEED TO MAKE OUT WHERE NOT
ONLY A SUPPORT OUR PEOPLE HERE.
WE NEED TO SUPPORT TO OUR
CITIZENS ARE TOOL KITS TO
UNDERSTAND THAT WE LIVE IN A
PLACE WHERE THEY FIRE.
YOU FIGHT FIRE.
YOU HAVE MANY CHANCES TO LOOSE.
DO WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT WE
HAVE TO LIVE WITH FIRE AND WE
HAVE TO BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW
THE FIRE YOU CHANGED OUR
LANDSCAPE.
BECAUSE THE PROBLEM THE FIRE HAS
BEEN ALWAYS BE HERE THE PROBLEM
IS THAT WE ARE IS THEY'VE BEEN
IN IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PATH.
SO BET ON THE SOME OF THE FIRE
BUT WITH BETTER SIGNS WILL
BETTER TO KNOW YOU IT'S A GREAT
APPLICATION.
AND TO BE HONEST.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY PLANES YOU
MAY HAVE.
I COME FROM A COUNTRY WHICH IS A
SPAIN.
WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
AIRCRAFT FOR AN AREA IS SMALLER
THAN CALIFORNIA.
AND HE'S NOT ENOUGH YOU GO
THROUGH THE PATH OF PUTTING MORE
MONEY IN THEIR PLANES.
YOU WILL NEVER GO BACK AND THAT
IS NOT WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
THAT YOU'RE GONNA ONLY STUFF IT
FIRES MANY MORE PRESCRIBE
FIREFIGHTING MORE TECHNICAL
FIRES I WE KNOW WE NEED MORE
EDUCATION TO OUR COMMUNITIES. TO
DO PROPERLY ON SAFE IN EVERQUEST
SAFE ABOUT QUESTIONS WHEN THEY
ARE LEAVING OUT BY THE
ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU --
CHERRY MEMBERS MY NAME IS KATE
DARGAN.
I AM REPRESENTING A BOTH A FIRE
PERSPECTIVE IN PRIVATE INDUSTRY
PERSPECTIVE TODAY I HAVE WORKED
IN THIS FIELD SPECIFICALLY FOR
FORTY YEARS THIRTY AS A
RESPONDING FIRE FIGHTER IN
CALIFORNIA FOR CALIFORNIA.
THE LAST TEN YEARS AS A BOOT
STRAPS START UP SOFTWARE
TECHNOLOGIST.
STARTING A SOFTWARE COMPANY THAT
NOW TOUCHES THOUSANDS OF
FIREFIGHTERS AROUND THE COUNTRY.
I WANT TO SPEAK TODAY AND THE
NAME IS IN MESSAGE THAT I WANT
TO BRING TO YOU TODAY IS.
THIS IS A ROBUST PRIVATE
INDUSTRY.
OUR FIELD THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
COMPANIES WORKING HARD TO BRING
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY [inaudible]
THE ENVIRONMENT THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE A MERGING INTO WITH
SENSORS WITH SOFTWARE CAPACITIES
WITH THE ABILITY TO MOVE DATA IN
REAL TIME VIA FIRST NET.
IS AN ENORMOUSLY HUGE AND SOON
TO BE EXPONENTIALLY EXPLODING
FIELD.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SAY TO YOU
WITH ALL OF THOSE FORTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IS WHAT I DO AFTER
THE NEED FOR THE FIREFIGHTERS
FOR THE TRAINING AND THE
EDUCATION THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
NEED TO USE THESE TECHNOLOGY
TOOLS?
THAT'S A HUGE GAP THAT'S OUT
THERE THE SECOND IS AS TO
SENATOR DODD'S A SUGGESTION FOR
THE CLEARING HOUSE.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE CONCEPT OF
THE CLEARING HOUSE CAN BE
EXTENDED INTO A FUSION CENTER
SPECIFICALLY FOR WILD FIRE.
BOTH CAL FIRE AND YES COULD
BENEFIT GREATLY BY THE
AGGREGATION OF DATA TO A CENTRAL
PLACE AND THE UTILIZATION OF IT
IN THE FUSION CENTER MODEL THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH HOMELAND SECURITY
SO I'D LIKE TO JUST.
SUPPORT THAT IDEA IN EXTEND THAT
OUT.
THANK YOU.
YEAH HI --
CHAIRMAN GRAY AND EVERYONE ELSE
THE COMMITTEE --
GRAHAM KENT FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF NEVADA RENO.
I'M HERE OBVIOUSLY WITH NEIL AND
CAN SMELL TOO AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING US TO SHORE VISION
AND SOME OF THE PARTNERS THAT'S
A LIKE WITH WHY FIRE AND OTHERS
THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH RIGHT
NOW.
AND NEXT WEEK IF YOU'LL WANT TO
JOIN US BUT BOTH OF FOLKS FROM
BOTH UC SAN DIEGO UNIVERSITY OF
OREGON.
AND NEVADA WILL BE PUTTING
CAMERAS UP IN CINEMA COUNTY AND
AND THE GOOD DEAL WITH MUTUAL
AID AS THEY HELP US BUILD
CAMERAS IN OREGON.
AND THEN ALSO IN NEVADA.
AND THEN ALL PRIVATE PARTNER G.
LINKS -- TO
BE MORE GRACIOUS TO WHAT THEY
REALLY DONE AS THEY PUT OUT
EIGHTY FIVE CAMERAS.
AND LAST NIGHT WE CAME OVER FROM --
RENO THERE ARE LITERALLY CATS
AND DOGS IT NOR WINDSHIELD.
BUT THE FOLKS FROM G. LINKS WERE
UP ON **** HALL COONS HOLLOW IN
PLACERVILLE PUTTING UP CAMERAS
IN THE RAIN AND IT WASN'T.
IT WASN'T A VERY GOOD DAY.
BUT AS NEIL SAID IF YOU'RE GONNA
GET TO THAT TWO OR THREE HUNDRED
CAMERAS WE GOT WORK IN THE BAD
DAYS AND AGAIN THANK THOSE FOLKS
FROM GLX HELPLESS PUSH THAT OUT
AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
COMMITTEE.
FOR GET EVERYONE TOGETHER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER
PUBLIC TESTIMONY --
WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE CLOSING
REMARKS BY THE MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE --
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR EVERYBODY
TO PROTEST BUT A DAY AND
CERTAINLY ENJOYED PALE
DISCUSSIONS I'VE LEARNED A LOT
AND OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
LEARNED A LOT.
AND WE'LL LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE WORKING --
FOR WITH ALL OF OUR PARTNERS
HERE TO MAKE GREAT PROGRESS THIS
AREA FOR THE STATE THANK YOU
WITH THAT THE COMMITTEES ADJOURN